[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40. oh no
oh my
goodness eight of the world's best
players competing for the right to
challenge for the most coveted title in
chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
we know what that means puts the jacket
on the game is over
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
that is the genius of jan's performance
the fact that he really did make it look
easy
light queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
miss amigos
welcome to the 14th and final round here
at the 2022 feed a candidate tournament
live from the palacio de centonia you
see the fans coming in there were so
many yesterday as round 13 concluded and
jan napomneshi was crowned the champion
of these very candid sermons the
chess.com spanish team does a great job
there the players will be seated here
eventually when they make their way into
the playing all hey what's up chandler
that's our videographer and
miss amigos welcome to the broadcast
room this is a very uncomfortable
close-up of my shirt but it is great to
be joined once again by international
master elmira kripchenko grand master
daniel niradinski i am grandmaster
robert hess and almira yonda palmashi
what a historic event he's had
well first of all this is
his second win uh second consent
consecutive win at the candidates and i
wanted to say that if you make a tennis
analogy i think that he has converted
all of his break points he and saved
kiss as well that was a really good
point that when he's had the advantage
he's made the most of it when he's been
worse he survived those games and daniel
magnus carlson did a brief interview
yesterday where he called jan criminally
underrated i think that's pretty
promising uh in the sense of trying to
figure out whether magnus was telling
the truth so maybe now that jan john's
rating is a little bit closer to where
it belongs magnus will be more inclined
to play him a second time but we see the
standings there that essentially tells
the whole story that's all you really
need to know
yes five wins eight draws zero losses
perhaps the most important category no
defeats for yon napaneshi and yan you
know he was much more light-hearted
yesterday we were able to catch up with
him here in the studio so we'll replay
that interview and hear his thoughts
about if he would in fact play in a
world championship match
can you confirm right here and now that
you will play in this 2023 world chess
championship
uh sir you are organizing it yeah
why are you asking yeah well
well i mean
if i'll be given
okay and so second part of that question
who do you want to play in the world
chess championship
uh
as i say
literally i don't care
no but of course it would be quite
challenging to play magnus again yeah
and well i guess has that do you think
that impacted yourself during the
tournament did you actually just
you literally didn't care and you were
just playing for first no matter what
uh no of course i was playing for a
second yeah
i knew i knew okay i knew okay i should
like take an eye so uh ferrous and uh
won't do that brilliantly so then okay
then i fight for second place and then i
somehow okay qualify
uh
i mean it's i think these thoughts could
be quite distraught you know
destructible yeah so you just start to i
don't know
dividing the cake too earlier so it's
it's it shouldn't be like this yeah i
mean it's it's very it's very strict
it's very you know it's very tough
tournament and you know you
um
basically you make one mistake and
everything goes wrong if you
start like thinking calculating okay how
many points and so on and so on
i mean that's probably what you're
forced to do when you're like trying to
catch up someone but so that's uh that's
also the tough part of the tournament
well yonder palms he's been our leader
from start to finish here in madrid and
almira he was just much more emotional
you could see how happy he was he
finally let himself express himself
well finally we see the true young
if i may say because he's
such an interesting person he's very
well
read and you know urgitted and he has
such a great sense of humor and he well
he still has a game tomorrow today i
think yes
yes
no but what i wanted to say the good
news about this interview that at least
we have one player confirmed for the
world championship match well the
intrigue is still on in this tournament
but we are probably waiting also for the
official statement from the world
champion that's right and jan said when
we asked him he was like
magnus would be quite a challenge it's
clear that he thinks or wants to play
magnus carlson absolutely and you can
look at this from several different
perspectives i think the best one is
from the perspective of revenge jan
feels that he has unfinished business
obviously he wants to become the world
champion but he wants to do it
specifically against magnus carlson i
think this tournament has signaled to us
that he feels that he has been
unfairly judged and considered
after the last world championship people
just kind of looked at that result and
started shoveling turn on him i think
jan wants to set the record straight
very badly
yeah no it's fair and one player who
probably wants magnus carlsen to sit out
the world chess championship is hikar
nakamura and the twitch and youtube
sensation was the star of a round 13
recap
yan krishna duda gave hikaru nakamura
the fight he wanted in round 13 by
setting aside his solid petrov in favor
of a fighting night or sicilian hikaru
found a creative plan sinking a knight
into g6 and supporting it by advancing
his h-pawn
duda found an impressive rejoinder
swinging his knight back to f8 and then
on to h7 and g5 and finally to e4 where
he won a pawn in the post game
interviews hikara revealed that he
thought the position was nearly winning
and that to this point he was playing
like a brilliant computer but the
engine's evaluation was much more mixed
and things remained incredibly complex
hmm okay that's fairly surprising though
so maybe maybe i just actually
um i mis-evaluated everything that's
going on here um so i thought it was
just playing like a brilliant computer
with this knight on g6 um
then duda got a chance and he took it
striking out with b5
had duda followed up with the positional
before he would have clearly had the
better game but hikaru read duda's mind
for seeing that he would go for the
tactical pawn to d5 and then rook to c2
which allowed hikaru to play the
incredible resource bishop to d6
i mean i thought he would play b4 and
when he didn't i was shocked i once
played d5 and that's just a bit of a
lucky break that i had bishop d6 here on
the game turned just as dude's time was
low hikaru offered a scary exchange
sacrifice that had to be accepted when
due to decline hikaru seized a winning
advantage with near perfect play
including the striking king to h2 by the
time the final winning combination
arrived picaro had already put his coat
back on but look at the chair there's no
jacket on the chair which means he car
is wearing it might be
yeah we know what that means hikaru puts
the jacket on the game is over
once at carl's powerful past pawn
reached e7 protected by a pretty night
fork a dejected duda resigned
amir that was a really great game by
hikaru nakamura and something you've
said throughout the tournament from
hikaru's he doesn't really blunder much
even though he mis-evaluated the
position it was still very unclear and
he was able to better duda in a tactical
skirmish
yes and uh this was a very impressive
win and also uh such a nice illustration
of steinitz phrase i was using it before
like he said that give me a night on the
sixth rank and i will win any game he
was mostly talking i think about the
knight on g6 or e6
but this was such a beautiful game and
uh even hikaru i think that he said that
he played like a brilliant computer i
think that from a human perspective this
was a very very interesting idea so um
kudos on that yeah for sure and daniel
we know that hikar missed that night
swing from f8 to h7 to g5 but that pawn
sacrifice
or blunder whichever you want to call it
again it wasn't
that big of a problem for white and
hikaru he really played an excellent
game when duda went wrong and he did
what he had to do i mean we've discussed
many times jan schistoff's bad form in
this tournament and when somebody's in a
bad form
you know the best thing that you can do
is just get a complex position get a
position where
the price you pay for a calculation
error is very steep and hikaru did just
that he did that from the opening he
didn't play perfectly he'd be the first
to admit that but he did more than
enough to put his opponent in a
situation where ultimately
uh he made too many calculation errors
and that has really plagued jkd
throughout this tournament yeah hikaru
nakamura he punishes opponents when they
make mistakes he did that just yesterday
and we also had him here in the studio
and i'm not danny wrench i don't read
all the hikara faces but i know
happy akaru when i see one
the tournament's been a success
regardless of tomorrow so um yeah i mean
we'll see it's been it's been fun um
playing playing against these players i
mean i've been pretty competitive so i
can't complain uh overall but yeah to
have to have one today and sort of just
be able to um just give it my all
tomorrow withdrawals is obviously very
nice although i mean to be to be frank
again just like everyone else on the
planet uh i don't don't really think
second place is gonna gonna matter in
the bigger picture but nonetheless i'm
happy with my play so just one more game
and we'll see if i can uh if i can do
well
amira a very refreshing attitude from
mikara nakamura he's gained a bunch of
rating points he's playing excellent
chess and he just seems like a person
who is content who's really thriving in
the moment well
as i said yesterday he is in such a
happy place right now
i think that
he's feeling this unconditional support
by his community he is supported and
loved by his family so he wants to well
to succeed forever and once again this
is something greater than just this
tournament yeah there is indeed and his
community is very strong we've seen so
many fans come here it's the palacio de
santonia every single day asking for
autographs and photos but donya you know
he's happy he said no matter the result
today he's gonna be happy with the turn
how the tournament goes but he's a
pretty big matchup in store today in his
fight for second place yeah i mean
hicaro might be happy with where his
rating is after the tournament
regardless of how he does but let's be
perfectly frank the last game might be
the most important one in determining
how you feel after the tournament
there's this recency bias when people
look at their own tournament
performances where the last round seems
to occupy an outsized place
in how you feel on the plane ride home
and how you feel the following couple of
days so absolutely it's been a great
performance by hikaru win draw or lose
today but he certainly doesn't want that
l to dominate the second half of the
tournament well that's a great segue
into our pairings for today almirah
richard report he gets the white piece
against team over jabba at this point
you know for the rich report it seems
like he may want to go home he's very
creative though so do you think that
he's going to bring the fight to the
azeri superstar job of uh well i i just
had a look at their lifetime score and
it speaks for itself so it's tied one
one and five draws so maybe uh well
those players who do not play for
anything today that they will play it
safe although i think that it doesn't
really apply to richard reports i don't
know what does it mean to play safe in
his case and he is always very creative
in the opening so i think well i think
he even played b3 against timur so
we might see like a very uh peculiar
opening today and then uh he will define
his strategy yeah when you're looking at
richard ports games you can never know
what to predict so there are no
surprises and they're all surprises with
him and donya in the matchup between
fabiano carwana with the white pieces
and a great lifetime score against
alareza fruga how motivated do you think
fabiano will be he does have a chance at
third place which gives extra prize
money as well yeah extremely motivated i
think when you have a bad tournament and
you can't really say fabi mufabi's had
two tournaments one of them was
excellent the second one was the second
half of this tournament was really
really miserable
and when that happens like i said you
want to end the tournament with a bang
you want to end it with a win it's
easier to analyze the games afterward
you feel better about it so i think
fabi's going to be tremendously
motivated he's got the white pieces
against a farouza who has been
struggling essentially all 13 rounds so
far
and fabi's definitely going to consider
himself the favorite he has put a little
bit too much pressure on himself
throughout this tournament taking a few
too many risks but maybe with first
place in second place out of the
discussion
maybe that feeling of relief is going to
bring out the best in fabio we'll see
and of course we'll come back to the
match of dingley running hikaru nakamura
but almirah yanchez of duty with the
white pieces against jan napomashi yan
locked up the tournament second cans in
a row with one round to spare he's very
superstitious so he probably doesn't
want to lose the final game because
that's what happened in the last
candidates and then he lost to magnus
carlson well uh first of all he is
playing against young sister of duda who
has not been performing well in this
tournament but what is very interesting
about this game that jan told us himself
yesterday that he it's very important
for him not to lose this game and while
this is his second win in the candidates
if he makes a draw today he well this
his result will be even more historic
it's the best result ever in the
candidates
and i think what happened last time
actually that uh he was so overwhelmed
by his victory he knew that he's going
to play magnus carlson so they parted
straight away like right away after the
game so i think that uh they're going to
party today
well i hope i get invited that party and
of course he will talk about dingley
nakamura all throughout the round let's
remind everybody of the standings if
you're just joining us here for the 14th
round here are the standings jan de
palma she has already won the tournament
the battle for second is between ikar
nakamura and dingley ren so that
undoubtedly will be a great one as the
you see the the playing hall the players
are joining the media and everyone who
wants to take their photos so it's a
very interesting last round with dingley
ren and nicara nakamura playing for
first danya
yeah that's going to be a huge game and
ding might have a bad taste in his mouth
given what happened against timor job a
very similar situation
a game that dingley run was putting
tremendous pressure on himself to win
and not only did it fail to win but it
was clear from a very early point that
the pressure he was putting on himself
backfired it produced a lack of
objectivity bad opening play all of
which is very uncharacteristic so one of
the things i'll be looking for is to see
if dingleran might tone it down a little
bit in the opening try to
you know
complete the demands of the position
rather than playing with an agenda from
the start he's definitely going to be
nervous the pressure is definitely on
the chinese grand master but he has
delivered before and he's going to be
looking to deliver again he certainly
will be and that means after that great
breakdown of the two of you it's my turn
to go to chess.com events and vote so
first game yonder palm sheet with the
black piece against the yanchez of duda
i'm going with the draw i think that
young chessup wants us over with and
yonder palm shield he'll be happy to get
the historic nine that point in the
candidates richard report teamwork job
of i'm going with the draw again i just
don't feel like these players are hungry
in the 14th final round we see this at
super grandmaster tournaments all the
time five out of caruana with white
against alaris afruja a great lifetime
score i think fabinho would like to
leave madrid with a few rating points
i'm going with fabulous preparation over
oliver zafruja who has struggled and has
played a little bit too risky chess
and in dingley run versus car nakamura
i'm going with
a draw i think we're gonna see a
six-hour battle slugfest between these
two giants of the game but ultimately
peace will be amongst the so does
everybody else
everybody going for the conservative
safe vote yeah many predictions of draw
here and well
you can win one thousand dollars if
you're the top guesser we have dingley
ren on screen you have until move 10 to
go to chess.com event and make your
votes on site hikaru nakamura with the
black pieces he's shown excellent
preparation he said that about himself
yesterday he's been proud of his
preparation in particular with the black
pieces and dingley wren
he's a man on a mission he needs to win
this game this is essentially an
armageddon match
uh robert and i wanted to ask you do we
have the leaderboard
of our voting or not yet like who is
leading for the moment that's a great
question we'll ask our team to let us
know who's in first place in terms of
voting uh we'll maybe even actually
announce on the screen and
well someone's just saying right in
front of the camera oh god that somebody
needs to be identified and kicked out of
the tournament hall immediately
don't do that to us not when we're
watching dingley randikara nakamura and
well this is richard report with the
white pieces of teamwork java this is
dingley red versus hikar nakamura and
this game is where our eyes will be
that's maria emilianova the photographer
extraordinaire for chess.com she's been
giving so many great photographs to the
news reports and she always does an
excellent job but teamwork
[Laughter]
he's uh playing an instrument on his
nose there right i think that
you know with the black pieces he
doesn't even know what he's going to be
facing today against report
[Laughter]
very
in a ceremonial first move
played there in the matchup between duda
and nepamushi and here we see
feed a president arkady dvorkovic he's
probably going to make the move i would
guess maybe c4 for dingley ren but it's
a big question mark as to how ding will
play here against hikaru or maybe i mean
ding doesn't strike me as a first move
troll that honor i think belongs to yana
pomnishi so perhaps zverkovich's first
move is going to correspond with what
ding will actually
play and the moment of truth i think it
is in fact
one d4
then both players betraying a smile but
those smiles will be quickly wiped off
of their faces as the game is going to
begin and
dude in an uncharacteristically good
mood this tournament that's good to see
none of us like to see
players feeling miserable and suffering
so good mood all around as
the last round
begins
world chess champion it's always an
honor to be visited by the legend
vishyanan so great to see him make him i
bet you he makes that move and then he
tries to sit down he's like right i'll
play this game
yeah he's used to people making the
ceremonial first move for him not the
other way around but he has been a great
ambassador for the game he also is
running for feed a vice president along
with arkady dvorkovic so he is on that
ticket and d4 played by dingley ren
knight of six the choice of hikaru name
c4 so we'll get that nimzo unless
of course not
the king's indian defense is a hikaru
nakamura specialty but when you need to
draw a game that would not be a good
opening choice
and another big decision here for hikaru
well that question was answered quickly
transposition to the queen's gamma
declined you could play the ragazin with
bishop b4 but no the semitarash c7c5 in
the first
small surprise of the day
this is such a surprise because you know
as i remember they've played numerous
games in the slav defense where ding
almost always went for a bishop before
and the line with c5 where he had so
much space
uh so hikaru at that time i think was
feeling okay with this you know like i
just want to make a draw but here he he
goes for a more dynamic approach
yeah the c5 move is a one that's kind of
all the rage these days uh at the top
level and dingley wren clearly not
expecting it just by his facial reaction
he makes the move e3 and we should bring
this game up because there's a lot to
analyze out of the opening so we'll
bring up an analysis board to go through
some of the possibilities that did not
just happen e3 a very calm move but
typically you know e3 is a very popular
choice but you can take on d5 and
nowadays knight takes d5 white plays e4
and after knight takes c3 pawn takes
pawn takes pawn takes long sequence of
takes takes takes takes bishop b4 check
is played the bishop blocks and after
bishop d2 queen takes d2 well white has
maybe a small advantage you can see the
wind percentages off on the left-hand
side of your screen where white does in
fact have a good score in this line but
donya there's very likely a reason that
dingley roaring didn't want this
probably too many pieces traded off too
many pieces traded off and after c takes
d5 there's also c takes d4 which has
been very popular recently
uh narrow forcing line ding wants a
position and i think
that's what his main mistake was against
timur he tried to do too much at once he
tried to get an advantage and a
complicated position he tried to do all
of that in three moves
right now he's got to be very careful
because this is what happened against
timur he played that move knight a6 and
ding's response to that was inadequate
so maybe taking a little bit longer here
to remember his preparation making sure
that he's not playing anything over
ambitious that's what ding has to do
here but
maybe a little surprise for hikaru as he
retracts his bishop to d3 yeah bishop d3
maybe catching a car off guard amira
this resembles a queen's game but
accepted at this point so stylistically
who would you say
the start of this game favors i know
it's very early but these players do
have quite different styles
well they do have quite different styles
but i don't think this position caught
hikaru off guard because he plays so
many openings and once again i've
studied quite a few of his games he uses
the queen's gambit accepted from time to
time
and i also play uh this opening plate
for many many years with blacks so
the typical move here would be simply to
take on d4
c takes d it takes d then you simply
develop your bishop on e7 and we've seen
actually numerous games where white has
the bishop on b3 or on d3 it simply
comes to the same
position although in this one there is
always a possibility for white to
sacrifice the d4 pound when you play for
example if you cast on castle
you can play i think queen e2 here or
and sacrifice the pawn on d4
and sometimes the computer will consider
this position to be well
a little bit advantageous for for black
but then it changes its mind
yeah because white is already aiming
towards the king side this bishop coming
to g5 rook to d1 so it's an adventurous
pawn sacrifice but that can be justified
i agree with you i'm here the normal
move would be rookie one anyway so you
don't have to sacrifice because at that
uh in this position you cannot take on
d4 because there will always be bishop
h7 right just to show that that even
before here same idea right and anytime
there are pieces in line with each other
and one piece in the way thinks about
what happens when it
moves and bishop b5 is checked you win
the queen so the same thing after castle
it just would have been the h7 square so
good point and well b5 was hikara's
choice he's lashing out over here on the
queen side donya
this is interesting now our incredibly
hard working team
has reported to us that the position
before
b5 before b5
has
occurred several times it's not
particularly popular but it occurred for
the first time in a game from 1913
black in that game was edward
lasker not emanuel lasker but edward
lasker was also incredibly strong he was
an im
now hikaru seemed to be taken aback by
b5 uh by bishop d3 but responded pretty
quickly and ding now changes the
structure once again so we won't get an
iqp instead we'll get a symmetrical
structure on the queen side after b2b4
which i think is going to follow
followed by bishop b2
and it would be a mistake just to say
that this is totally equal because it
looks symmetrical the fact that white
has an extra tempo in these positions
and i know you'll back me up on this can
actually be incredibly important
and also sometimes you want to have the
knight on d7 and the bishop and b7 this
position so you could follow up with
knight b6 and rock c8 and knight c4
right because if we just look at the
pawn structure here the c5 and c4
squares can be quite vulnerable it's a
good point elmira and the bishop one b7
would like to be unopposed so the same
thing goes for white this knight would
like to be on b3 in many positions so
that when you play rook c1 you put a
knight on c5 that would be nice but b4
has in fact been played by dingley wren
and unlike in his game against team over
java this time b4 is a good move comes
at uh right at the bishop the bishop has
to move costing black a tempo and as
this game continues we likely will see
something where both sides end up
castling and then white
is a tempo ahead right white gets has
the first move so you have
i guess that half move ahead here and
this bishop on d3 though that i think is
a really nice piece sometimes can cause
problems over here on the queen side and
don't be surprised if white ever makes a
move like knight to e4 you probably
don't want to trade queens but in the
event of the nitrate here we already see
some pressure down the queen side that
can be annoying for black to deal with i
do think that dingley wren will avoid a
queen trade amira if you trade queens
you probably feel like your opponent has
better chances to make that draw and all
hicara needs is a draw i agree with this
but on the other hand i have
so much experience in the queen's gambit
accepted where white takes on c5 and
trade queens very early and this is
actually a very unpleasant position for
black to play you um you really need to
feel the
subtleties of these positions
just in order to make a draw and there
are only two results possible
yeah no it's true black is deprived of
any counter play
in this line
and i think a car you know he's happy
with the draw as a possibility and we're
going to go back to the
bird's eye view here just because we
have two pretty much identical games in
the top left and the top right so
slight differences there where black is
castled in the top right and the top
left the bishops on e6 and the king
hasn't
made its way over
from the center of the board but they
just deviated they were following each
other and fabiano caruana i mean he's
been essen these kind of positions all
tournament and even in previous ones uh
similar to how he beat hikaru nakamura i
mean not the same exact position but
from the stems from the same line yeah
it's not a surprise that this has
occurred in caruana farouja fabi plays
these openings this opening with both
colors he understands the structures
very well so
uh a very sensible choice in the last
round
you want to play something that you're
comfortable with
and farouza you know he's definitely a
lot less experienced on the black side
of the berlin then fabios with both
colors so he better have done
uh his research in these positions
because otherwise you can easily slip
into a bad position on the top left or
job of report they're following a very
similar line but for now we can focus on
the fabio game yeah and i was actually
going to ask you elmira that i think
that sometimes players can assume that
equality is easy to achieve because you
look at the engine it says three
different moves leave the position equal
for black you're like okay i can figure
this out but it's much deeper than that
and fabiano who's been playing the white
side of spanish structures for such a
long time he has a wealth of experience
and for others of russia who's only 19
years old we've seen in this tournament
where he's like the engine says i should
be doing okay and then as soon as he's
out of his prep that's where he may
struggle compared to the more veteran
players in the field yeah this is a very
important point because when
you analyze at home and the engine gives
in various lines that the position is
equal the most important factor then and
this is the player who will make a
difference the player who knows all the
plans and uh
which piece to trade like how to uh
change the pound structure how to
improve my pieces and actually we are
now concentrating on the game between
fabiana corona and uh larissa but do you
it's almost a remake from when we look
at both games of rapport caruana because
they well
the plans differ now then that's why i
think uh fabio went for this line once
again
yeah and he
had an interesting game against rapport
and from the black side in that one and
he's experiencing both colors and done
it that actually probably makes it even
harder for ali raza because not only
does fabiano has he prepared from the
white side for today's game that with
that experience from blackside he knows
what is uncomfortable
yeah and what else might be
uncomfortable is the fact that he's
already taking a good chunk of time
uh deciding how to defend the e5 punt
now
as far as i know this is still a very
prominent theoretical position this has
occurred many many times
and there are actually four or five
viable ways that have been
essayed to defend the e5 pawn you can
play f7 f6 which is sort of the
classical move you can play rookie eight
if you don't want to push any king side
pawns queen e7 even bishop c5 to d6 in
some of these positions is not out of
the question to pave the way for the c
pun to push forward to c5 and clamp down
on the center so a big menu here for ali
reza the fact that he's taking as long
as he is tells me that his preparation
for this game
might not have been particularly
extensive you might have just decided on
the opening and then kind of said you
know screw it i'm just going to play it
yeah it could be surface level and
actually we will maybe take a look at a
few variations here because the move f6
seems very natural you defend a pawn
with another pawn you create a pawn
chain but often times white heads write
for this f5 square because when you play
f6 you don't really want to also play g6
in these positions so uh here you can
think about c3 and d4 as another option
you can think about knight h4 king h1
pawn f4 type of breaks we've seen this
in other games in this event so i think
for ali reza he's trying to figure out
how is this game going to continue he
knows that rookie 8 pawn f6 queen e7 all
these moves are fine for him but they
take on different trajectories and he
has in fact played the move f6 and
almira
he's spending his time in the opening
it's only spent 10 minutes
but we've seen his time management
throughout the tournament where he often
can't afford to use minutes unless
there's something he needs to calculate
well maybe this actually illustrates the
lack of experience that he has
of playing
these high level tournaments but i
wanted to come back to this position and
especially uh well not only the move of
six
but it was such a fascinating
explanation given by dania because we
always tell i think the beginners and
players who learn the game like you
should always protect your pieces but
let's have a look at this moment after
knight c4 as daniel said you have
four
fairly
equal parameters yes yeah the very
elementary tactic not there i'll do it
better this time there checkmate and the
night so this is why the piece is
protected but sorry i'm gonna go ahead
of course so like after knight c4 you
have so many alternative and how do you
actually make a choice like do you bring
your bishop to d6
but then you think this bishop is quite
active on c5 so maybe uh well this is
not the best choice if you play f6 you
should always ask yourself a question
but this move f6 in the long term we can
uh
my king and well i worry about the king
safety is it better to make rook 8
which is probably more flexible so you
can go
uh knight f8 knight j6 96 or bring your
bishop f8
to f8
back to the defense and you also have
queen seven but you ask yourself should
i use the queen at this moment the most
valuable the most dangerous piece and to
defend upon
so this from this point of view this
position is extremely interesting yes
it's really not an easy choice when
you're sort of looking at this with
fresh eyes you haven't prepared it super
deeply and they all take a different
course so it's true and f6 is a very
natural move but as you're pointing out
i'll mirror this king for example c3 you
already have to look out maybe queen b3
will be a nuisance because of the
pressure on b7 and the king on g8 being
uh in line d4
is just a nice move to play anyway so
i think for fabiano where he can win an
extra 24 000 euros if he wins this game
that's quite a lot to play for
yeah
i mean that's crazy actually for one
game and i'm quite sure that fabby is
aware of that
and
he's taking this game very seriously
from every perspective and i really
want to to make it clear
that i'm not overstating the case when i
say that the last round leaves a major
you know good or bad taste in the
player's mouth as we see the king
sliding over to h1 you pointed out the
plan with f2f4
fabi not mincing his words at all but
winning this game would go such a long
way toward making him feel better about
this tournament as well he's going to be
upset
regardless of what happens 24 000 euros
40 000 years it doesn't matter he was
tasting first place after the first half
but in the sense of helping him feel
better and helping him analyze the games
more objectively winning the last round
is always critically important
for players of any level in any
tournament but especially here it's true
and you know 500 would love to win
elmira alaiza would love to do the same
but when you're met with this move king
h1 which you know exactly what fabian is
doing he wants to play this move f4 at
some point but instead of moving his
knight
to h4 which looks very logical to get
the knight over here and maybe to f5
perhaps five is saying i'm not quite
certain where the knight should go yet
in fact based on what you do alireza i
might choose a different direction for
my knight maybe the knight will come to
d2 or somewhere else so king h1 it's not
exactly hiding his intentions but he
can't play f4 next move so it's kind of
a funny decision well he is not
revealing them at the same time as you
as you said king h1 is a very flexible
move
um so he's not cross-examining i think
eliria zafaruja yet but one once again
if the rook was on e8 then it would be
possible for black to play knight g6 and
knight to f8 and knight g6 right and to
control the f4 square
um
yeah your points and then e6 or g6 would
be very nice
trying to take control of f4
also there would be a possibility to
bring the bishop and the 6 and to take
on c4
change the white structure yeah black
needs to figure out this development and
i mean just the way we see all there is
of thinking here
donya
it it does kind of feel like fabiano he
hasn't won the opening battle from sense
that he's much better
but it does seem like already is truly
thinking not recalling preparation but
really trying to work hard to figure out
what he should do here whereas fabiano
you know make the move like king h1
unless you've studied this before yeah
and i'd point out two things um first of
all unrelated but
we know that perugia
has had this position before and an
online title tuesday give me sicaro
which was over a year ago back when
hillary has played online chess
i don't know if he remembers this i
think it's a move i don't think he
remembers that this exact position has
occurred in his games before and that's
exactly the point he's just not
experienced in this type of position
and remembering your preparation in the
anti-berlin is about as hard as
remembering it indeed italian what's the
problem you might ask well unlike let's
say a night or
there are a thousand move orders you can
play king h1 on move six seven eight or
nine you can play bishop e3
and and black has different moves
against each of white's options on each
move so it's virtually impossible to
remember all of your preparation these
players will be the first to tell you
that and for that reason in such
openings experience and general
understanding of the ideas becomes
critical and my worry is that ali reza
just because of his age and because of
his lack of experience in these
positions
doesn't have the requisite knowledge
general knowledge of anti-bullying
positions to feel comfortable i think
that's reflected in his body language
but i would reserve my judgment for
another few moves because objectively
we're not arguing the position is equal
objectively that's clear
but alireza needs to be very precise and
i think the next few moves will
demonstrate to us whether he can
overcome his discomfort and lack of
experience and come up with the right
plans and ideas
yes i agree with you daniel completely
what i wanted to add is that uh now the
methodology of training uh well has uh
sh well changed dramatically because
before you were playing very little
games you were analyzing them now you're
playing like
millions of games and the experience
comes and the feel for the position
comes from uh well from those
tournaments but i'm pretty sure that
fabi knows that uh ali reza first played
this game even if it was a blitz game so
now you have to allow to analyze like
the amount of games that you have to
analyze and to prepare for your opponent
is also
very much bigger
but that's where fabi actually makes his
difference he spots he spots exactly the
position where he thinks that his
opponent
well doesn't master or doesn't have a
feel for it and he goes exactly for for
this line yeah and i think that
fans and people who don't quite get a
first-hand look into how top players
prepare
fabio has had this reputation and i
think it's you know not fair what people
say where they say he just memorizes
opening theory and that's why he's good
this position that we have in the top
right with algorithm thinking it's not
about memorizing anything because it's
not concrete there's no tactical
sequence that if alvarez doesn't know it
ends in checkmate it's a position that
as you were saying amir he feels that he
is way more comfortable and he's just
going to try to outplay other ways from
here so as someone and you know full
schools who has worked with fabiano
before it's what often these top players
do is not just have files with 50 moves
but they say this looks interesting
maybe i should try it and my opponent
may not expect this exact sequence and
then we'll have a game and i feel like i
have the better knowledge and better
background so we will keep an eye out on
this game as i'll raise the fridges on
the clock but all eyes as per usual are
going to be on dingley wren versus zakar
nakamura not much has changed there we
had that position
on our analysis board so when ding
makes a move we can get back into it but
why don't we go to the bottom right yan
na pam mashi with the black pieces
against young chest of duda because jan
is spending a lot of time and throughout
the tournament we've talked about how
yana pomschi he's typically a speed
demon in the opening he's always ahead
in the clock but he doesn't look so
comfortable as he tries to avoid a loss
in the last round after winning the
tournament already so which petrol was
it
yeah we'll go back and analyze here as
we got into pom she leaves his chair his
jacket is alone but we see after e4 e5
we have a petrov and daniel this move d4
which hasn't played at the highest level
i can think of a karwana grisha gamers
yeah this was all the rage at some point
maybe 15 years ago
but the way the duda plays this is very
interesting after knight 64
bishop d3 was a given until
about five seven years ago
when
this move detakes e5 very curious
looking move started to become a little
bit more popular it's still a sideline
and there was no way that nepali should
have expected this i don't know if duda
has played this before but even if he
has you know
he's probably played four other lines
against the petrov
now jan has already faced several
surprises in the petra of this
tournament and he's overcome them
successfully so he responds with d5 and
you get this very interesting structure
where white has this thorn in black side
that pawn 95 controlling a lot of
importance d6 f6 making it harder for
black to develop successfully
but it's still largely a positional line
and after knight bd2 trying to smoke
that knight out of e4
this is a moderate move if i've ever
seen one queen d8 to d7
try explaining that to someone who's
played chess for five days yeah and i
think the easiest way to explain the
show what happens if the queen stays on
d8 even if you make a move like bishop
c5 which looks very nice attacking the
pawn after knight takes e4 pawn takes
for a queen takes d8 check the king has
to take on d8 and then white goes knight
to g5 forking two different pawns over
here so queen d7 almira what an
interesting opening line but it does
make a lot of sense once you explain why
the queen on date is bad well it does
make a lot of sense indeed uh what i
wanted to show that in order to grasp
the essence of this position is
that
why black doesn't want to take on d2
because it will be like almost an easy
trade but then you simply take with the
bishop let's say you you will play c5
then
c3 is a natural move then you and it's
six let's say you put your bishop on d3
then you castle and
you launch an attack yeah your bishops
are staying in the correct direction
towards where the black king is going
and this pawn e5 that danny mentioned is
a really big thorn in black side so
this is normally the position that black
should avoid right when playing this
line right and so that's why queen d7
which hasn't played in a car wanna game
from 2018 and vitsugov was was playing
carwan and vichy was one of yonder
palmish's second so uh interesting to
note that it's always important because
when one of the trainers for a player
plays a line there's that influence and
so donna with the opposite colors yes
yeah vegetables
but uh five and a quarter the world's
leading expert on the pet trough at
least he was in 2018. so vichygar is one
of the world's leading experts on the
french by the way if you want to learn
the french as
for black i don't know why anybody would
want to ever do that but if you belong
to that category then look at vitrigov's
games that's 100 true so in this one
queen d7 odd move white plays bishop d3
and then black does not take on d2
because almer was just explaining that
that's exactly what white wants so
instead the knight backs up to c5 trying
to get this bishop white says no
and then we see the knight go back to e6
which if you remember dingley wren the
black piece against takara nakamura a
knight blockading a pawn is usually very
good because it peers over that pawn
into enemy territory so oh
sorry clicked ahead but to just to get
back to the live position that after
knight e6 castle bishop v7 normal move
rookie one castle knight f1 good
re-maneuvering of the pieces by yon
chistop because after c5 bishop d3
almira you were talking about a king
side attack and rook d8 knight g3 and
black plays the move g6 so white's
pieces all aiming towards this king side
and jan putting all his pieces towards
the center so this is a really
interesting battle and both
yes
it's actually a very thematical maneuver
what i wanted to
point out is especially for our viewers
whenever you have this type of structure
and the knight is only six then you
should most definitely aim for knight of
one knight g3 and uh for the fy
square right because
you've blocked your pieces from
capturing an f5 and that's exactly why
yon played g6 and i guess we should say
duda in the palm machine just to avoid
any confusion although it's jan chistoff
he doesn't go by jan so either way the
move c3 played by jan chistop and this
is a very important move because now he
can keep his bishop on d3 and what i'm
already thinking is let's go alpha zero
style h4 h5 i'm thinking let's go tall
style knight of five oh my goodness if
we get a knight f5 that would be awesome
and
i'm pretty sure i picked this game to be
a draw but looking at yonda palmishi's
face here and how young of duda seems
very ambitious i could see either player
winning this game he promised that they
would not party all right
he's like should have taken another
advil this morning
but knight c6 is such a natural move in
this position i think jan will make it
rather quickly what is he afraid of
after knight c6
yeah i mean knights i think i think it's
not so much that he's afraid of
something i think
he might be seriously considering
another canada move
which is c4 followed by d4 now c4 is
very anti-positional in and of itself
because you're weakening
the d4 square but if you follow it up
with d4 you're forcing a bunch of trades
i think jan invested a little bit of
time in that ultimately decides against
it and he just did in fact play
the most natural move knight b8 to c6
another sympathy and duda continuing to
play instantly wow robert
alpha zero hess zero due to zero but we
have a pawn on h4 again yeah how many
times is tournament as white played h2h4
before move 20. and it's been a lot and
i just wanted to point out that this
idea by black i think does equalize the
game because you're gonna force some
trades and then white doesn't have as
many attackers and if the bishop instead
had gone to f1 to make the move
d4 less possible because if you move the
d-pawn c4 hangs well your bishop isn't
staring at the black king so these h4 h5
ideas don't have as much power behind it
but amira i know you're enjoying this
game here we have knight c6 and h4 by
jan chisoff who's in his preparation
he's playing so quickly he's up 20 plus
minutes he wants to be the only player
to beat napoli in this event well i
think that even here in this studio we
have this battle the clash of the
generations you know i'm going for a
more positional approach and you're
going for the h4 but i think that here
um jan should definitely take into
consideration
dania's move c4
especially after knight c6 and h4
because this move h4 is not very useful
in the end game would not be very useful
unless it's on h6 already
[Laughter]
so maybe he should
take advantage of the situation and to
exchange a few pieces here c4 and d4
afterwards and this is also
this follows the principle of striking
in the center against play on the flank
so
this is definitely on jan's radar i
think
but
it must be scary for him to face
this amount of preparation
yeah this looks
quite nervous i mean he looks kind of
unhappy
with the position he's looking to the
side and he's trying to figure out what
to do here because c4 is a very
committal choice because if this bishop
goes back to f1 then the d4 square is
whites for the taking i could play
bishop e3 perhaps and take over the
square for my pieces so jan does play c4
doesn't even think that much he feels he
understands the position and that's how
yonda pomacy has played throughout the
tournament he has been confident he has
had a few shaky games three that i can
remember two against carwana one with
the black piece against ikar nakamura
otherwise he's been large and in charge
and right now against yanchez of duda
who's moving instantly i mean literally
not even hesitating
here in eight
a5 what is
see that's a mysterious move it's not a
bad move so we should be very clear our
reaction we don't know if it's a bad
move well our reaction's not because
it's a blunder i mean we see the
evaluation bar it changed a little bit
but not too much so maybe an inaccuracy
but a5 elmira what what's he thinking
well maybe there is something in the
variation after d4 can we get back to
the position before the move f5 we
didn't analyze so maybe there is some
nuance in in this line
do you want to give the e4 square
potentially no but let's say c takes d4
you cannot allow it anything else and
let's say night
which night i don't know i couldn't
decide
uh
okay let's let's see i made your
decision i want to force a decision uh
on your like on white's part because
the g5 square is protected
okay so what do you do here knight e4
yeah i like this
with the idea of playing knight f6 and
someone you could basically force the
queen training knight takes c2 and then
queen d3
i i'm struggling to figure out in which
universe
like a5 actually helps
oh
no there's no way i actually don't
understand a5 i'm really trying hard to
justify this choice are we sure that's
what he
yeah that was replayed can we get a
verification on the dgt here because a5
is
extremely surprising i would understand
b5 yeah maybe to protect the pawn and go
b4 or d4 but a5 even a6 i would
understand more to be able to meet some
sort of bishop a4 with b5
is there some incredibly deep concept
here that we just
you know we're not in the candidate so
we don't understand it just
the only explanation this i can find
that he wants to wait for a move before
playing d4
can white make uh well a useful move in
this position that you can then he will
try to
to make this line work beautiful camera
thank you so much to our great
production team getting us a close-up
here of the board
and did nepo say yesterday to stop this
a and h pawn nonsense moves thank you
darth von trier i guess he's stopping
the h pawn nonsense with his a pawn
nonsense but h4 made sense
a5 is looking a little uh more random
dart one tweeter this is such a creative
name
yeah i should definitely uh go to the
chat more often
i have an idea which is that the move
rook a8 to a6
might come in handy in certain positions
because
we we've seen in several games like the
rook on a2 or on a7 guarding the seventh
rank maybe jan has judged that it's
important to guard the sixth rank
i'm not sure exactly against what or
against which move specifically but that
could be something
uh to take into consideration
i'm kind of buying it because h5 is such
a clear idea that at some point g6 can
be yeah yeah yeah some sort of sacrifice
on g6 the thing is black also has two
knights on the sixth rank so for the
rook to actually
you know bear some weight the knights
would have to move away
so this is like
one of the deepest moves we've ever seen
in in history
i like elmira's explanation that
he's waiting a5 says you are gonna have
to do something concrete and then i can
respond kind so there was something
about d4 and i think it was giving up
this e4 square that he didn't like
because even here in 94 let's say you
start with this move
uh that would have been an option for
yon chistop and with a knight coming to
f6 if you take on c3 that you can just
you know try even trade queens and just
take back with your pawn and say this
night looks a little silly back here so
maybe this is what
nepal she was avoiding and look at young
shishtev this was definitely a surprise
not only for us but for him as well
and now he started to think for the
first time on the first time
off in this game and he was definitely
prepared i think against d4
wow day five came as a huge surprise
yeah that's was not one of my main canon
moves i'm liking it more the more i let
it sink in and we're going to let
yanchester do to sink into a think here
because a lot has changed now in the
nakamura dingley ren game it wouldn't
seem like much but this move f5 played
by ikaru he
made a decision like this against
yanchez stop duda in a very different
position but it was a pawn push that
ended up being one that he kind of
regretted and now f5 after the trade of
pieces that just happened we were
leaving off of this position anyway
knight e4
trades and then f5 kicking this bishop
off of e4
this
a very symmetrical position
that's probably pretty good news for a
car nakamura who only needs a draw
yeah i mean hikaru is playing with
supreme confidence
i'm quite sure that he's out of
preparation
but i think he can smell it i think the
ding has fundamentally changed his
strategy if you compare this to the
rajabov game where he
started taking a bunch of risks in the
opening and he gave up the bishop air
here he's going for something
very
quiet relatively symmetrical and white
is not risking here i mean this is
essentially a two result game
and it's clear that if we're talking
about one side being a little bit better
we can only talk about white being a
little bit better because black has a
target on e6 and white doesn't and
that's it
so bishop c2 and bishop b3 is a pretty
straightforward obvious plan that ding
might want to implement i don't know if
there are any other enticing candidate
muslim maybe bishop b1 and bishop a2 is
something to consider very similar
but
i think hikaru senses that he's a couple
of moves away from equalizing and if
black equalizes here it's basically a
draw
well i feel that this move is a very
responsible one not only uh
black creates a weakness on a six but
there is another factor the e5 square
so if dean can exploit this uh he will
certainly be better i agree with danya
uh that there is not that much in this
position but i think that
the draw is uh
not that easy here to obtain
yeah because bishop c2 bishop b3 knight
why he needs to play a five this is a
typical move once again when you don't
have the knight on f6 in order to parry
all these threats uh like bishop h7 or
queen c2 or the mates so
and
maybe there was
a concrete threat of playing knight d4
and exploiting this pin here immediately
all sorts of threats and i think people
assume that trading queens means you're
heading towards a draw but after queen
takes d1 instead of f5 after rook to f
take d1 now i have an open file so you
have to watch out for rook to d7 and
after rook d8
as elmira was just saying i can make a
move like 95 or knight to d4 to try to
take advantage of this pin here and
white
is not better here right this actually
looks like it's a pretty stable position
for black but hikaru he lashes out
instead with f5 still maintaining the
balance and i think the one really
important thing here is let's say we
trade queens
and i do the same thing with rook to d8
and you put your bishop on b3 black can
simply put the king on f7 because e5 and
g5 are both under black's control there
are no annoying knight hops here and so
with the next one being bishop f6 it
feels like black is just about ready to
trade all the pieces off the board and
if that's the case then dingley wren who
we just saw glance up
from the board that means his winning
chances are not going to be particularly
high then there's just perfect
calculation on hickory's behalf yeah
yeah he's making this look completely
innocuous another asymmetrical factor in
this position we cannot ignore
is the black has the pawn lever a6a5
which
you know if a bunch of pieces are traded
could be a problem for white because the
rook on a could get really active
white logistically doesn't really have
the same thing because the b4 pawn is a
lot
more poorly defended so a4 is a lot less
likely and this happens because the
knights are not symmetrically placed i
mean there's a knight on c6 and a knight
on f3
and the knight on f3 is a good piece in
its own way it's guard you know it's
it's aiming for e5 it can go to d4
but the knight on c6 you know can also
have its moment in the sun
right and it's not merely a passive
piece it's not just defending e5 as
you're talking about it can help with
this a5 move and the bishop on e7
staring at the queens that helps and
bishop f6 will force pieces off the
board like that's the problem for ding
right now is a lot of hikaru's moves
force pieces off and without too many
pieces remaining it feels like hikaru's
task will not be as challenging as
diglern would hope there is one maneuver
that i wanted to try while i still have
the time is to play knight e1 here 93
and uh play knight c5 but maybe um
you will simply play a5 here or try the
rooks and not trade rooks it's not a
good idea also a5 immediately because
you have to challenge this idea right
amir was making a broader point here
that if in one move this knight could
just go right to d3 and try to get to c5
that's how white plays from vince or to
f4 right this e6 pawn is such a target
so the knight on f3 is actually
misplaced let's get it here or over here
i know that second arrow seems to make
no sense but that's how you have to
think about knight maneuvers you're like
where's my realistic dream square c5
looks good let's get the knight to d3
and up and over but a5 happens so
quickly and
i mean i'm looking at this and for
dingley wren
maybe he's looking at third place prize
money and that's important to him
because you know you would think that
it's win or go home time he has to win
this game
to have a chance at a world champion
match if in fact magnus declines so
the gamers for java was very bad
but
maybe he need to play something riskier
than he's doing now it's just too
symmetrical he car's opening preparation
has been stunning this term i think we
cannot ignore that like he he's taken
people out it's not easy just to
you know take dingler run out like this
with black and in particular i think the
very astute decision hikara made was on
move eight like bishop d3
was maybe a move that he had seen before
in passing but probably a little bit
surprising and i think the chinese
grandmaster was hoping for an iqp
structure because at least that would
have guaranteed some sort of asymmetry
some sort of intrigue and i can almost
guarantee that b5 was very annoying it
was a very annoying move to see for ding
because now you can't avoid a
symmetrical structure
now you have to aim for a very small
advantage with precise moves and icaro
has shown
you know virtually flawless play
in simple positions and in slightly
worse positions this tournament and
maybe here was the big moment for
dingley red because queen e2 suddenly
you get the queen off the d file so you
can slide your rook over we're not
claiming that white is much better but
with the white king already castle and
you just have that half move because you
you've gone first in this game but what
happened here after
bishop b2 queenie two even here was an
option queen two as well so maybe knight
e4 was hasty but even it was hasty but
it just feels like a position that is
too symmetrical like you need to play
for a win and dingley wren did beat
yanches of duda from a pretty quiet
position we know how capable dingley ren
is of
playing precise chess while his opponent
flounders but hikaru throughout this
event we keep talking about this he
hasn't made blunders inaccuracy sure
everyone does that but hikaru's losses
his loss to 500 karwan in the first
round
castling wasn't inaccuracy and then
fabinho played a pretty flawless game to
win and then against timor java rajaba
deserves a lot of credit for picking an
opening that hikar didn't quite feel
comfortable with and then when java
stole that a5 pawn hikart couldn't quite
get back in the game but there were no
huge blunders like not just a tremendous
oversight that changed the evaluation
from you know even to like plus three or
something like that so hikaru he's not
blunder prone he's playing a position as
we get back to the game that is entirely
symmetrical only difference between the
pawn f5 but when the queens come off the
board this king safely walks out to f7
and
i'm just not even seeing how dinglery
can hope to play for a win maybe he'll
play bishop takes c6 here not a move you
want to play but you need to win so at
least let's get a material imbalance of
sorts well what impresses me the most is
that i think that uh in the beginning of
his career this would be the position
that he would dismiss immediately you
know because it's symmetrical you create
a small weakness you don't control the
e5 square but it also shows uh how
strong hikaru is right now that he
understands the
the range of the positions that he could
play actually is
very broad and
he
is also very confident and he thinks
that i will hold it easily
and he looks to be doing just that this
is our marquee match-up of the round and
these two players well they are
absolute superstars in the world of
chess dingley wren currently the number
two raider player in the world number
one from china and as we look from top
to bottom whereas dingle has never
beaten nikaru but i'm looking at that
last column because
wins against yonder pontici now that
used to say wins against magnus but
because neither of these two players can
possibly play magnus for the world
championship yonder ponchi whether they
play magnus or one of these two
they both have beaten yana a couple of
times and a bigger question maybe a more
important question and i'll hear i'll
start with you
if magnus carlsen
declines his participation in the world
championship match
who's a tougher opponent for jan de
palma machine
who is the tougher more interesting than
well i think that hikaru nakamura is a
very tough opponent right now especially
that yan uh he's beaten ding in this
tournament with black and i think he
understands him better now as a player
but hicary he's
fearless
donna would you say the same i i
actually completely agree i would say
you know if i answered in a vacuum you
know without factoring in recent
tournaments i would i would say ding you
know he is 2800 plus for a reason
he's a terrifying opponent for anybody
aneesh he said that ding might be the
toughest opponent for magnus out of
anybody right now
but i agree with omir i mean hikaru at
this level of confidence
i mean igar was 28 15 i think tons of
people forget that he was well over 2
800 and and this was the kind of hikara
that we saw
in you know 2011 2012 the kind of hikaru
who just swept people off the board of
black yeah his opening repertory was
different back then he played the kings
indian that was a little bit more
possible although certain commentators
still trying to survive in that opening
now he's a little bit more positional he
maybe takes a little bit less risk but
the confidence is back
the unbelievably sharp calculation is
back and nobody wants to face him right
now
yeah hikaru nakamura he is an a plus
form he went to the fide grand prix
where he was a
nominee
he won
the
the events he was earning his right here
based on that performance in the
candidates he's plus two right now
great showing gaining a bunch of rating
points his performance rating in the
year 2022 which now includes 14 games
here and i believe 20 or so games in the
feeder grand prix
it's like 2 800
28 50 i don't know exactly what it is
but he is performing
absurdly well so dingley wren is a
superstar and we heard from plenty of
super grand masters in ishqiri chief
amongst them saying that he felt dingly
wren five minute caron may be the
toughest match for magnus but for yon
napomshi
playing either of these two would be
very difficult but i do think that
hikaru fears nobody not that ding is
scared right ding is a fantastic player
but ding
unfortunately at least in madrid he's
had two very bad games the ones that he
lost and then he's had some great games
where he pressed for a win but you know
we keep highlighting this hikar just he
doesn't blunder like right now this
version of akaru is is really scary for
the opposition and also if uh well if
this match will happen or could happen
nakamura reminds me of a heavyweight
boxers of
how like how difficult it is or some of
the mma matchups you know the media
interest also will be huge right
no that's very true i mean all of twitch
will be watching uh in addition to you
know sponsorship opportunities i'm sure
so it would be a big match and dingly
ren i mean the viewership is always high
when dingley wren's playing because it's
aired in china people are watching so
whether it was the online nations cup
and the online olympiad where dingley
red and the chinese team were playing
the viewership was ridiculous you know
like million plus people or so watching
and that's really cool so dingley wren
uh you know he's had a tough couple
years the pandemic uh with cobit has not
been easy for him he hasn't been able to
travel hasn't been able to play and you
know if he
started off on a better foot if he
didn't lose the black piece with white
pieces excuse me to yonder palmishi we
could be talking about dingley wrens the
what-ifs the hypotheticals but dingley
ren you know we know what he's capable
of when he's in his best form and
the first half and another candidates it
didn't allow him to compete for first
place
yeah and that's something that ding will
have to come home and analyze why is it
that it seems to take longer for him and
for the other players to really settle
into a routine during these critical
turnovers so i wanted to make one more
point on the subject of form
yasser saron once told me something that
really really stuck with me he said
you know when you look at players wins
they're always impressive every player
has won at least one game this
tournament even if you look at fruga's
only win against richard report that was
a phenomenal game
great attacking chess for rouge at his
best you look at jan schristoff's win
against fabiano carolina that was
amazing i mean he took fabiana out in an
opening that fabiano's widely considered
to be one of the leading specialists in
the italian but yasuo said if you want
to judge good form look at the players
losses
see how much it takes
for people to bring them down and if you
look at the losses then i think you
really begin to see
hikaru's amazing form
his losses in the candidates and in the
grand prix they always go into an end
game it's always like somebody has to
beat him in all three stages of the game
barely squeeze out an advantage his only
loss in all the grand prix events i
think was the levon aronian
barely you know an ending game 75 moves
it car never seems to lose in the middle
game he never gets crushed and i think
that's what terrifies people about him
it's that even if he gets a bad position
the guy never dies
and in order to beat him you basically
need to play a perfect game for 70 moves
that's something that
nobody is capable of right now well
where i always slow myself down on this
notion is that hikaru nakamura wouldn't
even be in the candidates if gregory
opparen had converted his winning
advantage against the car
caught in opening preparation there was
a bishop sacrifice and then gregory he
backtracked instead of fully punishing
hikaru so we can't forget about that i
think it's easy to get caught up in the
moment i do ultimately agree that you're
right the way hikaru loses and he didn't
lose that game so we don't count that as
a loss even though gregory you give him
that position 100 times he wins at 99.
it was the one time he didn't but the
way you lose is very important because
some people just completely collapse
other people just prolong the struggle
and another person who seems to always
fight to the very end favianna karwana
his loss to kara nakamura was like four
different losses because
five kept fighting back he found his h3
move and hikara had a win once again and
so that is really important and dingley
ren is fully capable of that right just
in this tournament his two losses happen
to be particularly bad and at
inopportune moments the start of the
tournament on the wrong foot and then to
lose to rajab of when he's trying to
chase down yonder palm rishi and as we
look here i think that dingley ross
i was going to say dingley run is that a
loss for ideas and i just put it all
together it's the 14th round i'm you
know i can make a mistake every year but
dingly ren is at a loss for ideas
because he's spending nearly 20 minutes
and he's looking at his position is
like how in the world do i keep this
game going right where i have realistic
winning chances and at this point i
think it's it's like a bridge too far
you just can't
play something that makes it challenging
for a caru
i i think that car is going to hold this
game easily that's just nuts i mean it's
just too symmetrical
and another just money opening choice by
by nakamura 20 minutes of thinking time
for deng
with every passing minute
it just
again i don't like to over read body
language but it just seems that he's
exasperated like really is this the
position i'm getting after move 14 am i
already out of winning chances
i
i wanted to suggest maybe after what
plane knight d4 and the knight 64 bishop
takes e4 he's thinking about keeping the
queens on board here and play bishop d3
i guess yeah bishop d3 is possible just
to keep the queens on
uh
and if he does in fact put his bishop on
d3
it just feels like a position where i
mean black can play bishop f6 and just
try to trade the bishop so there's a lot
there for black just to respond with it
it's like bishop b3 won't even threaten
anything because it doesn't allow you to
get to the a2 g8 diagonal because the b5
bond covers so i think just
he may want to keep the queens on the
board but he might lose a game like that
exactly but bishop f6 is a very
important move because you want to swipe
those bishops to play to take away the
queen then play king h8 and to follow up
with the e5 right yeah no black i mean
if dignity tries too hard he's just
going to get himself in trouble so
we're going to go back to our four board
view as dingley wrench works to figure
this one out see if he has any winning
chances remaining the other game is very
interesting it looks like yanchusta duda
has slowed down in the bottom right in
fact the clock is evened up and jana
palm she even has more time a5 brilliant
move nobody saw it coming including duda
so that one will remain a fascinating
battle in the top left we haven't looked
at it but richard report i think he has
a nice opening advantage against timor
rajabov the e5 pawn is under attack
three different ways so good choice by
report and our top right we see that
it's a very classical
battle between all there is a frozen
with the black pieces five minute chrono
with white and five note has the option
to play f2 to f4 at some point though it
could involve a piece sacrifice with a
fork so it's going to be really
interesting to see how that one develops
but for now as we head on to break we're
going to remind you of a very very
exciting tournament coming up this
weekend it's already here it is
blitzchamps watch your favorite nfl
stars compete for their share of the 100
000
charity fund we have legendary wide
receiver larry fitzgerald we have all
pro second year player micah parsons we
have new cleveland browns receiver amara
cooper top five draft pick cave on
thibodeau and other stars will compete
for that charity prize fund july 9th and
10th 1pm pacific time right here on
chess.com
and we'll leave dingley wren on the
clock desperately hoping to end this
tournament second place but akara
nakamura stubbornly defending will be
right back here from defeated candidates
it is the 14th final round live from
madrid spain
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing the chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
what's the best thing for you in madrid
you have found here
well everything first of all people but
it was since my childhood that i have
discovered that people are great here
and
in general i love spain okay thank you
very much
[Music]
now
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess the
world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
we know what that means the car puts the
jacket on the game is over
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
that is the genius of jan's performance
the fact that he really did make it look
easy
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
and we are pleased to be joined by grand
master and fide director general emil
sutowsky emil thanks for joining us
well i guess the first question is
how pleased are you with how things have
gone here madrid the last three weeks of
great chess what's your overall take of
these candidates
well candidates is always a great
tournament you know it's every event
whether it was
you know this place or that place it it
is obviously a landmark and which has
history and this event was no exception
maybe tournament intrigue could be a bit
more you know because
nepo has been doing so impressively well
but all in all i think the event was a
great success and we saw a lot of people
following both online but here also in
spain it generated a lot of interest and
we're happy to conduct it in madrid in
the heart of a country which is a chess
country which for many years was one of
the one of the chess countries but
uh
for a few years they didn't stage big
events and now chess returns to spain
and and we're very pleased about that
emil you mentioned intrigue what were
the most memorable moments to you about
this year's tournament
well there were several critical moments
i mean in in hindsight you can sense
they were memorable but let's say we
could feel that the game between hikaru
and nepo when hikaru was on verge of
winning
was decisive already at that point it
felt that it could make a very big
difference but i also recall very
vividly
the games between fabian hikaru both of
them actually because i think these two
are the two best games of the tournament
[Music]
i think this is a win which hikaru
pulled in the second round
it was more of a you know excitement in
terms of
both preparation and some sort of uh
battle when fuddy almost got back in
this game and then
eventually lost but also the first round
came when when fabi prevailed and played
almost impeccable games that that was
great and talking about nato of course
that's
the impression that he was
you know head and shoulders above all
the others but
i would not single out any particular
game of him i i don't think that
from purely point of view of some
memorable games that would be remembered
for his these or that winning this
tournament it's rather overall
impression of his storm victory yeah and
you mentioned viewership and fans coming
here what to you does that say about
classical chess and what the future
holds with respect to fans
well i think this event
proved very much
and again proves that the classical
chess is very much a lifetime kicking
we hear from time to time about this
draws that annoying people and so on and
indeed that can happen and some people
might be frustrated to see some games
which they consider dollar board but
in fact classical chess obviously have
their place and
the way you look at it i mean with all
the
fun engagement and the excitement of
more of rapid time controls of bliss or
bullets i mean still classical chess
remains at its niche and it's a
very respectable niche and i doubt that
any other format would generate such a
spectatorship for a long time maybe
maybe indeed for one night he would
obviously have i didn't know magnus
playing against hikaru bullet all night
and it's broadcast it would be but to
have it like a competition running for
three weeks
i have my doubts at the same time we had
to fully realize that we do not here not
only to to be a guardians of classical
chess but also to you know to to feel
the the trends to feel what the audience
is looking for what what kind of new
ideas could be introduced and indeed we
are experimenting with those and we are
talking with players about all that
because for us it's also very important
and we are not imposing some time
control without checking or asking
opinions of top players or sometimes a
broader audience to to to see how what's
their reaction so i think in general
like like in every management decision
the decision of feeding here is always
you know to not to change necessarily
but to slightly adjust to introduce new
new ideas to to to test it sometimes
sometimes maybe your experiments would
not bring anything good and then you you
you should assume that okay it didn't
work nothing nothing happened so you try
something else it's all right but in
general we need to preserve the balance
between
what chess is about
with its tradition with the modern way
the chess develops itself as a online
audience is is huge
as
e-sports factor slowly becoming a factor
so i think we are fairly okay with with
preserving that balance but
we are constantly looking for
improvements
tournaments like the candidates are
remembered not only by who won but also
by the city in which they were held
could you talk a little bit about the
city of madrid and its role in making
the 2022 candidates a success
yeah i think i think it's very important
where the event is held and when we
started negotiating uh with sponsors
about the
actual venue immediately the idea came
to mind that it should be some city
where the event would you know would
resonate that it would make a difference
to have an event in this city
and madrid came as a very strong option
and also i i'm thankful to scheimberg
family who supported the idea to have it
here uh i think
the the atmosphere and we could see the
minister of sport coming but also
national newspapers covering it every
day and we have a lot of
chess fans here waiting at the
tour to meet players to get i remember
oh well how popular chess was here when
the linares was was taking place and uh
spain let's not to forget let's not
forget is also a part of being capital
of spain i mean there is a strong
connection to latin american countries
so we we see it gets very popular the
event and i'm i'm
really hopeful and i have all the
reasons even to plan for having big
events
to take place both in spain and in latin
american countries that would certainly
be lovely and you know this event has
been a great success but i think a lot
of people are wondering about what this
event qualifies the players for because
magus carlson he remains non-committal
about whether or not he'll play in the
world chess championship so
what have you learned i know he had a
meeting with arkady dvorkvich for 40
minutes that was reported yesterday so
what can you say about
magnus carlsen potentially playing in
the world championship match
yeah that's that's an important question
and probably
probably the main reason you asked me to
behave
actually i was also a part of this
meeting it was
magnus
mr president and and myself because i'm
in charge basically for the all the
major events including the candidates
and world championship match
their formats and
the venues and and everything
so of course it was important to talk
and to understand
um there is a certain misconcept about
magnus attitude towards that some some
say it is a balloony like like
that he wouldn't play that he would play
anyways and no matter what he's saying
that no but but if you knew magnus you
you would take his word seriously and we
did and our conversation yesterday also
proved that
he
he he literally means what he's saying
and
we are looking for the ways to
let's say to have uh
him stay within within a
world championship cycle there's one
clear point i want to clarify because
there's been a bit of means concepts
that feed is going to change the format
or adopt new regulations in fact there
are no regulations for the match 2023 so
far we have been non-committed ourselves
because because the talks about micros
possibly not link came right after dubai
so we we felt it would be wrong now to
adopt and then to try to talk to to hear
what magnus has in mind and then maybe
to change we didn't we didn't actually
approve it and
we are still
having quite a bit of time to to decide
and to finalize
uh magnus was
quite reasonable in his
ideas
i'm not
probably cannot disclose details here it
will be unfair
but i can tell that we
a we are
we have started discussing it internally
with
what could be done
to to let's say to preserve balance
between what we feel is right maybe to
also to to hear some ideas of magnets
being implemented
uh at the same time we don't have a lot
of time to you know to waste
because imagine today okay today we know
nepal is playing magnus but we can't
carry on for three months or something
to not know and then suddenly to start
to start fighting for venue and sponsor
for the match with hikaru or we're
always ding i mean it would be
absolutely different match absolutely
probably different penny and so on
so that's why we agreed that we have we
were going in to intensify both internal
consultations and and also talking to
magnus
and i believe that the decision on the
format uh would be
within
maybe two or three weeks time with
yonder palm she's input as well or uh
yeah so far we have to develop the easy
the form okay which we would believe
that it would be it's not any
negotiations between the players or it's
not the negotiations with magnus what
what is it's it's fear as a pulling set
of regulations we believe should be
uh should be in place uh of course
uh we would not be happy
if magnus skips it
it's obviously
not the end of the world but
he's not just a world champion but the
dominant world champion and you don't
want the player who is clearly number
one in all ratings
uh to be i mean all ratings all
classical ratings for all the time i
mean uh
we don't want him to skip the cycle at
the same time
we also don't believe that the world
champion can just say you know
it would be this way why don't play so
we have to find this balanced solution
and we'll be working on it
um
for magnus once again i was very
very appreciative and am appreciative of
the way we spoke yesterday he was very
candid and he was very positive actually
it was never in a
sort of ultimate more or conversations
that would impose a pressure on the
presence of myself
it was rather that he was telling his
story his his vision and and his fear
and uh i think it was uh
i didn't know how to end up but uh i
think it was
both
very constructive and it left a hope
that that
it can
indeed work
um
if i the magnus i would once again think
twice about
uh okay i'll leave the world
championship tackle but it's it's it's
difficult to come back and you know that
just history is strange i mean who would
think in 1972 that the official dropped
in 1975
that three years after you would have
absolutely different heroes everybody
would only think about copper and
cautionary feature drama would not be
even on newspapers anymore everybody
would concentrate and so on and with the
world rapidly changing with war it was
everything so you don't know what kind
of developments it could be
uh i think for magnus legacy losing a
title like that would be would be this
but once again he's the one to decide
and we are we can only be let's say
reasonable but not necessarily following
uh
everything that he hasn't met
we avoided it this year and the hikaru
uh the ding nakamura game is unfolding
as we seek but there is currently no
tiebreaker procedure for second place
now we interviewed some of the players
most if not all of them expressed a
desire to have an actual playoff for
second place in case the world champion
declines to play what is your take
on the tiebreaker system as it exists
currently and what is your take on the
idea of moving toward playoffs rather
than uh the sb or any other tiebreak
system for deciding second place in
tournaments yeah that's a very good
point we thought about it
uh i believe it's a bit weird that you
sort of preconditions and because world
champion alleges that he might not play
you suddenly have a tie break for the
second place
so what if russian players
god forbid the russia does something
even worse and then you
russian players are not allowed to play
at all so you do also tiebreak for third
place to determine who would replace
russian winner i mean it's a bit getting
far stretched i think
having a tiebreaker for first place is
reasonable having a tiebreaker player
who would replace one of the players is
not exactly what he wanted it
i understand those who who claim that
maybe maybe it's uh the way to go uh for
this event we decided that it shouldn't
be i think the only person who i don't
know
in studio a part of hikaru airing this
thought i remember discussing it with
with fabi
uh during warzone and he said well
having tigers for the second place would
be too much and uh i remember very well
but it's not like we were lying or
solely on his opinion we also believe
that
where do you stop that's the question
where do you stop was the same like with
the tiebreak system for the rapid and
bliss championship you remember the
discussions there so currently actually
we have sent we have sent a
questionnaire to players
uh about the
best system to to determine about the
world rapid completes if players share
first place what to do whether we should
go all players play off ten players
share plays so play another five hours
play off and determine who is going to
be or we cut it somewhere at the end of
the day it's all you have to find the
way which would be also fair because uh
if if talking about the the rapid and
blitz it's not the topic here but
it could be very possible that the guy
who shared first place simply played
much stronger fields of the guy who was
stands by by the time and whether he now
the number one should prove that
uh in one blitz game that he
he can continue fighting for for a gold
medal and the guy who came all the way
from down in the swiss gambit should not
i don't know
as for the
playoff in general whether to have
matches or to have a candidate's
tournament so that's that's a good
question let's let's take brief look
backwards
uh
entire playoff or matches system was
introduced in 1960s
and do you remember after the in famous
tournament famous and both famous and in
famous tournament curacao 1962
the system was introduced the matches uh
were introduced and and they were played
uh
now
we have to ask ourselves what actually
left a big
memory for for the chess spectators
do you really remember many matches that
would be really leaving you like in
history a part of fisher like crushing
everyone would you name
spassky supporting the 1960s what do you
name
[Music]
who who advances there i mean even even
for casper
these matches didn't leave much of a
trace because although casper in 98 is
moving up and then he beats
biliavsky's unfortunately
and so
whereas a candidate's tournament is
something that always a candidate's
tournament starting maybe it has to do
something with 1953 legacy canada's
tournament but also afterwards i mean
london 2013 everybody remembers has a
very exciting tournament we remember a
lot of games you see a lot of players so
they're pros and cons and and one more
thing
very often we forget about the
practicality of things how you
practically make these matches you make
them four games
it's possible uh and actually we switch
the women's system now for the
for the four games matches but there's a
percentage of draws is much much lower
now if you make four games like tried
once in kazan four four and six that's
the only probably practical way you can
have it all together then another
problem arises that basically nearly all
of the matches will be decided in rapid
blitz
which we still are reluctant to do
because i mean it's a world classical
world championship and to determine it's
this way
and then if you try and divide it
let's say making quarter finals of eight
games then another quarterfinals of 80
games and then a final of 12 games
whatever that could work but it's uh
practically if you start thinking of it
it's very difficult
so there are several several sides to it
i understand the cons of the candidates
as well
because the main con in my opinion
is that a player who doesn't have a good
tournament has an impact basically and
by his
poor play or even if he simply doesn't
care in last rounds anymore so he can
impact and that there is a problem with
that
um but
we thought about various ways to to to
to do it whether to have some incentive
for players to occupy okay this term
they haven't sent it for the second
place but but actually the incentive for
second place or for third place
those the players continue fighting we
even altered the the system of prize
awards you know it's not points and so
on of course for these players and
another 10 or 20 grand would not make a
huge difference we raised price fund
it's it's 500 grand for the for the
second time okay it has numbers last
year
we we altered the system we constantly
look for an improvement but i'm not i'm
not sure if uh
tournaments should be replaced by the
matches although matches
arguably are more exciting yeah and you
know some of the things you mentioned uh
i guess there's been a call for
consistency where some events have
increments some events don't and as you
just mentioned that the women's cycle
now is different
from this open cycle so what's the
thinking behind changing the formats
changing the time patrols and why is
there not just one for all the events
that's a very good question first of all
for the for the women's time of women's
cycle uh we actually were striving for
several years to have it
consistent with open cycle and and it
was fair and we basically achieved it we
introduced grants with men alone we have
a grand prix for men and women we have a
world cup for men and women we
introduced the women's candidates
tournament in the same format
it took place in 2019 but this year for
for the reasons of ongoing war
we simply we simply don't have a
solution
you have two ukrainian players and you
have
three russian players one of which
christian you've now moved undefeated
so what you do you have ukrainian
players who are not allowed to compete
with russians by their government
so do you i mean
do you feel it would be right to
just to kick out russian players
just for being russian we don't
think so
do you feel it would be okay to impose
on ukrainians to either you play
violating the the
the regulations of your own country or
or you quit the tournament would be
always unfair so we found the compromise
and i think it's reasonable it die it
comes at the cost to us actually because
for us it would be simpler to organize
it
at one venue and so on we are going to
have
two pools in two various places one
would have been west one probably in
this
but
that's how it works now it's always a
question when you say um you know to
have
some sort of standardized standardized
solutions
it's easier for it would be easier for
us
the problem is that it does not exactly
connect with the reality many times you
have absolutely different type of event
i'll give you uh
an example with uh
having increment or not having an
increment
not having an increment came actually an
idea that came in connection to the
match
the match is is the most exciting thing
and and there
a you want you have a broad broadest
possible audience now for broadest
possible audience it's clear you play
two hours two hours this increment of 30
seconds is very difficult to understand
and to grasp
uh you have to add you remember you had
all this long draw series and so on so
you bring an element of
call it more excitement
some player in time trouble he has only
half a minute to complete his six moves
and so on so it counts him now then
logically came a consequence that the
candidates as a qualifier for the match
does have it as well
now it would be logical to go one step
down and to have let's say in the world
cup the is the event without an
increment or to have rapid change
without an increment so always a
question because you know simple
solutions are simple just to have we
play all the same time control we play
no matter what's even but the events are
different by their nature they're
different by the spectatorship
the number of players the length of the
competition the number of arbiters who
are observing and monitoring the event
imagine you have uh tournament without
increment in an event where not
every board is monitored by the operator
it is it is also different so there are
always many questions and
i realize of course that
people would
rather
expect us to say okay from now on we
play all the same one time control
players get used to that and that's it
but it's not happening here let's say
for grand swiss for grand swiss we have
a long time control of seven hours
and why is that
world cup we have a short time control
and that's that's also a question that
we we have to understand where it comes
from because sometimes it comes from
the reasoning of
spectatorship
sometimes it comes for the reasoning of
the format of the event and we try we
always try to have this balance for fide
itself once again i would like to
underline well for us it would be easier
not to break our head
and just to go with one time control but
it's not for the lack of uh
not for the lack of
compassion towards players or not
because we're thinking actually we are
thinking about every particular event
what would be the best and most suitable
and it's not like we're having 12
different time controls let's let's not
exaggerate in classics we have like like
three
so it's not it's or or basically two the
longer one and the shorter one
so and and in rapid you have basically
one used now 5 15 plus 10.
um
to have everything
the standard way it's possible but i
don't think it's the best solution
because i think i just think sometimes
is better and smarter than just
following one practice
could we get your take on online chess
and in particular do you think that
hybrid games or online games that are
fide rated is that part of what you and
fides see as the future of modern chess
well online chess is very important i
think
i mean
there are two
conflicting views and i disagree with
both of them that online chess
is the future of chess and online chess
is just something that is not just
basically that's not true i mean there
are obvious problems with online chess
but uh there is no other way to engage
as many people as it does
as simple as that we have millions and
millions of people playing thanks to
online chess we have millions people who
started to follow just to watch
broadcast things that
so it's it's clear that there is a
future to that now what is the future of
online just in terms of sportive valley
of the official titles and so on we
start experimenting on that we started
conducting official events we had online
olympia there are
quite a bit of things which require
tackling and tweaking and not all of
them are easy to tweak actually
hybrid is better in these regards hybrid
is more difficult to to to to actually
to organize because you actually need
players to to be at some location maybe
maybe all of them would be in different
locations but they would be playing uh
we we started rating federating the
hybrid events as you know
and we'll continue with this practice
of course for ratings the hybrid event
you need some preconditions to before
especially in regards to the arbiters
not easy but i believe that's the future
because
more and more things are done online
but
i would tell you that talking to many
governments sponsors big companies and
so on i realize that for many of them
the moment that you switch
your official event from from otb to
online it loses a bit of it let's say
preciousness or or value or status
because
too many things which are happening
online are not serious or not considered
serious so here you have people coming
in competing and so on which is which
provides for special atmosphere for
journalists for tv for for broadcast and
still with all the modern technologies
we are not nowhere close to do the same
for the for the online let's say magnus
online tour exceptional great players
and so on still you cannot compete to
compete
you still cannot compare it with with
official event like candidates no way i
mean it's still it's still a long way to
go so uh we will be slowly moving and
and developing it i believe that it's
still a future but chess
is more than just a game because in
online you you lose this factor of
of a i don't know cultural event taking
place
socializing
kids coming playing facing grandmaster
taking uh master class playing simul
taking photos and so on all this is
still missing uh in an online event
uh says that once again i cannot see
any better way to popularize chess than
to promote online
yeah though that makes perfect sense and
emil this is everyone watching emil
sutasi the feed a director general and a
chess grandmaster himself and i have one
fun question as we let you go
what do we have in store for the closing
ceremony because the opening ceremony
seemed extravagant any fun surprises for
tomorrow's clothing ceremony yeah we are
working on it uh the i think the opening
ceremony was quite special and many
people still recall it and we are
working on it and
of course closing ceremony which will be
tomorrow at 9 00 pm uh is planned to be
special but
what exactly extravaganza or something
memorable moments we are still polishing
it and
we we tried not to discipline well we
look forward to it and i guess before i
do let you go just that one last
question that everyone wants to know
when is magnus carlsen's deadline
because you said you're in discussions
at some point decision has to be made
whether or not to move on from magnus
playing john de palma she so when is his
deadline
we haven't set a formal deadline
but
let's say i would say july 20 which is
also an international chess day
is about is about a time when when we
will have a decision okay well we look
forward to learning more then we've
learned a lot from you today so thank
you so much emil for joining us thank
you thank you thank you denny
and hikaru nakamura dingley wren still
competing for second place here in the
fide candidates
dingley wren did not get the desired
outcome of the opening he is looking for
any possible advantage against the
sturdy american player hikaru nakamura
hikaru has a half point lead over
dingley ren heading into today as you
can see on the screen in front of you
with four wins seven draws and two
losses a car has a fantastic event
dingley ren has had a fantastic second
half but a late loss the team over job
of
him get leapfrogged by the american
almira i mean dingley wren he's not
getting what he needs to get
i agree with you just i wanted to tell
you that i'm feeling that um i feel that
we are playing i am playing this game
with musical chairs
that was
very interesting interview i've learned
a few things uh especially that we
finally have a deadline for this very
important
official statements and announcement but
i was trying to analyze this game
and i thought that
well ding lyren tried almost everything
here and
well it might
backfire very soon if he if he's not
very careful i think bishop f6 is black
next move
it is very important to trade the dark
square bishops and well first of all to
unpin the king
let's say bishop f6 king will take on
the syncs just
ah no if you if you play rook c1 then i
have to reconsider because i also have
to keep control of the c5 square so
let's see rook ac one let me think uh i
have to adapt myself maybe i will swap
on d1 and first play uh rook d8 what do
you think about this looks like perfect
defense right because
swapping off the rooks doesn't leave
white with much remaining my mama told
me that if there's only kings left on
the board then the game ends in a draw
so that is still accurate despite the
many changes and alterations we should
ask emil he's still in the room yeah
considering a draw is still the case
when all the pieces go off and just
king's remain no this is a position
where it seems very difficult for hikaru
to go wrong uh while we had a meal on
the show several moves had been played
but
i don't i feel like dingley run he's
just pushing pieces hoping for some
mistake but look at the clock right
hikaru nakamura still has one hour
37 minutes remaining it's dingley wren
who's desperately trying to find
something and if he
really tries to win he might be trying
to lose because he he just doesn't have
a plan
well
this is true but on the other hand
even the emails interview
underlined the ambivalence of the
situation that the players has been in
since the beginning of the tournament
they don't know what they're playing for
it would be much easier for them
to play uh
and not
force on the position
in this situation if they knew that for
example the second place is not on stake
but for the moment we don't know and we
should emphasize this
and that's why dingley runs making moves
like rook d1 to c1 keeping more pieces
on the board and there is a direct
threat rook takes c6 would be a problem
for black with knight e5 check coming
that would be a fork so
hikaru he you know has to watch out for
little things here and there but dingley
ren if this were a game at the first
round of some tournament he would just
trade rooks trade another pair of rooks
just agree this one should be a draw but
because the onus is on him he doesn't
know what he's playing for hikaru a draw
with black is a great result no matter
if a world championship matches at stake
so all the pressure was on ding from
move one and
i i just can't get over how the opening
has gone and how well hikaru has been
able to stabilize yeah and i think this
is another thing that makes zikaru scary
to play against of course he wants to
play for a world championship match he
wanted to win the candidates i'm not
claiming that he doesn't but he's also
enjoying his experience here in madrid
he likes the fact that he's here that he
qualified that he's playing that he's
making recap videos
he's just living in the moment and it
seems like some of the other players i
mean hikaru even talked about fabiana
caruana in this context may have just
overthought it they may have expected
too much of themselves they may have
painted the situation as either i get
second place or the world falls apart
and that's not how hikaru has treated
the candidates and i think that's
largely what has opened the doors for
him and why he's able to play so
confidently and at times so quickly and
and accurately but i i do like rick dc1
i think that's a measured attempt to
unbalance the position and keep pieces
on the board
yeah and i think it also goes to show
that black shouldn't just play with his
hand rather with his brain because
sometimes our opponent puts a rook on c1
we play rook c8 without even thinking
but you need to think in a position like
this because you never know when some
kind of tactic aiming at the e6 square
could be very good for white so you just
need to be on the lookout at all turns
it does seem to be a very stable
position but
as we know yonder pomnishi won the
tournament already clear first place for
him and ikara nakamura in second all he
needs is to draw his game against the
man chasing him and then he will get
second place that means additional prize
money and perhaps as of july 20th 2022
we'll know if he gets a shot in a world
championship title
yes we will
it's been an incredible performance five
wins not only the only person without
any losses but everybody else has lost
at least two games i think that's that
really demonstrates the extent
of yan's dominance but we remind you
that he did lose this last round game
uh i think to dingley ren
at the 2020 yucateerenburg candidates he
mentioned that that game really stung at
him even though the celebration was on
and he doesn't want to repeat that loss
and so you can tell the
concentration and the focus
is on it's there
in his last round battle against jkt and
that mysterious move a5 i think the
mystery has been solved and what a move
it was the rook lift happened you called
it so the rook in the bottom right hand
side of our screen for yonder palm
shield is on a6 yanchez dude on the
clock and we'll
go through the last few moves because we
saw an h-pawn push then an a-pawn push
in response so as we analyze this
position go back to when the h4 happened
and then a5 after c4 what a shocking
move
h5 and rook a6 this shows some
phenomenal understanding because
this is not an accident he didn't push
upon and get his rook but he must have
seen variations where his rook is needed
to cover the sixth rank but it's not a
natural plan almira well but
let's have a look at the opening it
started all in in a bit artificial
manner as well when you play queen d7
and your bishop is still on c8 maybe you
have to rethink your strategies and to
look for
well a way to dismantle your pieces and
this might be the the plan with a5 for
k6 you need to bring their stroke into
play and probably the lines that they
have analyzed with d4 directly
they might be equal but there are some
positions which might occur where your
rook is stuck on a8 and your bishop is
still on c8 and you you have problems
developing those two pieces it's a good
point and queen d7 was already thinking
outside the box in the opening and an a5
rook a6 creativity galore in this last
round match up so we saw bishop
developing the e3 trying to secure the
d4 square
jan said i don't want you to plan a
piece there because if you can keep the
position closed then white can play on
the king side with a free hand so that's
why yon understanding his king might be
in some danger you often play your best
defense when you distract your opponent
and play a different part of the board
so dyna d4 and after pawn takes knight c
takes d4 94 was played the one big
downside of pushing your d-pawn was
giving white this e4 square so whose
chances do you favor here yonda pomshi
who has more time been playing a great
tournament or jan christoph duda who has
some aggressive intentions on the king
side chose this pretty
random seeming opening and wants a last
round victory yeah the complexity has
reached a zenith
here with
you know massive tension in the center
big decisions for both players
i i can't really evaluate this position
i you know the old school you know
russian school boy me prefers white just
because the f6 square is a permanent
weakness and
you know white's got this pawn on h5
that's exerting more pressure on black's
king's side
keeping that in mind you might say well
i see a way for black to force a queen
trade and i mentioned this previously
knight takes c2 and queen d3 i think
there's a non-zero chance that jan goes
for this now white does not have to take
on d3 white can trade on his own terms
and i can go rook a c1 and i think it's
very important to point out that even in
an end game black still experiences
problems with the f6 square the king on
g8 is not out of the woods just because
the queens are off the board and if you
play b5 which looks really obvious
natural white can strike at black's
queen side with a2a4 as you're
indicating and uh
i think that jan has to be a little bit
more careful than jan
i think the black has to be a little bit
more careful than white here
and uh i think that jan schuster has put
his time to good use
amir it's a good illustration that queen
trade don't necessarily neutralize your
opponent black's queenside pawns may
have gone too far what i found
interesting is that daniel thinks that
after knight d4 the game has reached its
paroxysm i thought it will be a few
moves later when uh
young sister will decide to sacrifice
something
but i was
thinking about the way
[Music]
so how to do it because i i don't think
that jan will go for knight c to quincy
to queen d3
uh
can he start with
b5 here but then white will go uh
because for the moment my c4 pawn is not
hanging if he will play a4 i i can
continue with i can follow up with b4
and at some point i'm not sure when that
moment is i'm just looking at knight f6
check because
whether it's before a4 or not the knight
f6 check forces the bishop to take the
pawn takes back and now we start seeing
all these pieces stare at the king this
queen needs to get to h6 like it's
background problems that's why i hate
playing these positions always
background problems king can't get out
this way you can't really push this pawn
ever because the g6 pawn and well the h6
square is under white's control so so
can i take on c2 here
and now that i can also develop my
bishop play queen d3
in this position i guess dania would say
let's just go rook c1 trade on our own
terms and go for this pawn and
it's a problem because black's king does
not find
shelter even when the queens come off
even if material stays even white just
continues to have this pressure and with
the presence of opposite colored bishops
we don't just assume it's going to be
equal because of
what you hear that all opposite colored
bishop endings are drawn no the side
with the safer king is usually the happy
side with opposite colored bishops
because black's king is in trouble in
the dark squares white's king is tucked
at home has like four different pillows
all the blankets you're not getting
anywhere there you nighttime monster
stay away
yeah but they think this is young's best
chance
maybe quite possibly yeah to get for the
opposite uh color bishops but
it's not an end game it's a middle game
even though the queens are going to be
traded
i think
the more we analyze this the more i
realize that from a practical standpoint
if not
objectively black's position is quite
unpleasant
because if you look at this
in a superficial manner you see the
knight on d4 you think that's a great
night you see the queen on d7 the rock n
d you think black's got pressure in the
center
but then you realize that white has
tremendous potential energy the threat
of knight f6 check
the pawn on e5 which has been a theme in
this game ever since duda established it
there on mov4 the fact that black's
queen side pawns were disjointed and the
fact that b5
doesn't solve all of black's problems
due to the a4 pawn strike all of this
taken together i think is making yan
visibly uncomfortable i think this is a
great opening choice by duda he's got a
lot less to lose we've established that
paradoxically right even though jan's
won the tournament he doesn't want that
bad taste in his mouth he wants to meet
a good mood at tomorrow's closing
ceremony emil
teased us with
some of the extravagances that might be
on show tomorrow so
this is getting uh spicy and there are
no draw offers until move 40. and i
think that really helps in a situation
like this in the 14th around the
candidates when yonda palmer she's
already locked up the tournament so
whether or not he
loses when he draws i mean it doesn't
matter right he wins the tournament that
was a big
because that invites the queen to the
party over here on the king side but the
point i was gonna make is i love that
all four games are still in progress all
eight players are trying to
you know play their best they still feel
energetic they want to win their games
if possible and that's not true of many
tournaments so it is cool to see the
players fighting it out that's not even
true of your predictions yeah no i i
you're right i was wrong i admit it
that's right robert you were wrong yeah
i'm big enough to admit when i make
mistakes everybody i'm looking right at
you i made a mistake my predictions have
been terrible ever since danny left this
wasn't supposed to be my responsibility
but now that i'm doing it i admit i am
not i volunteered to be on the on the
chopping block but i wanted to say one
more thing which is that
uh in last year's candidates in the
final round three out of the four games
were also decisive
and i think the genius of chess is the
rating system which creates an inherent
inherent motivator to play players who
have a bad tournament they want to win
the last round to lose less rating
players who are having a good tournament
they don't necessarily want a quick draw
with white they want to capitalize on
their good form
so
you know
nobody wants to end the tournament with
a whimper and even if there's nothing on
the line per se i think that's the
reason we don't see a lot of quick draws
maybe in the old days 40 years ago the
players look at each other
you know we want to go to the bar next
door let's end it nowadays these players
are professional athletes they fight
until the bitter end which is great for
us and great for chess fans we should
appreciate that might not be great for
you on the palm shield yeah except yeah
he would have loved to exit today with a
quick draw make history in the
candidates with nine and a half points
out of 14
rounds but he's on the clock and it's
looking scary for him
not much has changed in the game between
dingley ren and hikaru nakamura and
let's go to the game between five-minute
karwana and ali raza farouz actually no
i take it back let's go to that man's
game richard report because we actually
have not looked at it it does look very
similar to the game between car one and
farouza but we should give these players
the time that they deserve because
richard report teamwork java they've
been fighting all tournament long for
java it's been a successful event for
report it's been a struggle
especially down the stretch so
we have this position here looks very
familiar to us during this tournament
there's been a lot of exchange spanishes
where white takes this knight on c6 it's
stemmed from the ante berlin but it sort
of transposes in many regards and this
bishop on d6 best piece on the board for
sure that bishop looks excellent there
right by far
but well the difference between those
two games is that richard report has the
bishop on b2
uh and fabiana corona has developed it
on e3 the
another game
comes to my mind but completely
different it was uh le von erin against
vladimir kramnik wherever coming didn't
uh castle and
g8 and g5 and here uh the execution is a
bit different
but the idea behind uh well this move is
very similar you you want to launch a
very direct attack
and g4 can be played right now like yeah
the rook went to g1 for a reason and
it's not to protect the g2 pawn it's to
go right after that king and jay and you
brought up the game between uh lavon and
ronin and vladimir kromik that was a
masterpiece by krumnick who blew
him off the board like it wasn't even
close that game it felt like uh the
londoner never knew what hit him yeah
and so here with g4 g5 coming and i was
joking about this bishop 1d6 it's a
really bad piece so you don't really
want to take it unless you were quickly
playing f4 or something there's no
reason to take this bishop here its
future is probably back somewhere on the
king side so i like the look of reports
g4
yeah i mean
i think the reason he's thinking is that
bonds don't go backwards and
my guess is that rajaba well why did he
play bishop h5 to f7 well he makes sure
that g4 doesn't come with tempo which
gives him a tempo
to decide how to react now he cannot
simply allow the pawn to land on g5 so
black can meet you for
with
the move g7 g5 closing down the king
side that does create a massive hole on
f5 and white can try to get one of the
knights there that's one option another
option is to say okay what's the
drawback of white pushing upon a g4 well
that weakens the f4 square so black can
send the knight there via f8
downside to that is that it does allow
white to execute the g5 pawn push
i don't really envy black situation
after g4 but richard also doesn't have
to hurry with g4 he can start by playing
the very typical knight h4 knight f5 so
there's a lot to decide here but no
question in my mind that white's
position is for choice
yeah well temura java he plays
those types of structures
with pair of bishops
in in the rasa lima but this is not the
same
their black very often sacrifice the
pawn on c4 and gets the activity for the
pair of bishops here it seems absolutely
impossible
because
the knight well has such a beautiful
outpost on c4 unless you take on c4 what
you don't want to do
here because you lose control over the
white
squares the light squares
[Music]
i think it's really important though
that as soon as the move g4 is played
and i say this often pawns are two
squares away look at the square in
between so g4 is a move that of course
report wants to make but then it gives
black this very clear plan to bring the
knight in so i wonder if there is an
improving move
one of the ideas we would talk about was
knight h4 first that makes a lot of
sense but i'm wondering if there's an
improving move
that just says i'll play g4 eventually
but i don't want to actually give black
a plan because if we pass the turn to
black and we said all right you go what
is black's plan here maybe it is to take
on c4 at some moment that's not really a
plan that's a move so what do we think
black's plan is it's likely knight f8
knight e6 and knight to d4 something
like that so we uh want to
note that and by playing g4 we might be
welcoming the knight instead of d4 into
f4 and that could be problematic for the
king on h1 whereas white thinks he's
going for the attack maybe it can flip
back against him
yeah and then richard has been thinking
for seven minutes here
and there's a lot to consider g4 is a
very committal decision you can't take
it back
but it would be very much congruent with
his style and his willingness to take
positional risks so i'm expecting him to
either play g4 or to start with that h4
i think those two
might be the main moves that he's
deciding between
but if white starts with knight h4
black replies knight f8 how do you
continue here
let's say knight f5
96
yeah
yeah now you're basically saying all
right unite you got your knights f5
congratulations i'm gonna give you the
medal can i go
somewhere over here around these parts
you can go queen g3 but i will always i
i anticipated to i wanted to play king
h8 here immediately
and i'm almost thinking like i don't
want to take there but i want to play f4
because the knight can't take
right and if the pawn takes the big
diagonal opens for the bishop oh wow the
evil bar didn't hate it but the point is
knight takes f4
runs the queen g7 mate and if you take
with the pawn then this bishop is
thrilled to be here there might be some
kind of sacrifice in the near future on
the g7 square to get to f6 and why can't
even consider playing e5 so i don't know
if it really pans out but look how
complex this position is you start with
king h1 you play rook g1 you threaten to
play g4
but then you switch to another plan you
play knight h4 you played knight f5 and
then you play queen g3 and f4
yeah
and it's funny because we're now
speaking of attacking chances but it's
such a closed position so the side that
controls the pawn brakes i like to say
is often the side with the advantage and
after bishop f7 g4 g5 one of those pawn
breaks maybe an eventual f4 you play g3
move the knight play f4 play it slowly
but okay but let's try g4 i think it's a
very direct approach and you are not in
time here you cannot play knight f8 96
because i will play g5 immediately right
so this
this is a real cross-examination they
are where you going
this is a very unappetizing position
from a human point of view rook g3 or
rook 8 g1
yeah it's just the forces
starting to build up on the king side
yeah so g4 is asking the real question
are you playing g5 i think the answer is
yes i i feel like her java i mean java
obviously hates
getting intact i mean everybody does
i think he would respond with g5
and how do we bring our knight to f5
knight c4 to e3
yeah who cares if it's illegal just ask
emil's permission
one illegal move for trump okay well we
can start with this knight here just so
we can
knight f8
so
to you know two can play at that game
okay queen here you're gonna go to
knight g6 i assume i'll go knight e3
mm-hmm knight f4
and nine i'll go to knight
i think a knight f5 and why didn't we
play h4 before could we
we could play now oh we can play it
here yeah h4 i guess your point is that
if i play h6 and that creates target
and that target will force me to lose
the tempo
yeah our bishop of faith
now what i liked uh
before that when uh we start with h4
then we still have this possibility of
playing king g2 king f1 and playing rook
f rook h1
oh i hate this for black
i feel like black can get checkmated
here in the blink of an eye
yeah this does not feel comfortable i
mean if g5 is your response
yeah sorry all right and you know
what what does mean about black's
position is the fact that you know you
don't have any cutaway
it's the fact that the queen side is so
gummied up
and if black already had b6 and a6 in
you could make the case that okay black
can consider b5
but that knight on c4 is standing
sentinel over the whole queen side and
it's like white has carved lunch
on the king side which is not to say a
report can do whatever he wants and it's
just mate
but
i mean this is a very unenviable
situation for timur and
he you know one of his big hopes right
is that uh richard will get into time
pressure i think yeah he's going to need
richard to keep on thinking here because
this could be a blistering attack down
the g file so as we leave report to it
he is going to try to work this out
we'll go back to our bird's eye view
take in all four games because no player
has finished their tournament just yet
we see in the bottom left dingly wren
trying to double his rooks maybe he has
some chances
yeah it's a slow methodical approach
from dingley wren but he is going to try
to work his endgame magic in the top
right we see a position that's in many
ways similar to the one the top left so
report with java caruana farouja
they're
maneuvering their pieces not quite a
tactical affair yet and that's not the
case in the bottom right where yon
napashi he decided to take this
knight on f3 the queen took back
and we'll see how those players continue
because jan has made a move to put duda
back on the clock but for now
we are going to head towards a break
we are
always excited when eric rosen plays but
we're equally excited when james canty
iii
is on the move he's his hat says that's
not a move but he has plenty of good
moves because he's razor sharp we in
here g5 and we live that's james k in
the third taking on the always tricky
the personable eric rosen the beloved
eric rosen thursday july 7th at 10 30
a.m pacific time right here on chess.com
so
the players in the playing hall richard
report still thinking trying to make
this attack work you would love to end
this term with victory and we love to
see this madrid in all its glory and all
its beauty this is where the candidates
is taking place we'll be right back
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
it was bigger
than chess
in fact
it was bigger than the world
championship
it was war
literally and figuratively
every aspect of the 1972 world chess
championship was a battle
the united states and the ussr were
embroiled in the cold war
ten years after the cuban missile crisis
u.s president nixon met with soviet
premier residents in moscow despite an
easing of political and military
hostilities towards each other the
united states and the ussr took the cold
war to the 64 square battlefield where
masterful chess was played on and off
the table
the players couldn't have been more
different the american-born bobby
fischer was an eccentric and outspoken
new yorker with a particular disdain for
the soviet union and communism
boris baskey was the calm and refined
front runner of the soviet chess machine
that dominated the sport for decades
by 1972 bobby fischer had made a name
for himself as someone who wasn't
satisfied by just winning he sought to
dominate
leading up to the world championship
fisher won 19 straight games and
decimated two grandmasters 6-0 and then
6-0 in the candidates matches setting a
world record that has never been broken
however fischer had never beaten spassky
in any of the five previous games they
played
boris faskey failed to win the world
championship in 1966 but took the
coveted title in 1969 when he narrowly
defeated tigran petrosian in their
rematch the 1972 match marks basket's
third appearance in the title event but
the first time as the sitting world
champion
in the months preceding the match bobby
fischer's demands for increased prize
money made the 1972 world championship
one of the most challenging events to
organize but his tenacity led to this
match being the richest chess event in
history unfortunately fischer's demands
and antics did not stop there
his behavior before and during the match
created drama suspense and worldwide
entry involving some of the world's most
powerful people
over the course of the next few months
just.com will be releasing various media
commemorating the 50th anniversary of
the most epic world chess championship
in history
we will be hearing from experts learning
about the players exploring the drama
and getting inside the heads of bobby
fischer and boris
we will also be examining the most
important moves and games of the 1972
world championship keep an eye out for
hashtag fisherspotsd50 and join us on
this fascinatingchest.com historical
journey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
want to play check us online or learn
how to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess
continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
we know what that means a car puts the
jacket on the game is over
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
that is the genius of jan's performance
the fact that he really did make it look
easy
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
i don't even just say it you can just
read it miss amigos
and that's
my amigo dania waving to you all can we
say it all together oh should we say it
all together let's do it let's do it one
two three miss amigos
this is international master elmira
scripchenko grand master daniel nirodsky
i'm grand master robert hassan just like
the players in the candidates we have to
have our fun saying miss amigos it's our
shot at the glory yes yes
that reminds me of my biggest pet peeve
which is those old school assemblies
where the speaker is like it's like 7am
good morning everybody and then
everybody says good morning yeah i
didn't hear you
i hated that
but
you know you love the shirt oh thanks
well you know i this came today i was
told i could wear it i wasn't sure if i
should you know either be dressy or be
miss amigos i think being friendly is
the way our broadcast should go is that
something that's uh well we can buy it
uh chest.com store i have no idea
chess.com i took the shirt off of the
table that was out there and that's when
where it might not even be mine
okay so you still have a commentator
steel shirt i mean a very professional
oh oh oh here they come
okay okay so
is this the right size though okay so i
have one too
hey um
so donny has no friends
yeah i like to be professional during uh
during commentary broadcasts we'll find
you some friends i think uh maybe they
have to get more shirts so oh yeah yeah
it's really not you it's them right
that's what i needed to hear back to
back to business no no no no
look at the side of the car nakamura's
face right there dingley ram with his
tiny chair how about not mention that
this round i always mentioned dingler
instead
actually why did we ask emil about the
chairs
what about how they were the chair
selection what was the process like yeah
you were asking about
online over the porches you know the
difficulties that's not the important
question
it's very important though because
i i like his answer about the how
important is to preserve the over the
board tournaments especially like i've
read a lot of studies that even now
our brain is perceiving like what is
happening online is still that's it's
it's not real like the so it's important
for us to be here before i get into
discussion what is reality i'm gonna
reset i'm gonna remind everybody of
where we are what we're looking at you
know who you're looking at that's a car
nakamura but in this event it has been
yon napomneshi that has been the story
line he has been stellar and he leads
with nine points out of 13 games looking
for a record nine and a half points or
even more if you get windhave 10 points
out of 14 that's unheard of in these
parts but as we look at second and third
place we have hikaru nakamura taking on
dingley wren that matchup is
in the event that magnus carlsen comes
july 20th we now know that's the
deadline that fide is giving him
international chess day that if he says
i'm not playing then hikaru or dingley
wren will square off against the
underpan machine
yeah and that makes the second place
game more critical than a second place
game has ever been
at the candidates you can sense the
intensity on dingley around and he cars
nakamura's faces ikaro needs a draw to
clinch second place he's half a point
ahead of dingley round with that
win in the penultimate round against jan
christoph duda
and they're in an end game the end game
looks completely equal but
dingle run we talked about it he played
rook dc-1 we liked that move
and maybe just maybe
he's starting to find and uh squeeze
some water from the stone almira i'm
starting to like digly rent's position
and in the last bunch of moves the
bishop went to d6 i think this was a
really important moment hikaru brings
his bishop to d6 rather than trading off
the bishops on f6 so there must have
been something here he didn't like
probably something to do with this rook
c7 check idea maybe knight to d4 because
now e6 is under attack and if you take
with knight takes d4 there's this
inter-mezzo rook c7 check and there's a
lot to work out here we have the benefit
of the evaluation bar saying it's just
even but with that rook being first to
the punch that's often how we lose games
it doesn't matter that it's a level
position we don't feel comfortable
because we're passive and our opponent
seeks some activity so maybe that's what
hikaru didn't like but he plays bishop
to d6 here and after rook c2
knight e7 he's rerouting his pieces he
trades the light square bishops but
while he protects e6 perhaps it's the c6
square that's going to be a problem in
this game as the last of knight to b3
this rook can come to c6 there's no more
a5 and maybe this knight can go to a5
black is the worst c5
black is uncomfortable and you're just
one temper short if you could play
knight b6 knight c4 but here in knight
b6 will be met with knight
a5
that's really annoying and here is the
difference uh
between f2 and a3 and f5 e6 it's in the
endgame you can really feel it and
that's why i think well humans feel that
how unpleasant this position is what the
computer might defend stubbornly
i think that hikaru
doesn't like his position that much
right now and he's looking uh for the
ways to um
well to simplify it to simplify this
yeah i mean to piggyback off volumiera's
point we talked about this yesterday um
in ali raza's game
it it's not just the fact that white is
0.4.5 better in and of itself that's not
a particularly daunting evaluation for a
car it's the fact that he suddenly has
to deal with a worse position when
two seconds ago he could taste the sweet
nectar of second place
and the life seemed to be inevitably
getting sucked out of the position all
of a sudden why does the c file a great
square for the knight the d4 score for
the bishop blacks knight doesn't have
too many prospects this could get really
ugly if white gets a rook to c6 and
black no longer has that a6a5 pawn break
at all
so
hikaru i think just needs to take a
couple of minutes here to
re-adapt himself to this new set of
circumstances he made it a serious
inaccuracy i'm not sure exactly where
maybe it was more than one
but he's got a new set of challenges
that
you know that he needs to
to adapt himself to right now and you
mentioned how in that
in the game he's not going to be able to
play a5 this might have been his last
opportunity to do so he said brought his
knight to e7 he was so concerned about
this pawn e6 which i understand it's
uncomfortable bishop staring down at a
king but a5 it
but what if i don't want to take i was
calculating rook c1 rook to c1 i think i
can i think that was ding's idea yeah
undoubtedly a takes before yet to
calculate rook c6 bishop c6 rook takes
and then this pawn on a3 is captured
bishop e5
similar to what duder rejected yesterday
kind of position with two pieces for a
rook and a very weak king it's hard to
make yourself go for this and
the king that's what's really important
if this king we're already on h7 you'd
be like yeah black i'm doing this in a
heartbeat because yeah i have two past
pawns i'll get my rook in but because
the king is where it is over here on f7
you see the first check you see the
second check where's my king going if i
go here there's a fork on f7 if i go
here i'm giving another pawn with check
and it says it's just a repetition the
king should go here the bishop goes back
and forth that is so difficult to not
only visualize but to properly assess
from this far away and that's a great
example from yesterday's game when akara
was playing in zion chistop duda there
was that position with a rook and a past
pawn for two minor pieces and actually
i'm just gonna bring it up i'm gonna
bring up that position if i can because
uh i think it's really instructive to
show uh some of these similarities but
it's hard to
make it work because
i don't forget them side by side
i'm going to try to pull up the game
from yesterday with uh
chistop duda and hikaru nakamura so if i
they don't mind there was that moment
right around where was it right around
here yep wow you literally clicked on a
random moment happened to be right this
is yesterday's game where what we would
have seen was after this sequence right
d7 hikara came in here and talked about
everything and he also thought that his
winning chances were great because after
a4 takes takes rook to d7
you see bishop c7 bishop takes e5 this
rook takes g7 be mate so even though the
engine says zeros it's just equal it's
not the case but
it's very very very difficult to see
this from a mile away
yeah
uncanny similarity really exact same
material imbalance
very similar situation
and the consequences are not as severe
for hikaru who rejected this line due to
playing knight c7 basically many was
lost
here hikaru obviously still has
excellent chance i mean i don't even
want to say drawing chances that implies
the position is lost
you know he's worse
he still has a very solid position but
i think he's doing the right thing and
taking a long time to figure out how he
wants to arrange his pieces what
defensive formation is going to be most
solid
maybe the pressure did get to him
it's very possible and maybe just digly
wren's
maneuvering was
a bit seems seemingly innocuous but also
confusing what's he going for it seems
like he's just making moves and then
suddenly with the pressure heading
towards the e6 pawn hikara felt he had
to trade light square bishops and one
idea i'm thinking about for him right
now is his move g5 it's very committal
though uh making a move like this and it
opens up the bishop staring into empty
airs but after the move g5 if you trade
on g5 i could see a future where black
moves the king brings this rook over
here and there could be a party down the
h file it's very far away especially
with the rook landing on c6 but this
kind of play with pawns pushing on the
king side it could give black the
necessary
counter play because right now white
isn't having all the fun but here the
white kings has this refuge he can play
king f1 and king e2
right
so
he's made a different move he brought
his bishop to e7
very clearly aiming for this pawn i
think g3 is automatic
yeah you don't want to go h5 here i mean
maybe you do
it's good from a positional standpoint
but it creates an additional target
so i think ding
is going to play g3 it's a lot more
congruent to his style and this is more
forcing right not f6 you probably have
to take on f6 and this still is going to
be better for white of course but you've
allowed some trades you need to be
certain because eventually this king can
come up to g5 and start going after this
pawn that's an overextended pawn in the
end game which becomes a target rather
than a strength we saw yesterday that
hicar's knight landed on g6 that's where
it's useful if this knight for dingley
pen could get the g6 it might be uh
having a second that's easy knight c5
d304 g6 what's stopping you just wrap
around this way right but the point is
it's pawn on h5 now becomes a clear
target that black will go after so and
especially in this position as strange
as it could be this the knight is much
better than the bishop on f6
yes
yes it's true and this knight such a
nuisance over on the queen side
you want to trade these pieces because
the knight on d5 is very very strong
here and
oh he played h5
all right i mean in dingley run i trust
what do i know
i don't like that move though me neither
i feel like
the yes you're stopping g5
but that was not dangerous enough of an
idea to warrant creating another target
i really and hikaru was surprised you
could tell he raised his eyebrows
it just felt unnecessary because if you
play g3 you maintain the status quo
and white controls this open file here
blacks control the d file well there's a
knight in the way and if you move the
knight to b6 as almira said the knight
just goes to a5 taking away your only
square this bishop can come to d4 if you
try to trade off bishops thinking that
bishop d4 is annoying once we get a
position like this and the rook comes to
c6
black is completely frozen my knight is
going to wrap right back around to b3
into d4 c5 this a6 pawn is a target in
addition to e6 so i think that
dignitarian would have been better
served sitting on the position showing
some more patience here
and hikaru made a quick move bishop f6
and got up because he wants to take back
on f6 with knight and this h5 pawn is
immediate target i think that ding
wanted to play the position uh with the
pawn on g2 if black plays g5 but not
with the g3 uh
the
variation that i was analyzing is that
let's say if you play g3 let's play
black plays g5 so you'll take on g5 you
take on g5 and then i will continue with
g4 and
he
with black would work
yes on the next move so i think he
didn't like uh
this setup and he didn't want to weaken
the f3 square
yeah there becomes a bit of a bind there
especially when black's rooks end up on
the h-file and the king is perfectly
safe for white so you have to worry
about that and will this amount to
anything more than
an optically pleasing position because
we look at this we love white's rooks we
feel very good about it but at some
point you actually pinpoint a target and
then start hammering away at it and it's
not easy to do that you get one rook to
c6 but you can't get another rook on the
sixth rank so you're right amir maybe g3
was worrisome for dingley wren but
considering how quickly hikaru played
bishop f6 he understands that this pawn
on h5 it might not be long for the sport
but
it's uh
it's a devious plan actually i think
what he wants he wants to take on f6
knight takes f6 then
uh
white infiltrates no no
infiltrates on c6 and knight c5 so while
your knight is going to be on h5 far far
away in a galaxy far far away i will
take your a6 spawn and threaten the e6
that was the plan i thought
it's a really good point though that
black's knight gets distracted from d5
over to h0 just to win this rook pawn
and in the meantime as you're saying the
white's pieces start
coming into the attack and might just
win upon right back yes a very strange
deflection yeah
this is a very interesting idea though i
know the
the engine
uh
through through its mouthpiece the eval
board the evo bar is not approving of
this
a lot of people might look at this and
say wait a second but i can just play e5
and chase the bishop back but that's
exactly what ding wants he wants to
bring the bishop i think back to b2
and what has been the consequence of the
movie five yeah you're pointing out the
f5 pawn i would also indicate the d5
knight has lost its anger
and rook c6 and knight c5 with black's
pieces suspended in mid-air
this becomes a lot more unpleasant
the downside of white wasting well not
wasting spending a bunch of tempe on
this is that black does get a chance now
to get the d5 knight around two c4
knight b6 is possible here
but
i can see why he car would potentially
reject this option in knight a5 prevents
knight c4 so
i wouldn't rush to criticize ding's
choice i think it's creative it's
interesting
maybe not objectively best though and
the opening of the sixth rank could have
serious repercussions and the bishop one
of six defensive piece the e5 pawn can
be targeted maybe the knight hops into
c6 at some point so i agree that even
though
immediately the evaluation bar says nah
that's not so great that it becomes
difficult for a hikaru in other ways
after playing e5 you solve one problem
but you create other problems for
yourself but hikaru he's thinking right
now he played bishop f6 quickly he's not
going to play so quickly on this move
and he's deep in concentration well the
civil bar should not be trusted in these
positions
yeah i mean the same thing happened i
think we don't have to pull it up but
ding's gaming into duda i took a closer
look at it it was an equal end game
completely equal end game and then five
seconds later it was winning for ding
where the black pieces in that game i
think he did something very similar he
chose a bunch of moves
where
there was an obvious reply
uh that a lot of people just assume
solves all problems but in fact creates
a bunch of other problems
and duda didn't want to change the
nature of the position and that allowed
ding to get good squares for his pieces
and i think he's trying to do something
similar here posing hikaru with
unpleasant and unenviable dilemmas
only time will tell if this strategy is
going to be successful for a second time
and dingley wren you know he pushed his
pawn to h5 we weren't so sure about that
move but he followed up with bishop d4 a
very clever attempt and that's
how you beat these super strong players
they don't just blunder they don't hand
you the game you make
them
you force them to make a decision do i
push my pawn to e5 and hikaru he knows
he can play this with e5 attack the
bishop but he doesn't really want to
because his e6 pawn as you were
mentioning done is so important covering
the d5 knight and covering the f5 pawn
so these little decisions it's like a
micro decision every single time rather
than like here you go here's my bishop
take it you win the game it's always
like um increasingly uncomfortable i
don't know how to handle the dynamics
here and so i think bishop d4 was a
really really good move but speaking of
good moves we got to get going look at
the top left there whoa richard report
everybody
that is
perhaps the game's most creative player
he just pushed his pawn to g5 where two
black pawns can capture it we'd love to
see it i don't think major loves to see
it but the last moves if we bring up an
analysis board we haven't gone far it
looks completely different just because
the pawn sacrifice but the bishop one's
f7 g4 and h6 and what a cold shower g5s
h6 was supposed to stop g5 and report
says no no no in we go
i think that dania has to switch it to
shuffle it up a little bit and start
saying damn boy
doesn't have the same ring to it though
wow g5 what happens after
h takes g5
i h4 i mean i first said knight takes
gpa maybe maybe
and then rook takes
okay g1 and it's not like it's mate
immediately it's just that white
has a lot of pieces on the king side i
mean how many arrows do you want me to
join you may go fully caru yep like
this position looks
really unpleasant n93 knight f5 also
yeah once the queen moves 93 knight five
everything comes to the party and what's
interesting is if we
look at the evaluation bar and main
objective here that it said that white
was about plus one
something like that it's going to change
its mind as it gains more depth
and we know that white's position is
better but if the position remains
closed
it's an advantage because you have more
space not because you can actually do
anything concrete so g5 is one of these
forcing variations that will
put timor java up into the think tank
whereas move like knight h4 knight f5 we
understand that this is going to be
pleasant for white but black will play
knight f8 knight e6 or knight g6 and do
very much the same thing so it's
pleasant for white but nothing special
as these top grandmasters like to say
whereas g5
is a shot out of nowhere but a shot
heard round the world because this king
on g8 it's going to fall directly under
the rooks fire i was thinking that well
that's was the word that i learned
yesterday so is this the right situation
to say that he's not clinging on his g4
pawn
he's jettisoning that pawn okay and like
what is the past tense of clone
okay
like clang
clank to my pawn and i guess i'm flanked
to my place no clown clown we should
also find h4 in addition knight takes g5
looked like a lot of fun but if you
don't feel like sacrificing a full piece
you can just play h4 and that way you
open up lines for the rook and we don't
like being down material but when you
sacrifice a pawn you get an open file
for a rook and that's really good when
you're attacking
yeah black's best move would be to put
the rook over here
this is
this is a wildly unpleasant position to
face you might have to start running
with your own two feet
king f7 yes because if you're taking on
h4 it's me it's immediately made quick
queen h6
yeah and then there's no but there is
bishop but then rook takes g7 and rug oh
and if we if we just don't want to deal
with the bishop same exact thing amira
spotted it oh no no no no
i was thinking with the queen on h6
bishop of f8 this line of course queen
checks first right and
ah but now if king of f8 you you have
knight h4 after queen g7 yeah or rook g7
knight h4 ouch
poor king
working rook h8
one last attempt and then knight g6
check says thank you
for your rook and white goes up material
and this king
is not any safer so
what
what an idea and that's why you want to
watch the last round because with all of
the inhibitions gone not that they're
ever there for a report
but
you see some
crazy ideas
and virginia has no idea and it's only
moved 19 but he has no idea that he's
better here he sees g5 he's like oh no
my king right right so eric rosen not
playing here but this looks very very
scary for that king on g8 so he's
probably worried his calculation has
improved over the tournament yeah so i
think that majaba will lead them to it
because the game with our winner of the
candidates yonder pomschi and yanchez of
duda that one is also heating up with
this king on g8 if we look in the bottom
right
bishop takes pawn on g6 opening up that
king
for a piece though so
a lot has happened in this game but
now then it's reached its peripheralism
yeah
fg
is forced i would imagine and i doubt
you can leave this bishop here
especially because it's nope attacking
that pawn here
so we'll analyze f6 g6
queen
i guess so so you need to attack the g6
bars because you can't play queen f6 and
queen g3 is not the right way because
that allows the black queen to come back
to the defense so you need to put the
queen on such a square jan on e4 because
it prevents the black wind from
defending the pawn
oh and this is so beautiful because you
also have row so king g7 or b1 oh my
gosh wait a second so just like the this
is really dangerous just like the report
with java game where you might sacrifice
a piece and the engine says you're fine
this doesn't look fine for black this
looks like you're losing i would think
i'm lost here
but hilariously just like hikaru's
tactic against duda
where yon shistaff put a rook on a
square was defended by the queen and
then a bishop can distract the queen
there is bishop d5 in this position
lovely move which is a saving grace for
black forcing a transition into an
endgame now this time it's not as
disastrous as bishop d6 was earlier
yesterday but after knight e4 it's a
very complex end game all three results
possible in a game like this where white
has an extra pawn or two extra pawns uh
e and f files and black has two extra
pawns over there on the queen side so it
could be a pawn race
it's just a mess
this is
a super unpleasant position for yan
you know the engine might be giving
zeros but
even to see this line is is incredibly
difficult
but amir we've we said it throughout the
tournament that yonda pomshi
he hasn't been perfect but many games
he's played engine-like when he needs to
not only he's played engine-like but
also i think that one important point
that he revealed also during his century
he said that he's kept his energy he
didn't play a single game i think which
lasted more than six hours so
he still has the energy to calculate in
this game and uh what is the time by the
way i cannot see an hour for yon and 32
minutes 49 seconds for yanchez
so he still has enough time to figure it
out plenty
but
f takes g6 seems forced to me here i'm
guessing he's like just considering the
follow-up that's what these players
typically do where they know they have
to do this step one but they want to
make sure that they have a
response ready actually there is a small
trick that my coach
vault taught me alexander chernin is
like oh he worked with even with fabiana
caron and he said to me that if this
move is completely forced then you have
to make it because you have to move
closer right because then they well you
still have a better vision of the
position
after i've take g6 so maybe we can have
a
closer look if there's anything else
i have to play queen e4 i don't think
there's a no another option you need to
put pressure here
open up your rook
for the attack and
king g7 is in force so just like my
natural reaction to defend the pawn but
there must be plenty of other options
it's important to point out that queen
takes g6 is not a mate threat i think a
lot of people would assume that it is
but
the threat in heron and queen takes g6
is that you lose the bishop like the
threat is queen takes g6 followed by
queen takes c6 so
hype theoretically black could create a
counter threat
such as attacking white rock on e1 for
instance a move like queen d2
and uh the engine likes this move queen
takes g6 king f8
just to show that the rook now is
hanging here and that's why the
evaluation bar drops so you defend your
bishop tactically but try and assess the
position after rookie three try and
convince yourself that black is okay
after after rookie three
you know this is a terrifying position
and i understand that the computer
when the computer finds a defense you
always think it's obvious oh just this
and this and black is fine but put
yourself in the shoes of someone who
actually is looking at this position
from a distance of four moves
i mean your hands are shaking it's
terrifying this looks so scary
i mean it looks like you're mated and we
know from yesterday's game yan chest of
duda he made an assumption based on a
version very far down the line i think
that in a player's head you think that
this is just winning for white you
dismiss it even though it appears that
after queen d1 check king chu black has
the saving resource rook takes d6 and
that makes a lot of sense but from
forever away it's hard to
uh see all this oh and rook f3 check
queen takes up three and all of a sudden
black has amassed
a tremendous amount of material for the
queen and here black is winning right
because your pawn is pushing and your
king is actually quite safe with your
two bishops around it but that's
again it's light years away and
hard to spot but we are seeing this
variation nepo got up and then do the
moon he's like i don't care you're not
stopping me from going to the bathroom
no he's not and
well this is going to be a really
interesting turn of events because for
like yonda palmashi his king is in
danger for yanches of duda he's down a
minor piece so
uh
accuracy required by both
what a position
yeah what a what a fun one i'm looking
at all the games because all of a sudden
the game between ali reza farouja and
five under carwana that one is getting
spicier and i think
as we take a look at that game that
maybe alareza he got impatient the
position was closed we've seen
throughout the event that
already he wants more
exciting games dynamic positions and as
we bring this one up and analyze it a
little bit here
f5 the last move by alireza and that
allows
white to initiate a series of trades and
i'm going to show that let's bring up an
analysis board here because i want to
show you uh knight dominating over a
bishop e takes f5 bishop takes f5 knight
takes queen takes bishop takes c5 bishop
takes c5 and then you put this knight on
e4 and because there are no pawns on the
adjacent files to kick this knight out
this is
an amazing it's a stallion on e4
i was thinking with the king on h1 the
rook on g1 and the similarities between
the two games
he was simply feeling forced to play
five because white had
this move g4 at this
disposition oh so he's looking over a
sports game
that's actually a really good call yeah
that's so uncomfortable but
but what but to me the move g5 here was
asking to be played
but maybe with a bad turn result you
don't trust your calculation and you're
worried that somehow g5 will backfire
but i like the look of g5 although what
if i play knight five
and we get a similar position where
block is to stop a point yeah black is
up which illustrates by the way just how
good white's position is
in the game even in the game
continuation here you're going to play
g4
in order to carve out
that outpost and car you know
permanently discourage f5 right and when
knight g3 into f5 at any moment
light square domination against a dark
square bishop where the engine says yeah
no problems here all is well but then
the players they're like no this looks
really uncomfortable for black because
only white can try to go for
a win and speaking of that other game
where g4 happened
um we're just spoiled in this round i
don't know what's happening gianna
pompeo wins the event and everybody
decides it's a free for all because in
the game between richard report and team
over java we see in the top left the
report actually sacrificed a piece and
the engine
does not approve so that was a big
moment here
instead of
pushing pawns
knight takes g5 played and the engine
not entirely certain but does say black
is slightly preferred but we were
talking about this position
yeah but the engine is giving first of
all such a position the engine cannot be
trusted in such a position at a low
depth
i think a detail that we cannot overlook
is that black can actually start by
illuminating
the knight on c4 bishop takes c4 is a
very nasty intermezzo
this is a bishop you have to recapture
and after h takes g5 white doesn't have
that many
gallons or since we're in europe leaders
left in the tank i mean there's yeah you
have your heavy pieces but you only have
one minor piece
and
black can get the bishop around from d6
to f6 in order to lend maximum support
to the g7 font i could see this fizzling
out really really quickly for white can
you although
and this moment here the bishop takes c4
i was wondering can i just go knight
back to f3 i was thinking about knight
of seven actually that's why i was uh
romanian
but i have queen d8 to f6 at the right
moment that knight on d7 comes in really
handy
that's true so bishop b6 and you play
queen f uh queen f6 here
it's not over even here like queen h5
and knight g5 is a possibility but this
seems to be
very gimmicky
that's why knight f7 was more dangerous
but i i was feeling
i had the feeling that it was losing by
force because you don't have knight a
queen f6 i have knight h6
oh after knight f7 uh-huh but i guess
you just take it yes no you can you can
just take us bishop with seven and queen
h6 uh well yes it's completely lost yeah
too many pieces
given away but
knight takes g5
we love reports creativity
but he probably could have just played
h4 as well so he was going for the
direct assault saying that i'm going to
win by brute force but with h4 the point
is that now you're throwing just take on
g5 and of course if gh4 queen takes h6
problems down the g file are going to
win white the game so
maybe h4
was more prudent
yeah that seemed like a perfectly viable
attacking option
but the main difference being that this
doesn't sacrifice a piece
but i can also understand report he
you know he he decided on what he was
going to do
and he didn't want to separately
calculate f takes g5
he believes in his attacking chances he
believes in the open g file
and uh it's it's going to be a treat to
watch this unfold and we'll see if java
can put up the kind of stellar defense
we've seen from him in games such as the
one against ali raza farouja where he
played over seven hours 90 moves he was
always worse not being attacked in terms
of checkmate but he didn't have to
withstand a lot of positional pressure
to hold that game so for java he's
thinking imagine if he wins this game he
goes to a plus one score and he had lost
two games earlier in the event to
hikar nakamura and five into karwana
everyone said oh this rajab guy what's
he doing here hasn't you know won a game
of classics since the 2019 and now he's
won two and he
could win his third if he shows that he
can
fend off richard reports a feisty
kingside attack but don't you have the
feeling that those were the games that
he won only because his opponents threw
himself themselves at him
the game indeed they ran yes for the
game of sakara i would say that i just
really liked uh hijab was opening and i
felt like he handled things pretty
seamlessly
and he also declined an implicit draw
offer right yakaru there was that moment
when even hikaru expected two more to to
go for the drama very fearlessly he
accepted a position with an open king
and then conducted it
impeccably so
i understand what you're saying let me
know like i agree that there is this
additional onus on the players weirdly
because regardless 2753
to to try to beat him but
he's really proven himself in this event
in a big way
and he we had him in the studio and he
was talking about how he felt it was
unfair for people to criticize his lack
of tournament victories
individual game victories because i
haven't played much since 2019 but as we
see here i mean java was a legend he
beat kasparov and linares he's helped
azerbaijan to three european team
championships gold medals he's played in
now his third candidates tournament he
won the world cup
and he's only 35. yeah what more can you
ask for the from the guy right like he
has done a ton
of in the chess world and
you know he he didn't fight for first
year but he's made his mark on the
competition there's one detail which is
always left out i don't know why when
people talk about his winning with gary
casparov in 2003 which is that he played
a french with black
well i remember reading that gary and
the rest of the term were very upset
because that game won like the
brilliancy probably
tournament gary but yeah it wasn't they
were saying that it wasn't actually a
great game that gary went wrong at some
point and then rejava capitalized but
because her job was a teenager
regardless how many people can say they
beat garry kasparov the number is not
very high so the fact that rajava could
do that as a teenager and has been
successful in so many other events it
speaks volumes about his level of chess
well especially here i agree because we
always analyze the game from the
perspective of the absolute truth the
aesthetical beauty but i think that
beating gary kasparov's like is such an
achievement
it's
well stands for itself it doesn't matter
how you do it as long as you've done it
and it doesn't matter how hikar nakamura
makes a draw as long as he does it he'll
get second place and dingley wren just
trades rooks down the d file pieces are
coming off the board that means that
karu is inching closer
to a draw and second place the game is
far from over there's still a lot of
life left here but with hikaru trading
rooks we'll just go back to see how it
happened he did in fact go e5 so wow and
another surprise not going back to b2 to
reserve the parking spot
on c5 for the night
can we have just a quick look uh at
bishop f6 i still don't understand what
happened here
just before he played bishop d4 bishop
f6 bishop f6
okay i don't understand what was wrong
with desperation and rook c6 i wanted to
play here no i agree i think this was
the way to go
maybe he didn't see how this is winning
i mean i don't see how the game is
winning but knight takes h5 you have
knight c5 knight c5 you will enter okay
six and you're gonna get this two on one
situation with black's pieces away
you know lounging around on the beach
this is a really unpleasant position
yeah especially if you do this i mean
this knight just goes to c7 if you go
rook a7 to try to kick the knight out
this rook comes to c7 offering a trade
because when all is said and done the b5
pawn goes and white has a two on none
over there on the queen side so you're
absolutely right that bishop f6
knight f6 rook c6 but you need to be
really accurate as black
but what what again take this
i hold ding in the highest regard
in in terms of his endgame play and his
technique i think is one of the greatest
technicians of our time in chess history
but this particular tournament it seems
like a couple of times he's gone for a
certain position
and then at the last second
just when the gates of success are
staring him in the face he he turns back
it's like that
overstated joke about three people who
are stuck on an island you know two of
them swim back and drown and the third
one swims 99 of the way there and he's
like i'm tired i'm to go back to the
island
just something about the ding's
decision-making has has been strange
and like you said the in the current
position the game isn't over i would
still take white but i think icaru is
very very close to
pushing ding's initiative back and
neutralizing it once and for all and i
would almost argue that maybe ding sees
too much
that he's like so strong and calculates
so well that he's always finding his
opponent's best responses and he sees in
this position that his evaluate
evaluation function is on point he's
like okay in this analysis board maybe
he just plays rook to e7 and now h5 is
falling and if i play knight c5 then
black plus a5 which is a very useful
move because if you lose a pawn you
don't want to have more pawns remaining
that might also fall as we just showed
in the
variation and down goes b4
but i
for me
it's all about h5 i still
can't fully get behind his decision to
play h5 here g3 just keeps the position
as is it maintains his advantage it's a
nagging advantage it's going like white
is quite a bit better here white is
better for sure and
so i think h5 was too committal and then
he ventured in with his bishop
out to c5 and stuff like this and hikaru
he's confident look at him
he's really confident right now there
was a point he got uncomfortable earlier
and and now he's back to where he was
when the queens were traded he's up on
the clock
and ding is just not not feeling himself
here hikaru knows that head shake that
right again as soon as i say it and
there it is he goes away from the board
hikaru feels this draw he knows
it's bound to happen and
for dingley wren you could send so he
keeps glancing up at ikaru he's trying
to find something to do on the board but
hikaru nakamura playing stubborn defense
in this game and is there a weak point
in hikaru's play i was thinking about
achilles hill you know so like what
could be described as
this like for hikaru
wow that's a
tough question i would say if there
isn't that would be a good question for
hikaru actually yeah yeah why don't we
save it for him if we can get him in the
studio that'd be a really good question
he might want to answer it but he has
been very honest um obviously all chess
players have weak points or moments
where they've gone wrong in this
tournament he gets five minute karwana
he castled and then that got him to a
tough position even in this game it went
from looking like there should be no
problems in the world and then ding was
able to press a bit so uh yesterday
against yanchez of duda he won the game
but when he was sitting here he was like
oh i thought i was playing like an
engine i was playing brilliantly so
obviously he's a human and he doesn't
play perfect chess but it'd be
interesting to hear his thoughts on his
own play uh because we can pick and
choose all these moments but ultimately
it'd be really interesting to hear what
he has to say and i'm looking
left i'm looking right then due to the
game against napoli no move yet from yon
napolis determined winner in the top
right
with karwana and farouja is a brilliant
knight on e4 against a bishop that is
staring into thin air on b4 in the top
left
i still don't know what's going on we
have an evaluation bar with reporting or
job of and no matter what it says i
still don't believe it i still have no
idea i feel like rajabov is sitting here
pretty stressed but
he's going to have to
really calculate not i'll look at a few
lines because he might just get
checkmated if he makes one misstep and
here i think if he plays bishop c4 do we
have rook g7 immediately or not or rogue
g1 maybe
so well and
maybe it loves bishop f8 but i wanted to
try rook g7 immediately aha so bishop
takes c4
it was like everything i
tried loses immediately but but you have
to try moves like that yes when you're
attacking the computer doesn't like it
so b rook g once king f7 i think is the
issue and then i've got too many minor
pieces kind of surrounding the king and
i knight f6 bishop fa rogue g8
yeah this doesn't work at all
but the move uh rook g1 certainly looks
fun
because the g7 pawn is under attack and
if you just play defensively with bishop
f8 after pawn takes c4 this is the kind
of position that reports saw ahead of
time whereas he made a sacrifice that
some may call speculative some may say
it's wrong but he's looking at a
position like this and saying it's very
challenging for black to play as white
aims from the f4 opening this bishop up
against this king maybe this queen goes
to h3 and rook to h5 all sorts of
threats here i think this is very
reminiscent of mikhail tall's sacrifices
now a lot of people just assume that
when tall sacrificed
you know he mated people in four moves
from the moment he's hacked but that's
not how it actually worked because he
sacrificed stuff against the leading
players in the world these people didn't
just fold over and die
but he got positions like these where
it's not like black is going to get
checkmated in the next two moves
but it's just incredibly hard to choose
one candidate move over another one so
you start getting to time pressure then
you miss some sort of follow-up resource
such as f2 f4 so
this is exactly how tall won so many of
his games
just imagine sitting where java was
sitting trying to figure out do i play
queen f6 or rookie 6 or rookie 7 or do i
take on cbor or not and as i say that
he's already down to 34 minutes you
could take 34 minutes on one move here
i wasn't even looking at the clock until
they moved 21.
oh my goodness this is tough because
white's plans include queen h3 in rook
h5 and he did just make a move queen f6
to start with and that seems to be a
good move by rijaba but in these types
of positions right queen h3 rook h5
check down here pawn f4 is overwhelming
the e5 pawn and behind it is the g7 pawn
it's just not easy to make an individual
move because we see five different plans
from white who is down a minor piece but
has
the
possibility to break open the position
so in in the game we saw queen f6 played
and that just keeps g7 defended i
assume
rook a to g1 will be the response here
because you're just trying to put more
pressure up on the g7 pawn and still
queen h3 is an option still f4 will be
available and there's so many threats
here
yeah bishop f8 i guess is
called for
but do you have queen h3 and rook f5
so the knight on d7 is hanging apart
from everything else
and bishop e6 intercepts the contact
between
the rook and the pawn and e5 so that
might be a deterrent
although bishop takes c4 could follow on
the next move
yeah we're going to get a position like
this queen g2 and g3
this king's never going to find shelter
so even if
it says that black is doing well you
don't even know do i take on c4 do i
leave that piece i assume you probably
have to take it at some point like now
because the e5 but these positions are
never ever clear and white has an attack
white has one pawn for a piece but the
king on g8 whether it's a rook g6 or
rook f5 or queen back to h3 it just is
a difficult position for black to handle
very very much so
i love this i love this kind of play i'm
a sucker for these kinds of sacrifices
and uh richard
you know he's got to play pretty quickly
himself because it's hard to defend
these positions but god knows it's hard
to keep the attack going
so it's not just a
you know
a one-sided story i'm expecting rook hu1
within a couple of minutes at the most
very very very natural move and for
rapport he probably needs to put
pressure on her job on the clock the
last thing you want
is to sacrifice a piece for just one
pawn and then start
thinking too much because you'll be the
one in time trouble and then you're
gonna have
an issue justifying your sacrifice but
he did play rook energy one we love his
chess style he just he's just so much
fun at the board and it makes it so fun
for everybody watching i have another
question for richard's report i really
want to know if he threw his computer
away
well if he could throw his computer away
and play games like this
the guy maybe is unstoppable when he's
fully focused his everything going his
way it's gonna be a nightmare for his
opponents so
i just love the way he sacrifices pieces
he literally doesn't care about material
equality he's just like let's go for it
[Music]
after jabba's move he better come back
to his seat soon but there we see ellie
reza farousha pondering his unpleasant
position trying to figure out how to
deal with that monster of a knight on e4
over on the top right of your screen
and it looks like in the bottom right
yonder palm sheet you don't you subdued
they're following the variation that we
were looking at and will napolmashi be
able to play bishop yes five
he's definitely gonna think about it
he's gonna play it quickly i think it's
the only move
i mean is there anything you can't allow
the rook to get to b7 or even the queen
to get to b7 on the fork i don't think
so but the reason why i'm
not sure he'll play so quickly is
because he's been blunder checking a lot
ever since his game against hikaru where
he just mixed up his preparation or did
something wrong it feels like he's been
making sure oh and as soon as that he
makes his move so he finds bishop d5
doesn't need a blunder check because
he's a baller right now and someone sat
in front of the camera as per usual uh
but dingley wren back on screen and
oh my gosh ollie razorfish will play
move h5 in the top right let's go to
that one
uh fabiano
he has this really pleasant position
with a knight on e4 and the last move
was pawn to h5
amir what do you make of it
i know nothing
[Laughter]
like i i felt that f5 was such a big
positional mistake but here i don't
understand anything
i i love white's position
right it's
risk-free there's just nothing that
black can do
that g5 was really necessary in the
position even though that
knight f5 still obtains the same
outpost on e4 but at least you have a
pawn
you know reza's gotten impatient
just so many times this tournament and
done something drastic
the most
sort of illustrious example was his game
against nepo wrong word but you get what
i mean
where he played g4 and h4 and he
literally the same thing f5 and then now
h5 and i think he's trying to induce h4
i think he wants fabi to go h4 i'm not
exactly sure why h4 is bad but i feel
like alireza wants to provoke this move
for some reason should i do that
i don't think so then you have a clear
target sorry mr p7 oh this should be
seven and there's a tactic
g3 bishop takes h4 and rook out four
and all of a sudden
it's a free-for-all yeah that's what
alright wants and so if you're fabiano
what you do is you don't push pawns like
that i would play f3 and if h4 i would
h4 doesn't scare me you can play even h3
or you cannot do anything if black plays
h3 white could even take that pawn and
get an open g file right and h3 there's
no infiltration squares because the g3
square is covered but my bigger plan and
let's even not play let's just go back
here is i was just going to improve my
pieces one by one now i have the g5
square in my sights and let's say you
don't mind and i play rook f2 and then i
play kg1 and king f1 and king e2 and i
move my brook over here and i do the
petrossian king march where i get my
king to the queen side now that's a long
story and actually i can just put my
king on e2 because you cannot possibly
get to the king over there on e2 it's
really safe but fabiano instead choose
the move
g3 taking a page out of your book dania
if h4
he might take it
yeah but the downside is that he's
weakened
the f3 score so early raza might double
rooks
on the app file maybe fabio also wants
to play f3 but i don't know if
you know
then the question arises well why did
you play g3 why didn't you just play f3
as you were indicating
you know is fabby being a little bit too
cavalier
with his king side pawn moves it's
always
very hard to assess exactly how you
should arrange your pawns in such
positions
so the jury's still out on on
whether this is a wise move
yeah he will do all this stuff f3 kg2 we
know what the near future holds for
fabiano but from there that's the big
question i love his position though i
mean it's just
uh i don't think it's stylistically
matches furuja and i think that
you can do no wrong essentially from the
white side
yeah but
at the moment i wouldn't know you know i
wouldn't go so far as to say that
you know fergus's position is still very
solid
fabby's gonna have to do a tremendous
amount of work to actually convert this
into
into something tangible but alireza is
not going to enjoy the rest of the game
that's for sure
no he will not 30 minutes to make
14 moves not that easy in this position
but i think he's capable and
oh i see yanchez of duda on screen let's
go to the bird's eye view
because
all four games are still in progress
here in the 14th and final round and
duda what's he
looking at ooh
yonda pomshi brings his rook over to b6
so he was able to save his pawns on the
queen side
and we were looking at a position just
like that right where it's an end game
chances
for both three results possible but jan
de palmasi played amazing defense so far
on this game again
and he's just been doing that all
tournament long it's like it was never
in doubt zero fear
i don't know if jan saw bishop d5 or if
he you know hoped that jan wouldn't find
it or if he strove for this end game all
along but it's a complete three result
game
it's a wild position and jan could not
ask for anything better
given what i think was quite an
unpleasant position out of the opening
elmira it's just
the nepameshi show right just all
tournament he's had three games where he
probably really was in trouble
now again young stuff dude it didn't
look good but the way he played a5 rook
a6 striking with d4
finding his way through this maze of
complications to give back the piece he
was ahead and now enter an end game with
even material
i just
you know i feel like yonda pomnashi
is
playing unbelievable chess the best
chess of his career and if he can end
this game in this tournament without a
loss
which i think it really will do a lot
for his confidence well not only he's
playing the best chess in his career i
wanted to say that he is back because no
one expected him to be back especially
after this pain painful loss against
magnus carlsen in the world championship
match so
um
he played
such an incredible tournament and
well this game is is just
the last confirmation we needed to say
that he is uh
he's the next challenger
and he's up to this challenge
seems like he certainly is and while
he's back we'll also be back because
we're going to take a quick break get
ourselves ready for time control and
well after this tournament ends one of
the biggest events in chess the 44th
chess olympiad takes place from july
29th to august 9th it is coming to
chennai india is the biggest team event
in chess with something like 180
countries in the open and 160 in the
women so it's a wonderful event full of
camaraderie a team spirit and a lot of
fun in addition to the grueling chess 2
30 a.m pacific time each and every day
right here on
chess.com and we see hikara nakamura
he's still in this fight for second
place his task is not over he looks to
secure at least a draw which would earn
second place and perhaps a shot of the
world chess championship match we'll be
right back
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
it was bigger
than chefs
in fact
it was bigger than the world
championship
it was war literally and figuratively
every aspect of the 1972 world chess
championship was a battle
the united states and the ussr were
embroiled in the cold war
ten years after the cuban missile crisis
u.s president nixon met with soviet
premier brezhnev in moscow despite an
easing of political and military
hostilities towards each other the
united states and the ussr took the cold
war to the 64 square battlefield where
masterful chess was played on and off
the table
the players couldn't have been more
different the american-born bobby
fischer was an eccentric and outspoken
new yorker with a particular disdain for
the soviet union and communism
boris spassky was the calm and refined
front runner of the soviet chess machine
that dominated the sport for decades
by 1972 bobby fischer had made a name
for himself as someone who wasn't
satisfied by just winning he sought to
dominate
leading up to the world championship
fisher won 19 straight games and
decimated to grandmaster 6-0 and then
6-0 in the candidates matches setting a
world record that has never been broken
however fisher had never beaten spassky
in any of the five previous games they
played
boris baskey failed to win the world
championship in 1966 but took the
coveted title in 1969 when he narrowly
defeated tigran petrosian in their
rematch
the 1972 match marked spassky's third
appearance in the title event but the
first time as the sitting row champion
in the months preceding the match bobby
fischer's demands for increased prize
money made the 1972 world championship
one of the most challenging events to
organize
but his tenacity led to this match being
the richest chess event in history
unfortunately fischer's demands and
antics did not stop there
his behavior before and during the match
created drama suspense and worldwide
intrigue involving some of the world's
most powerful people
over the course of the next few months
chess.com will be releasing various
media commemorating the 50th anniversary
of the most epic
world chess championship in history we
will be hearing from experts learning
about the players exploring the drama
and getting inside the heads of bobby
fischer and boris
we will also be examining the most
important moves and games of the 1972
world championship
keep an eye out for hashtag
fisherspotsd50 and join us on this
fascinatingchest.com
historical journey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh
my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
we know what that means the car puts the
jacket on the game is over
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
that is the genius of jan's performance
the fact that he really did make it look
easy
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
and these players certainly have left
the legacy here in madrid international
master almiros kripchenko grand master
daniel erdicki i'm great master robert
has i almost forgot my name yeah i
remember i told you i told you that you
will no longer know who you are i don't
know who i am because i have somebody
else's face on my shirt you know miss
amigos i've been saying it every day
i've lost my sense of self but these
players they're still fighting till the
very end here all four games all eight
players still in session here in the
bottom right hand side we see that yon
na pamashi and yanchestav duda they have
an endgame where we've been saying all
three results are possible in the top
right five-minute car wanna still seems
to be pressing with an advantage he's
got a good knight against a bishop that
doesn't stare at anything and a better
pawn structure for white in the top left
nobody knows what's going on in richard
report against timor java because that
game features a peace sacrifice from
white for one pawn but an exposed king
for black and then in the bottom left
hikaru nakamura trying to make that draw
fully concentrated here as dingley ren
has infiltrated with his rook on the
seventh rank so really great games still
in play here in the final round of the
candidates
yeah i mean this is mouth-watering i
don't know where to turn to nauseatingly
complicated end games end game in nepal
nishiduda middle game in the java report
throughout your caruana carboniferous
rather
shocking development there with fabi
deciding to open up the center you
mentioned the good night that night used
to be titanically great now it's just
good
so
i don't even know
where we should go i'm gonna leave that
decision to more capable people oh well
while we see dingley ren and hikar
nakamura try to
find out who finishes in second place
we'll get right back to our final
exciting day of chess but for those just
joining us earlier today we talked with
fide general
director general amil sutowsky who's
also a grand master because emil spent
about half an hour discussing the
candidates with us the world chess
championship and emil also made us gave
us a little bit of news here and some
insight when we asked about magus
carlson and when fide would like to see
magnus make a decision about playing in
the upcoming world chess championship
of course
we would not be happy
if magnus skips it
it's obviously
not the end of the world but
he's not just a world champion but the
dominant world champion and you don't
want the player who is clearly number
one in all ratings
to be i mean all ratings all classical
ratings for all the time i mean and we
don't want
him to skip the cycle
at the same time
we also don't believe that the world
champion can just say you know
it would be this way i didn't play so we
have to find this balanced solution and
we'll be working on it
uh i think for magnus legacy losing a
title like that would be would be this
but once again he's the one to decide
and we are we can only be let's say
reasonable
when is magnus carlsen's deadline
because you said you're in discussions
at some point decision has to be made
whether or not to move on from magnus
playing yondu palmishi so when
is his deadline uh we haven't set a
formal deadline
but uh let's say i would say july 20
which is uh
also an international chess day
is about is about the time when when we
will have a decision
well as we heard from emil sutawski
himself the deadline is not set in stone
but july 20th seems to be the date
that's just about not even three weeks
away now so elmira magnus carlson you've
been saying he needs to let everyone
know if he will be playing or not
he has to by july 20th well actually
there is one interesting detail which i
was thinking about during the break
let's say
magnus declines and he doesn't play this
much what he needs to think about and
very carefully is the next cycle and if
you if he wants to play he needs to go
through the qualification path and we
all know how difficult it is so he's not
even sure that he will qualify if he
wants to play
whoa and i mean i really want to talk
about this but i just saw a move played
in the game between dingley wren and
ikaro nakamura and all of a sudden
dingley wren has a sizable advantage and
we don't know if second place will be
for world chess championship match but
we have to go right here because this
conversation has been revolved on hikaru
nakamura entering the round in second
place but just at this moment after
bishop g5
ins after king f1 instead of putting the
rook to d8 offering a rook exchange
hikaru plays bishop d8 and the computer
is not happy
yeah right square but wrong piece
apparently bishop d8
is i think a pretty clear indication
that he car is not comfortable with his
position what is the purpose of that
move
well it might be to cover the b6 square
because white wanted to
arrange his pieces perhaps with bishop
b6 and knight c5
what is the worst case scenario for
black i think the worst case scenario is
a situation where white wins a6 and
creates a passer on the queen side
because
black's minor pieces are too passive to
be able to handle a
a pawn on b4 that that's surging forward
and supported by white's miners
so maybe bishop d doesn't attempt to
prevent that or at least discourage it
but man it's passive and white's pieces
are looking
real good all of a sudden amir a pretty
surprising development there where the
bishop retreats back to d8 maybe it
allows for a5 at some point but such a
passive position for ikaru
yeah this is a very passive position and
i like dani's explanation because i want
to play bishop b6 and knight c5 so it
doesn't allow me to regroup my pieces
and to put them on more harmonious
squares but on the other hand
i cannot find the next move for for
black
so let's say if i play something like
okay rook b7
well the idea bishop b6 by the way
reinforcing that threat can't play a5
knight f6 b5 is there
knight f6 i'm guessing white just played
bishop decent oh now
targeting this pawn remember when he
carve played e5 now ding's idea looks
genius all this time later the weakness
of e5 finally
bites icaru in the you know what
oh my goodness this is really getting
out of hand so e4 you continue with
knight d4
yeah this is getting really out of hand
and ding immediately
after only a minute of thought
on rook b7 it's on the board and so far
we have to give ding lyren so much
credit because he decided to keep his
rooks on the board at one point he
brought his rook from d1 to c1 i'll
bring up that moment again
not
a maneuver you see every day but with
the rooks staring each other down he
doesn't want trades because liquidation
would help secure a draw for hikaru rook
d to c1 genius decision by the way he's
just an amazing decision and just to
bring the rooks up to the c file and
hikaru he was so worried about e6 he
gave up the c file and then once again
it seemed like hikaru was able to
neutralize any advantage that ding had
hoped for and
the rooks were traded here rook d1 and
then bishop d6 so putting pressure on
that e5 pawn ever since e5 was played
it's become a bit of a target and then
instead of repeating
am i
not mistaken here knight bishop
knight for bishop c5
knight f6 is the start of repetition so
hikaru is clearly
either a afraid the ding had a better
move that he didn't play or b
he thought that he could more
effectively force the draw with bishop
h4 and the eval bar doesn't dislike this
but it did directly lead to the position
in which
hikaru failed to play
what seems to be the only correct move
and that's rook d8
in this position
yeah rook to d8 is offering the trade
easier
said when you know the responsibility of
the game because maybe this pawn could
get in trouble if the rook comes to a7
things of that nature but this rook is
about to go to d3 this knight would have
to move and the rook comes down to d2
and white's king
and pawns are not that safe so
we're going to show the standings here
really quickly because yonder palm she
has earned first place no matter how he
does but second place is very important
if dingley ren can convert his advantage
in this game it was if the live position
the last one was f5 to f4 then he will
earn second place hikaru nakamura will
fall back to third
this is highly unpleasant and f4 is a
clear attempt at generating counter play
on the king side he's trying to weaken
white's pawn structure and maybe
ultimately he carries trying to get a
past h-pawn because that knight from g4
can drop back to f6 and finally pick up
that pawn on h5 so i really like f4 i
think this is his best chance this is
clearly what he was relying on but it it
doesn't solve
the underlying problem of black's pieces
essentially now being permanently
confined to their passive squares and
amir what did hikaru standing up you
know nodding his head sitting back down
and he's still actually like nodding his
head bopping around a little bit
what does that tell you do you think
he's trying to convince himself that his
position is good or do you think he
truly believes that he has everything
under control
maybe it's the same situation as
yesterday where he truly believed that
he was much better and
he was playing for some positional
concept whether here he truly believes
that this f4 move will let him liberate
his bishop let's say you take twice on
f4 you you have
another resource of playing bishop h4
unfortunately you don't have rook f8
otherwise i think everything would be
perfect
in this variation
but here
he created
a few weaknesses but somehow you don't
have an extra rook
no and as then it was highlighting you
can play knight f6 and win this pawn but
that doesn't solve all of black's
problems because black's pieces are so
passive the rook on b7 is stellar this
pawn can become a target especially if
this knight starts jumping into the
action so hikaru will have problems to
solve no matter what and after f4
digniran pauses he doesn't just take
because he might be considering this
with f3 it looks surprising but if this
knight were to take the pawn on e3
bishop takes pawn takes a bit similar to
the game between five out of caruana and
already ferugia will have a situation
with a very strong knight against a
bishop that won't exactly find the most
promising squares and if you play a5 you
immediately drop the b5 pawn this e3
pawn isn't exactly going anywhere so
this is probably the type of position
that is really uncomfortable for icaru
because he's going to have to fend off
threats and he has nothing that he can
do on his own
there is a plus side of taking twice on
f4 which is that it approaches the time
control and ding he doesn't feel
comfortable in time pressure he's got 16
minutes
he's
definitely not an acute temperature but
after knight f6 you could play for
instance king e2 or king g2 and king f3
boom you've made time control you've
preserved
your underlying advantages and now you
can essentially torture hikaru for the
rest of the game so
my vote is with
taking twice on f4 it looked like ding
is about to make a move
now he's retracted his hand and he
continues to think
big big decision here
as hikaru trying to hold what is now a
clearly worst position
and dingley wren very concentrated right
now because he senses it's his moment
he can take on f4 he can play f3 he's
all sorts of options here and every
position
every resulting position is good for him
but he doesn't want to allow hikaru an
easier way to escape with a draw so
we are going to head back to this game
in a moment we're going to go to the
game of richard report at team over jobs
there's so many weird things happening
in all of the games right now but this
might take the cake
what in the world java he sense it
though he knows that he has the upper
hand here and
we're in a position where virgil remains
a piece ahead for just a pawn
and
it kind of looks like black is the one
who's about to attack the white king
yeah but i wouldn't be too influenced by
the evol bar and the engine is giving
a completely decisive advantage for
black where did it think white went
wrong is it this last move f2 f4 let's
analyze but but java let's not i don't
want to take a way
[Music]
and there he goes he was rooked to g6
and that's a good move great move
trading off this attacky piece that's
why the rook lifted in the first place
and it's a huge advantage for black but
after the peace sacrifice
we saw the queen come to f6 the rook
came to g1 bishop back good defense and
rook f5 the first step dubious wrong
direction lets the queen
occupy prime real estate
on h4 which
severs a lot of the coordination
between white's pieces and following it
up with f4 is the cherry on top yeah
knight d2 first so oh he goes back he
doesn't want the bishop to capture i
guess but
you can take this pawn if you'd like he
probably figured that his initiate would
fizzle out and then he's just down a
piece for a couple pawns so he brings
the knight back maybe heading for f3 but
after rookie six he doesn't play knight
f3 he goes f4 and rook g6 is an
excellent excellent move by rijaba this
rook is threatening the black king now
it feels like white has zero attack
this is
highly uncharacteristic from richard who
i think is just completely run out of
gas
it's a long tournament
it's a really really long tournament
but it still feels like uh in rajab's
game against thing that richard lost his
objectivity
yeah
i
i wanted to give him the benefit of the
doubt after he sacked the piece i
thought that h4
had the benefits of the psac without the
negative which is the fact that p sac by
definition sacrifices a piece
but again i try to give him the benefit
of the doubt but it just seems like he's
not feeling confident in exactly the
kind of position where he usually feels
most confident when he's attacking it's
complicated
and uh
he's completely lost the thread here a
pair of rooks is going to come off the
board black's king is the safest it's
been in the last 15 moves and white is
still down a piece and what a change in
storyline this is for teamwork of he's
going to score his third win if he can
convert this in the second half right
people were saying oh he shouldn't even
be here he had the lowest odds all that
kind of thing but team um job proving he
belongs he beat dingley ren a couple
rounds ago and speaking of dingle ren
the number one player from china as he
takes on
nakamura
more crazy developments here
okay we need to analyze this right away
because this game can be very very
important not just for the tournament
but for the future of the world chess
championship and instead of taking on f4
ding plays e4
allowing three
oh to cement the pawns in place
keep them away from each other after
it's a really nice move but 1994
95 or knight i would actually consider
knight f6 here
and just go for but the specific line e5
knight takes h5 and then i get my knight
around to e6
i don't know my voice cracked when i
said that no but that's really important
we've seen knights and e6 all throughout
this tournament how good they are at
blockading a pass pawn annoying pawn and
white would still be better here that's
clear but at least black would feel like
his defenses are coordinated but
you mentioned also this knight e5 move
to keep this pawn in f3 and it's not
easy to just dislodge this knight
because the knight isn't just protecting
f3 it can go over to c4 and
boo that might be what nicaragua missed
backrank checkmate thank you for this
pawn it's not backing up and rook c1
would be made so the pawn f3 is actually
used for attacking purposes
nerves
i think nerves are coming into the
equation as time control is being
approached
with
the players nervous for different
reasons dinkins sensed that he car was
losing the thread
and ikaru can sense that he carries
losing the thread
so
this is an incredibly tense moment ding
probably has to get his king up to e2
just to prevent this nasty idea of f4 f3
make sure that his king doesn't
experience problems so that he can focus
on maximizing his piece activity
and that line with f3 to threaten wow
background checkmate you don't even
think about checkmate and the white king
let's just go back a second here
this piece not getting to the first
frame how in the world do you expect to
get down over here it takes a while but
it is a very good move it looks like it
could just lose a pawn though so i
understand why hikaru wouldn't make that
move for a number of reasons whether
it's knight d4 and this king eventually
walking around this way it just feels
like by pushing the pawn to f3 you're
you know you're gonna lose it and yet
there was active counterplay that would
have helped tekaru
get closer to equality
absolutely that was great analysis
a spot of mutual blindness as ding looks
up and he takes his time and he's got
nine minutes for only two moves so a
good job managing
the rest of his time no need to rush no
need to blitz out the last two moves
because ding knows these next two moves
are critical once an hour is added to
his clock you can get your coffee you
can take your deep breath you can adjust
yourself to the new circumstances but
you have to make sure that you don't
give up a lion's share of your advantage
before you get to move forward and that
is what ding is dedicating his time to
but i am expecting him to get his king
up to e2
and not to give hikaru a second shot
at f3 i couldn't tell if he was about to
move but almira the type of position
that we're about to see if he plays king
e2 there are no
tactics for hikaru f3 would have given
hikaru that chance and dingley ren he's
a boa constrictor he wants to give you
no options if we look at this position i
mean black's queen side is frozen the
rook on b7 is excellent here so he's
neutralized everything he's preemptively
stopped any plans that hikara would have
so it feels like dingley wren with just
a couple of precise moves he's going to
force hikaru into one of the most
uncomfortable types of situations in
chess i think this game illustrates that
maybe
throughout the game icaru was wrong in
assessing
the positions
at every critical moment he was a bit
wrong he was thinking that maybe it was
equal it is a bit better maybe when it
was dangerous it was not well really so
so and here he missed this f3
opportunity because he thought that
uh it was not the right way to play
and amir i think you're making a great
point
and you asked earlier about icar's
weakness now i'm nobody to talk about
ikaro's weakness but insofar as
you know
as this question adds to our
understanding of these amazing players
i think that hikaru has had some issues
evaluating big decisions throughout this
tournament take his first game against
caruana short castle take his game
against rajabov when he gave up that
pawn he thought he knew he had enough
counterplay to secure at least a draw so
a couple of times throughout this
tournament when he struggled it's
largely been because he's mis-evaluated
critical ideas even against duda that
pawn sacrifice
he thought he had full compensation but
at some point if duda played b4 ikaro
would have had his back against the wall
so
that may be the only aspect of this
tournament that has not been
perfection for ikaro nakamura but will
he pay the price for it in this game
that's the big question and we know how
much hikaru nakamura respects dingley
ren in fact he at one point said that he
would potentially give his spot and the
candidates to dingley ren if dingleroon
had not qualified but the question is
not just about this game a couple rating
points who wins the heads ahead this is
for a potential spot in the world chess
championship if magnus carlsen declines
so as we see here yonda palm she has won
the 2022 feat of candidates will he take
on magnus carlson the reigning world
champion or
will magnus abdicate the throne step
aside and leave the door open for
dingley wren if he can defeat hikaru
nakamura or hikaru nakamura if he can
hold on here for dear life
who will play
that's a great graphic i just want to
compliment our hard-working team
who have added so much to this broadcast
with
cutting edge
really cool may i say sexy different
graphics you're like yes you can say it
it's the last round yeah you could say
that graphics banging that's a good
graphic so if magnus doesn't play uh
well we are sure that yami pam nishi
will play but what if
the second place finisher will not play
oh goodness yeah there are a lot of
what-ifs here that we don't know how to
handle uh but yonda pomnishi
he
gets an opponent it's gonna be one of
these three
and at the end of this game it'll be one
of either magnus or the person who ends
up in second based on the results here
and right now we just saw dingley run
bring his knight to d4 he stops the pawn
from going to f3 and
his knight is also venturing over
towards the king side there is going to
be a problem on g7 at some moment and
i don't know it feels like hikaru he can
bring his rook over to e8 maybe try to
get after this pawn on e4 but the a6
pawn is forever weakness
yeah i think a lot of people would
wonder why rook d8 here
is not a good idea looks very natural
and i think ding has
spent time calculating the line knight
e6
and check on d1 is innocuous but you
might say well but what about rookie
eight i can win the pawn on e4 if you
keep calculating knight takes f4 rook
takes c4
you should see that there's that pawn on
h5 we remember from nakamura duda rook
b8 check pre-move knight g6 and it is
checkmate whichever way you go that's a
beautiful construction using
each minor piece and the rook
to keep the king trapped that is
really
a beautiful checkmate yeah i don't see
very often study like yeah the king has
to go to h7 and then the knight
thanks to pawn for its placement the
rook thanks the knight and well no
thanks to those pieces this would be
winning without the bishop i think yeah
black is just checkmated on the spot so
yikes
exit yikes so that's what dingley red is
aiming for his calculation has been very
good throughout the majority of the
tournament and it's a nervous situation
both these two players they seem nervous
almira
you know they feel a lot of pressure and
uh here especially in this position
you should
assess correctly if you can give up this
bishop
well
bishop d4 bishop d4 and knight f6 can
you hold this position
this is a nasty position but i couldn't
remember the games are always drawn i
can imagine that this even is winning
for white because i i can bring my rook
to b6 or i could just play king t
up up
yeah
every pawn is weak here every single one
for black so i don't really see hikaru
going for this
yeah this is no fun that's for sure
and accaro he brought his rook to
d8 oh
oh or to e8 yeah i didn't think so that
was my uh
my slip there king e2 here is the is the
idea for ding that's a beautifully
calculated
idea oh you see what i'm you give away
this pawn with check this seems to be
hanging with king f3 hits a rook hits a
knight and the eva another evaluation
the variation doesn't end here knight
takes f2 says please take my knight i
was gonna lose that piece anyway and
then you get this bishop on uh knight on
d4 and now black is doing just fine but
after knight takes on f2 i think that
this knight can move somewhere and the
problem is that this knight is under
attack and if the knight moves the rook
is lost so we just need to find a square
for the knight and
then black is in trouble i need two
maybe like 92 yeah the closest to the
king
and it's a matter of technique here as
they say
because the a6 pawn
yeah it's always a weakness it's a
target sometimes you can sacrifice an
exchange and hope to draw because you
have a couple pawns but a6 will fall b5
will fall and then white will get a
queen over there so
so
king e2 or king g2 both look very
effective but this is mu 40 so we
shouldn't expect ding to make a move
until almost all of this time is elapsed
there is an hour added to each player's
clock
after the 40th move is executed
and what an important 40th move it is
looking at ding here just trying to
figure out what he's seeing
he would maybe want to play the f3 to
defend the pawn with the pawn but that
allows the knight into e3 with check and
the knight potentially into c4 and then
white's queen side is in trouble so you
can't get away with f3 even though it's
a move you otherwise would be very happy
to play but maybe he also compares the
variations
which would start with knight e5 knight
d4 and if the rook is better on e8 or on
eight
because like this position could uh
arise after 95 knight d4
uh just before
like e4 instead of bishop f6 knight e5
knight d4 bishop f6
kinky 2 here and uh his position yes
there there is rookie which is played so
he's trying to understand like
what is to his benefit we're going to
eight is probably better placed in this
position whether rocky8 is uh he's not
doing really anything
yeah trying to
put pressure on the pawn but you lose
sight of your own pawn on a6 and we've
talked about many positions today where
even if black wins a pawn on the king
side the queenside pawns fall so fast
and then you can't stop white's pawns
from rolling so
hikar brings the rook to e8
and
king e2 or king g2 such a nice move here
as dingley wren
he drops to
about four minutes here he is
one move away
from
time control or he's deciding between
king e2 and king g2
which could transpose to each other if
the king reaches f3 and you might say
well why doesn't you choose one of these
two moves well we know why this is a
critical decision
king e2 is hard to play psychologically
because it puts the king in the same
file as the rook
but we know that concrete calculation
always transcends
general
principles or general thoughts
and ding he prepares his hand to make
the move but no he continues to think
and maybe he's forcing himself to triple
check
squeeze the last minute out of his clock
make sure that he's trying to play as
precisely as possible
2 30 left on his clock according to the
latest update yeah and it's with just
one move it's
not too difficult for dingley wren but
we've seen him struggle and move 40 in
the past when he played against timo
rajaba for the black pieces he made his
39th move upon capture then i moved 40.
he said all of his remaining time and
we've seen it in the
in the opening video where we are
screaming oh what happened and it was
just a shock so dingly wren he needs to
remain composed right now as he has just
one move to make and he does not want to
throw away this advantage look at him he
does look nervous
well we should show a very simple
variation in this position after kingitu
bishop d4 bishop d4 rookie 4 doesn't
work because and there he goes and it's
king g2 that he chooses he goes the
other way
so he decides to stay away from checks
but mirror you were saying e2 a very
simple variations bishop d4 bishop d4
rook e4
king d3 and then rook g7 is coming
that's the
king protecting the bishop whilst rook
g7 next and that means the knight is
also gone that is devastation so that's
would have been
a possibility if hikaru tried to steal a
pawn he wouldn't have done just that but
after king g2
maybe there's an argument for this
bishop takes d4 you still
can't easily take on e4 because rook
takes g7 check will be very unpleasant
it doesn't actually lose a piece for
black
so
it means that you can try this kind of
thing but after
the bishop can slide back the knight is
actually
trapped oh
i didn't see that yeah i wasn't
realizing it either that this knight is
trapped so
i still have 95.
yeah 95 and yeah rook a7 you start
hunting for the pawns and if the knight
moves this check winning that pawn no
this is why bishop is better than knight
the knight's a terrible defender and in
these types of situations and there are
weaknesses on multiple flanks
by the way two things if we go back to
our bird's eye view we've got a couple
of games that haven't reached
time control yeah nepo dude is going to
be a draw that game's going to finish
first
crazy stuff happening on all of the
other
boards the nepo game is going to end
in a moment but
what is happening in fabi's game uh
chaos pandemonium
uncertainty pressure how did this happen
this is just crazy i don't even pretend
to understand what's happening in that
game and we're gonna bring it up here
because black's king looks like it's
some in some danger and then b5 out of
nowhere just trying to distract this
queen which is needed to defend this
rook on d4 so b5
was ali ray's move
tactically it does not cost you a pawn
white already is up a pawn it's a double
isolated h pawn but still so
after
this position we saw a trade on d4 which
was shocking to me by the way but it was
indeed moving on it didn't seem
necessary to open up the position when
the knight was so perfect on e4 but he
opens the position up allows h4 and then
plays queen c4 check and knight g5 this
does look threatening for the king in
the corner all right knight enemy g5
looks scary but after b5
oh gosh five minutes slides back to d3
what if you just trade queens
yeah you can just trade queen's take on
a4 and this end game is
a bit better for black now because you
can take on h4 play bishop d6
yes
this looks
really unpleasant for white
we see the trade i can't believe fabi's
worse oh and ba 96 you might say i see a
fork well i see rook takes f2 and a
handshake in the nepo duda game as
expected yeah that game
fairly peter's out for a draw due to he
just shook his head a little bit he's
probably like what more can i do or
maybe his pen is just not working right
or both
i think he's very glad the tournament is
over with yanchez of duda
it wasn't a good event for him but jan
napomneshi has made history nine and a
half points out of 14 games that is a
record in the double round robin format
of these candidates
incredible i mean this is a show stopper
mic drop you can choose your phrase
what a performance by jan and he
improves on last year's candidates
by not losing the last game and playing
yet another excellent defensive effort
to neutralize what looked like a vicious
attack by jkd
and
speaking of vicious attacks
we can get to that game in a bit but
teamwork is on the verge of winning his
game against richard report i don't know
what to turn to we've got so much
exciting stuff going on let's go to that
game because that one is really exciting
and we see in the top left
rich report throwing all of his
remaining pieces towards the black king
and timor java says i'm just defending
every move i've made helps my king feel
safer the knight on g5 is about to be
loose this is over let's uh
you know quickly see how we got here
we left off f4 the rook came to g6
knight f3 queen h3 just a nice move
keeping the queen safe and after pawn
takes we see a swap the knight can't
take because the queen is loose king
takes g1 doesn't really help all that
much so queen takes g1 and bishop h5
attacking the knight and queen g4
offering a queen trade and just bishop
e7 putting pressure on this knight
opening up the f8 square for other
pieces
e6 threatening the knight you have to
move it right no you do not here comes
rook f8 the point is if you take this
knight on d7 after rook f5 e takes f5
black has bishop but not queen takes g5
for a beautiful reason
show it trade on g5 you're like what
it's over white black wins no f6
the bishop on b2 finally announces its
presence intercepting the black bishop
white wins the game but paradoxically it
is black who wants to keep the queens on
the board because it is black who is
going to checkmate white's king if white
hunts for promotion queenie checking h7
don't take this no
and you're gonna get mated
h7 d8 queen might say oh white promotes
white's gonna establish material
equality look at white's king queen f3
and black can actually abandon both
hanging queens here with bishop e3 check
and it's a very straightforward mate
when do you ever see this never
i don't think i've ever seen this both
bishops are hanging and both queens are
hanging i guess the h5 bishop isn't
hanging but i've never seen
this kind of
position and bishop e3 check leads to
mate you have to take only legal move
and then no matter where your king goes
it's going to be checkmate the bishop
comes in beautiful the king tries to run
away the queen goes to f3 forcing the
king back to g1 and then queen f1 is
check mate so team over jabba perfect
defense when rich report threw all his
pieces at him and now both players under
10 minutes it's
kind of like a rapid game but for report
he just doesn't have enough firepower
left
well we were thinking that this is going
to be uh richard's masterpiece but like
how do you see the canvas it's totally
different now and i have a feeling that
this was a blitz game
i think people would consider it
potentially a blitz game because of how
messy it was the sacrifices uh how it
turned around so quickly but rajab
deserves a lot of credit you know he was
faced with what seemed like a an
onslaught and yet he
reacted perfectly move after move and we
need
to get to move 40 if you're the players
i'm not
playing but
move 40 is critical you get an extra
hour on your clock if you are these
players so that's what uh java and
report are looking forward to and if
rajab wins
he will get an extra 24 000
euros because he'll get third place
based on uh
superior tie breaks
and that's not a bad extra payday for
somebody who stormed back at the end of
the tournament and you want to hear
something
mind-boggling if icaru had drawn his
previous game
and rojaba
won today he would have been second
i mean
try that on for size given
the kind of coverage that rojava has
received the predictions and the way
that he started the tournament
timor drop of story is going to go down
as in many ways one of the most
impressive candidates performances not
from a purely sporting perspective that
honor belongs to jan but from the
perspective of someone who's been
overlooked and someone who started badly
this was unbelievable as he casts
a menacing glance at report you can see
what's written in his eyes you ain't got
anything here
and tomorrow job of borrowing a miracle
is going to win there's that look again
because the look of death could revive
his career he hasn't been too active
over the last several years but a strong
finish may prove not just the world but
to himself that he still has so much
left in the tank and that he's hungry
for victories but we have to go back to
our matchup for second place because it
looks like dingley wren
he is
against hikaru nakamura hikaru finally
pushes the pawn to f3 but it's way too
late and now the king is on g3 this pawn
f3 is just a target and a car plays
knight c4 going for the queen side now
and bishop a7 oh my goodness bishop v7
is beautiful we should show why king
takes f3 is in effect of ineffectual
because of knight d2 check this is what
icaro
is
it's kind of funny because you think the
knight comes to c4 to take on a3 and
then they reverse chorus and go to d2
with check because your e4 pawn drops
and then black is not even much worse so
instead of taking out three bishop e7
it's essentially a removing the guard
idea the bishop is such an important
defender here as we see hikaru swiveling
in his chair um he's trying to convince
himself now that's the facial
expressions i'm seeing it's not
confidence it's like all right i'm gonna
let ding know that i'm doing all right
but internally he's looking at this like
where did i go wrong
the position is on the verge of falling
apart after bishop b5 here only here you
take on f3
right
and then well i should go
for knight the three here
yeah keyboard for devastating f4 e5 move
the bishop from e7 and g7 is going to
fall that's the problem is there are
pawns everywhere and all of black's
pawns feel pretty weak
that's where white's king is becoming a
very important piece in the game and its
counterpart on g8 is absolutely helpless
the king is a weapon the end game and
this is exactly where we see that now
it's a very good point so
dingley wren he has
57 minutes in the clock he will not just
take a pawn because it looks free
because the knight d2 he
he has to play bishop b7 it's a move
that uh he can spot in his sleep he's
wide awake he's concentrated and i think
he will in fact play bishop e7 just
trying to
bulldoze down the seventh rank
yeah and if you're
if you're ding you don't want to take 40
minutes just because you can i remember
i had a game against ray robson
one time and it was it was the us
championship there were 30 minutes added
after move 40 we were in horrible time
pressure we were blitzing out 10 moves
we made move 40 both of us looked at
each other almost smiled we both got up
got our coffee beverage of choice
bathroom
candy
back to the board before we knew it both
of us had two minutes on the clock we're
right back to time scrambling on move
42. so if you're dingly run if you feel
confident then
you want to go ahead and play the move
king f4 here is also a possibility but
i'm fully expecting bishop c5 to e7 he
is just a couple of moves away from
securing
an incredibly important and impressive
victory and we see the feature chats
coming in a lot of people saying ding
has this let's go ding you can do it
a lot of dingley wren fans out there of
course hikaru nakamura has
more fans than pretty much anyone out
there but right now a lot of people
rooting for dingley wren
and on the other side spam this flower
to give hikaru power we know those copy
pastas they are always in the chat and
that's an interesting avatar on that
user
i don't know what to say yes it is it's
very very interesting yes
yes
well look at ding he's not rushing his
move i see his eyes glancing up the
board and looks like he's staring from
bishop seven in the top right as five in
a car one and allergies are frusia
they're in time trouble it looks like
black is better with that a po not just
better i mean much better much better
agreed with that a pawn but without so
many pawns remaining it feels like
fabiano has good chances to hold on
whereas in the top left and the bottom
left we see the evaluation bar all the
way down and all the way up well we
should keep an eye on richard report
because i think he might resign in this
position
he is not one to prolong the game when
there is nothing left to play for
that one is over all of the pieces are
coming up the word that bishop on e7 is
heroic it is stopping the pawn on d7 the
other bishop is going to pick it up and
eat it for lunch
and this game is simply
done
what a finish to the tournament for
israeli grand master
nobody
nobody
thought that java was getting a plus
score in this tournament they thought he
was gonna be the punching bag that he
was gonna finish a minus four and
instead he comes through in the second
half ruining other people's tournaments
he beat hikaru nakamura right that was a
big ups at the time he beat dingley wren
with the black pieces when dingley wren
had won three games in a row and now in
this final round rapport plays his
typical enterprising style it looks
really scary and java has just been
objective we talk about how solid he is
and to many it's like he just draws a
lot and there i think the resignation
has indeed happened teamwork with java
finishes his candidates with seven and a
half points out of 14 games and he must
be ecstatic i mean he looks happy report
probably not so thrilled but happy to
have the tournament be over with but for
rejava of what a second half
simply incredible and i'm gonna say for
the last time i promise a phrase that
i've been repeating throughout the
candidates which is that
anybody in the candidates can beat
anybody else
and that's why predictions and
expectations are violated every single
time
you've got everybody over 2750
everybody's experienced
and
objective is indeed the word that i
would use to describe fabiano caruana to
to not describe fabian caron to describe
temura java
it is certainly not the word that i've
used to describe fabiano's last 10 moves
what is he doing
he's
what is happening the entire second half
of this tournament he's been unwrecked
man oh man and just to get you to the
live position that we last have rook
takes c6 after rook takes h4 here he
made the f4 which gives away the pawn on
f4 wait what if you just take it
attacking the knight 96 attacking here
knight e6 will not pan out because you
can take on h2 check and after kings you
won you played bishop e3 i imagine
oh you're trying a rocket no
oh get that out of here now it takes
that fade and then you say oh rook takes
c6 and i take on f4 we're good
it's a draw but no black has this inner
mezzo fab he definitely missed this and
if ferrus sees it he wins the game
well but that is
from a distance in time trouble that's
such an understandable mistake and uh
the reason why i said fabian has been
unrecognizable is not because of this
particular blunder but the second half
of this tournament he is just losing
games left and right
if i'm not mistaken he's gonna end up
with a minus four
in the second half he was three wins and
four draws in the first half he's gonna
have four losses and only three draws in
the second this is the player who
started seven out of seven
in the 2014 sink field cup that was
beating magnus carlsen that was being
all the best players in the world and
then now something happened here in
madrid where
five out of seven to begin with he might
end up with only six and a half points
out of 14.
and this might be also like ferocious
best game in the second half of the of
the tournament he finally played a
reasonable game today
you were asking for it even though yes
he provoked fabiano i have this feeling
that
every move that uh eliza made today
starting with the five was a simple
provocation and he doesn't take with
which is still winning i think a lot to
calculate so he takes with the rook on
f4 they are in time trouble
much much better for black not the end
of the game by any stretch of the
imagination so
alareza takes back with the bishop on f4
and one good thing is that this pawn is
going to the a1 square this bishop is on
the dark squares which means that if
this knight tries to give itself up for
these other couple pawns you will still
not be able to make a draw in a bishop
and pawn ending so that's really
constructive and important and that
means this knight is gonna have to chase
down some pawns when knights are slow
moving pieces and knight t6 is met with
rook f6 here
just one lesson
yep that's a very important detail and
i'll share a thought that might race in
my brows
which is that if alright fails to
convert this
he might feel more disappointed than
after any of the other losses because to
end the tournament the win
with black and fabian again an opening
that fabby is
known to specialize in that would do
wonders first confidence for his ability
to go back through the games without a
grimace
on his face so critical moments here
fabby drops his knife back to e4 that is
the correct square and we should also
remind you that fabi has never lost to
all there is a fruit in a classical game
of chess so this would be a first big
victory for alareza and that will feel
better going forward because once you
get that first taste of victory against
somebody you probably feel more
confident and you shouldn't be scared so
94 i still think that there are decent
chances for five hound to hold but it's
going to be immensely unpleasant and i
would say that probably
something like
80 20 in terms of winning chances for
black versus a draw for white maybe even
a little bit more uh for olly ray's
winning chances but you can see this one
rook behind past pawn yikes maybe it
actually is just more
crooked c4 though is a very important
resource now a4 would be a terrible
mistake
owing to knight c3 double attack on the
bishop and the pawn so holly reza should
start by moving the bishop back but that
of course allows white to blockade the
pawn but black's planet is very
straightforward you want to bring the
king
to the queen side
and the moment you dislodge whatever
white chooses to put on a4
that pawn is going to rumble forward and
the fact that there is a pair of puns on
the other flank favors black squarely
because white that's an additional
distraction for white it delays white's
ability to bring his own king into the
defense and all your risers should be
able to convert this it's a good point
bishops long range pieces they typically
thrive with pawns on both sides of the
board knight very slow moving piece
can't help out on both flanks so easily
so it seems like fabiano made his 40th
move alireza has three minutes and
change to make his 40th so will he bring
his king over he certainly will not play
a4 in blunder that would be a tragic way
to misplay this position after he's
outplayed fabiano in the last pretty
much doesn't move so king g8 i like that
the step in the correct direction let's
just bring that king over
yeah this is uh
a position in which i wouldn't
necessarily trust the engine evaluation
the engine can be very myopic
in these kinds of situations if you
calculate six moves ahead you might not
see how
black dislodges the white rook from a4
but it seems to me to be an
inevitability great time control move by
alireza withdrawing his bishop from the
vulnerable square
and a sip of water and that pawn on a5
is ready to go and fabiano caruana has a
torturous miserable struggle for the
half point ahead of him
he really does well
frugia he's looking like he's happy for
the may the second time all tournament
almira
he's at a very bad event but he's made
mu 40 he has an extra pawn against
fabiano no risk he can just play for a
win and i think he's gonna win this game
well they've reached time control for
the moment he needs to
calm himself down
and to well to find the clear path to
to winning this well to convert in the
extra pound and i really like dynasty
you should bring your king well black's
king
maybe you should start with the king g
king gift seven
and then
if well actually i was thinking that if
you move your knight then you can even
play bishop d6 right in order to support
your pawn
dependencies he needs to adapt his
strategy
he will certainly need to adapt hikaru
nakamura on camera right now
dingley red in the bottom left played
the move bishop e7 and the evaluation
bar is going through the roof so dingley
wren objectively has a winning position
hikaru nakamura will try his very best
to survive this game
oh well he looks oh he looks shocked he
must have missed something in his
calculations and we'll leave him to it
but hikaru nakamura an unhappy camper
right here and look at those paintings
on the walls it uh so many luminaries
from spain here at the palacio de
centonia we will be right back for the
finale here at the 2022 fe-day
candidates
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
it was bigger
than chess
in fact
it was bigger than the world
championship
it was war
literally and figuratively
every aspect of the 1972 world chess
championship was a battle
the united states and the ussr were
embroiled in the cold war
ten years after the cuban missile crisis
u.s president nixon met with soviet
premier residents in moscow despite an
easing of political and military
hostilities towards each other the
united states and the ussr took the cold
war to the 64 square battlefield where
masterful chess was played on and off
the table
the players couldn't have been more
different the american-born bobby
fischer was an eccentric and outspoken
new yorker with a particular disdain for
the soviet union and communism
boris baskey was the calm and refined
front runner of the soviet chess machine
that dominated the sport for decades
by 1972 bobby fischer had made a name
for himself as someone who wasn't
satisfied by just winning he sought to
dominate
leading up to the world championship
fisher won 19 straight games and
decimated two grandmasters 6-0 and in
6-0 in the candidates matches setting a
world record that has never been broken
however fischer had never beaten spassky
in any of the 5 previous games they
played
boris faskey failed to win the world
championship in 1966 but took the
coveted title in 1969 when he narrowly
defeated tigran petrosian in their
rematch the 1972 match marks basket's
third appearance in the title event but
the first time as the sitting world
champion
in the months preceding the match bobby
fischer's demands for increased prize
money made the 1972 world championship
one of the most challenging events to
organize
but his tenacity led to this match being
the richest chess event in history
unfortunately fischer's demands and
antics did not stop there
his behavior before and during the match
created drama suspense and worldwide
entry involving some of the world's most
powerful people
over the course of the next few months
just.com will be releasing various media
commemorating the 50th anniversary of
the most epic world chess championship
in history
we will be hearing from experts learning
about the players exploring the drama
and getting inside the heads of bobby
fischer and boris
we will also be examining the most
important moves and games of the 1972
world championship keep an eye out for
hashtag fish response 350 and join us on
this fascinatingchest.com historical
journey
everyone wants to know what do the
commentators do on their day off
grandmaster robert hess
attempting
the unbelievable
oh did not stick the landing gonna lose
a fractional point for that
robert
better luck on the broadcast
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
and we see dingley wren focused here in
the playing hall at the palacio de
santonia we got a little bit of misa
migos but right now dingli ren has no
friends he is just trying to
be alone figure out how to beat hikaru
nakamura
he has left his own devices and those
devices have certainly been good enough
as he tries to take down hikaru nakamura
who's in second place
they certainly have been he's winning no
question about that but a difficult
technical task still ahead of him we
know what hikaru is capable of in lost
positions so so hikaru decided to take
with the bishop on a3 this is a very
interesting option
after bishop b7 he played bishop b2 king
of three and bishop a3
that makes sense because the knight
is quite well placed on c4 prevents the
e pawn from pushing forward
so from a conceptual standpoint ding's
plan
should clearly be to move the king aside
push f4 and then push e5 and then at
some point move the bishop away from e7
if he does it too soon then the black
bishop can return back to b2 so the g7
pawn is currently
defended enough
so i guess king g3 to me that makes the
most sense
and dingley red is pondering because he
definitely wants to move his bishop out
of the way but we saw this earlier in
some variations if you do it too soon
this knight can often come to d2 a check
first the bishop comes back then you
have to watch out for this threat here
so
you don't rush if you're white and i
think that bringing the king over first
so you can play f4 and e5 is a very very
good choice
but it seems hard for dingley ron
dingley ryan excuse me to
go wrong he was king g3 and just like
we're calling for him
daily ross exactly now versus another
character from friends from france yeah
on an episode of friends would be
amazing
unfortunately friends all we get are
reruns these days
i hate friends
it's a picture that there were no guest
stars
from the chess world
and those sitcoms friends no the big
bang theory would be the most they think
relevant
uh
show
especially that they play chess all the
time
who uh do you think would be a good
guest star in the chess world uh i think
i'm real nbl big bang theory now that is
what i'm talking about because hikaru
nakamura he was an episode of billions
he had like a cameo
doing a you know chess simul with some
of the actors uh you know the characters
i say in the show an envy on big bang
theory that shows over two
but that would be awesome yeah that's a
good call
yeah i mean i love seeing chess players
anywhere it's just kind of cool always
cool to see like a leading gm in a
non-tournament role
it's almost weird but
you know i always love seeing it yeah
maurice ashley has been in a bunch of
things so
yeah we could pick and choose different
parts of culture and chess players they
find themselves there but big bang
theory probably
you know
it's a very um
studious
show full of
very intellectual people
doing things so i guess that would make
sense with chess huh but i can even
imagine this series now like about chess
players why can't we take like four
chess player and uh a penny and
anything is possible i think we should
call it queen's gambit
i watched that that was a great show
would not watch the other show you
couldn't uh
get four chess players and have me watch
it no shot
no chance
with just walking around playing chess
you know and talking about their lives
that sounds like it could be a good uh
you're lying through your teeth
[Laughter]
but hikaru nakamura he is a star he is
the biggest chess content creator on
twitch and he's trying to figure this
out and he was shaking his head as we
went to break he must have missed
something or is feeling particularly bad
about a certain continuation but he
knows he's in trouble both he and
dingley ren they're looking at this
position knowing that white is much
better but how much better is the
question
well there's a ticking clock on
whichever counter play he curve wants to
find because if f4 e5 happens
then the long diagonal is intercepted
and white can move the bishop away from
e7
i mean or just push the pawn all the way
to e8 so
to me
maybe the last chance that counterplay
and this is a very hicaro esque move is
a5
it also happens to be the engine's top
choice but i think in this case it's
very clear why
now
if you take on a5 yeah then
maybe maybe knight takes a5 because that
attacks the rook
and what you don't want to do is go oh i
can play rook takes b5 and i can win a
pawn hikaro would love to get this kind
of position this is a very drawable end
game
especially because bishop b4 might
actually just win the pawn on e4 so
white still has to be careful and white
has to find something precise against a5
i am expecting hikaru to play that move
and i'm just going to continue the
variation because white ends up one pawn
and perhaps make it two once rook g6
happens but we know that in a position
like this after bishop to
d2 i think it's better than bishop f8
but similar idea that if you take on h6
this is theoretically a drawn position
you see it goes to the table base says
it's a draw and i've had this position
before it's not too difficult for the
defending side if they know what they're
doing so uh hikar trying to find a way
to liquidate to get the situation to
peter out to
h f pawns that would be a dream come
true and dingley red wants no part of it
after after a5 i don't think that ding
is just gonna take this pawn in a5 he
can make this move bishop c5 which
attacks g7 and that's a pawn that black
can ill afford to give up because the
king will probably get checkmated over
there in the corner
but if black doesn't give it up if you
play bishop b2
then
white plays b takes a5 and now already
black's queen side collapses
rook takes b5 for king knight and bishop
knight can come back to c4
but now the bishop if white once can
come back to e7 you've essentially got
the same position up a pawn
and then it's only a matter of time you
know f4 e5 and white's gonna squeeze the
life
out of black's position because cicara
would be out of counter play in this
case
gosh black's pieces barely have moves
it's just incredibly unfortunate for
hikaru because he's doing a good job of
preventing dinglerun from you know
ending the game anytime soon but even
when pieces get traded you feel like
okay with the fewer pawns i have a
better chance
black's position is completely frozen
thanks as pawn h5
yeah this is this is miserable this is
grim
and uh he's got an over an hour on his
clock does he carry nakamura but
in this case i don't think
the additional thinking time is going to
help him very much we've seen crazy
things happen in this tournament and
other tournaments
but
i just don't see hikaru pulling it out
at this point i feel like the process of
winning this is a little bit too
straightforward and ding has too much
time on his hands would you be surprised
if dingley ren doesn't convert this game
i would but on the other hand we've seen
this a few times so the players are
getting tired and this
this is also a very important factor
that we should take into consideration
that if this will be a
six seven hour game
um at the end it's
the mistakes are
[Music]
well
it's easy to foresee i would say but uh
they're understandable
right and carl i mean
right now he doesn't look too exhausted
he's really working hard at the board
and he's going to give it every last
ounce of energy because it's the last
game of the tournament so
there's no chess to be played tomorrow
you don't have to sit and play seven
hours of chess so he is going to try and
survive this one especially because
second place is up for grabs and it's
important we've been talking about the
storyline quite a lot and we did have
emil stutowski the feed a director
general in the studio he gave us some
updates some of his some fiji's
positions on things and the
question is will magnus carlsen play for
the world chess championship
it's important thing to discuss and we
will remind you of what emil sutowsky
had to say when we had him in the studio
of course
we would not be happy
if magnus skips it
it's obviously
not the end of the world but
he's not just a world champion but the
dominant world champion and you don't
want the player who is clearly number
one in all ratings
uh to be i mean all ratings all
classical ratings for all the time i
mean
we don't want him to skip the cycle
at the same time
we also don't believe that the world
champion can just say you know
it would be this way why don't play so
we have to find this balanced solution
and we'll be working on it
i think for magnus legacy losing a title
like that would be would be miss but
once again he's the one to decide and we
are we can only be let's say
reasonable
when is magnus carlson's deadline
because you said you're in discussions
at some point the decision has to be
made whether or not to move on from
magnus playing john de palma she so when
is his deadline
we haven't set a formal deadline
but
let's say i would say july 20 which is
uh also an international chess day
is about is about a time when when we
will have a decision
so on approximately july 20th we'll know
if second place in this event is
officially important but to the players
we've had hikaru nakamura in studio a
number of times where he's suggested
that he wants to leave that possibility
open and he entered today up a half
point over dingley ren he would love to
exit the round up a half point so almira
and we it's our last time to talk about
it it's the last round so magnus carlson
i guess do you think that he'll play
well i've said it already so many times
i really think that he
has to play it's almost an obligation
that i fell towards the whole world but
i understand uh
well his reasons and what i wanted to
cover then is like i don't understand
what is a soft deadline this danny would
say bring the contracts
like we you cannot leave us all uh
hanging
out there so we need to know the world
needs to know and
july 20th hopefully is that timeline
we'll see if it gets extended for some
reason but magus carlson was in madrid
he did meet with feta president arkad
devorcovic and emile sutawski so they
had apparently a quite productive
meeting and while emile was here talking
to me and donna he said that fide
generally is receptive to changing
formats to doing new things right this
whole question of should the candid
cycle be uniform and increment all
across the board and emil responded with
these are different tournaments they are
qualifying people for the candidates but
the world cup is different from the
grand swiss right and which is different
from the grand prix number of
participants length of tournament so you
know it's interesting just to hear that
he's willing to be adventurous not just
him fiji is going to be adventurous and
change their minds to change their
formats in various ways
yeah i i agree with all of that i think
magnus is going to play my my opinion
has
changed a little bit and perhaps
acquired some nuance as i've heard other
players applying on this topic
ultimately i think one consideration
that might sway magnus
is jan napomischi's play in this
tournament you heard
uh i mean it's all over the internet now
magnus saying that jan was criminally
underrated
in general very praiseworthy uh praising
of yon's play in this tournament and
something i don't remember who said it
ikaru geary
but the fact that magnus is ultimately
looking for a challenge at this stage in
his chessboard he's proven everything he
could possibly need to prove he's
cemented his status as the greatest
player who's ever lived or at least you
know he's in every list of the top three
he's won everything done everything
climbed every mountain all of that is
there he doesn't need to add to his
resume what he wants at this stage is a
challenge somebody who's really going to
make him think and work for it work for
defending the title and i think that
what magnus carlsen might have seen in
yonder palmies play is exactly someone
who could offer him that challenge who
could offer him a satisfying challenge
in terms of defending his title and i'm
really really hoping that yon's play
will have put magnus over the edge and
made him decide that yes he wants to
give jan another shot and yes this next
world championship match is going to be
worth the world champions time yeah i
think that's a large part of the story
and we see
faces from hikari nakamura up here but i
think
in addition to a challenge as he
actually just on eye roll ikaru is
really displeased uh with his position
but from magnus's perspective i think he
also would like format changes and
that's a big thing because magnus
carlsen the chess player he has many
phenomenal games to his name but as
magnus carlson the person there's a
legacy here and he has voice criticism
that the world champion gets to skip out
on everything and then play the winner
of the candidates this is not a new
argument from him in fact i believe he's
been saying it for 10 years and he is a
big fan of sports
and
you can't really name many sports
outside of boxing i guess where the
champion just gets a free pass instead
of a favorable pairing or something like
that so i think that magnus feels
strongly about that based on what i've
heard from in the past and it makes a
lot of sense and it's good to hear that
fide
speaks with him that they're willing to
negotiate might not be the right word
but they're truly
willing to listen to one another and
that way they can come not to a
compromise but to a solution that makes
sense not just for magnus but for the
chess world as a whole i also think that
the chelsea world is ready for these
privileges to be abandoned
because well if it would be uh maybe 50
60 years ago that was nev well
never the case and we still remember
that there were matches uh played where
uh in case of a diet the world champions
they simply uh they had they consider uh
conservate their type they preserve
their title
uh and it's a it's a very important
change
yeah
and we're seeing a great
chat here on griffos seven imagine if
dink puts on his jacket it's the last
day give this person a diamond
membership because that is funny that is
funny we keep talking throughout the
event of hikaru knowing what's over
putting on the jacket and if ding says i
must take one from your book so give
that person a diamond membership that is
an awesome
awesome comment
it really is
yeah check check up with some good stuff
once in a while or even more than once
in a while and dingler and got up for so
for a second i was like yeah wait
imagine if he actually put on his jacket
and he was like showing hikaru this game
is over let's get out of here
that would be nuts now dingley wren i
think he's so singularly focused on his
position
and we have one more game in the top
right between five under caruana and ali
is a farouza and this tournament cannot
end soon enough for fabiano started five
out of seven
was
right behind yon napomishi playing some
great chess
and
in the second half it has just been
one of the bigger collapses we've seen
uh it's about to be if you lose this
game with his fourth loss in seven
rounds from fabiano carwana i don't know
if he's done that in like 15 years
yeah and i mean
i
losing four games in a tournament leaves
me tongue-tied it's just crazy you don't
have any ways to describe it and hikaru
talked about it yesterday he seemed to
feel strongly that it wasn't fatigue it
wasn't
exhaustion or
something that happened necessarily with
his frame of mind well
maybe it is but he made the point that
fabi
after that incredibly good start he
could taste the world championship and
once he lost that first game
in the second half of the tournament we
look at his very impressive stats in the
first half once he lost to hikaru that
long end game it's like something
switched something just went wrong and
he kind of realized that he no longer
has chances of winning the tournament
according to icaru and that sent him
into a complete talespin that was not an
acceptable outcome for him and rather
than sort of coming to terms with that
and playing for second he started taking
wild risks he lost that game to duda he
lost that game to ding
and
it's just like his his frame of mind
wasn't in the right place
but what a disappointing last couple of
games for fabian you know it would do a
lot for him i think to save this end
game against ferrugia if he loses this
game too
it will just complete what has been
just a catastrophe
in the last couple of games for the
former world champion challenger
and what's very painful is that the
candidates tournament happens every two
years historically so this is your big
opportunity five in a car wanna 29 years
old he now needs to wait so he's 31 two
years from now if he even makes it back
and that's not a slight against caruana
we just have spoken about this before
that there are great players who have
made the candidates one time and never
again or made it zero times
maxine vasher legrov not to pick on the
guy you know we talked about him being a
big bank theory episode that would be
awesome i still stand behind that but he
played in the last candidates without
actually having qualified so some of the
best chess players in the planet
they have not actually qualified for the
event so there's no guarantees that
five-minute carwana is back in the next
candidates well it's also uh
if you should uh look at if you can if
you look at it from the historical point
of view they're simply not lucky that
they live at the same uh well at the
same time as well as magnus
whether there were so many different
champions let's say uh
30 or 40 years ago
even more than and they all of them had
a shot at the tide so here it seems much
more difficult
yeah the level of chess is just through
the roof there's so many fantastic
players of course engines will help that
out uh with the players we become much
more resourceful defensively they have
access to just the best uh
assets that a person could possibly hope
for and somebody who grew up with the
engines alireza ferruga the teenager
who's been having a really bad event
here donna you you keep talking about
this if he can end this with a win i
think that would do so much for his
long-term confidence it really would i
mean it would save
quite a bit of his rating he's 27 93
right now he was over 2 800
you know at this level a couple of
losses
is calamitous for your rating i mean in
the blink of an eye you can drop 20
points that's about what he's losing
in this tournament but it would also as
i said before it would help him approach
the games objectively it would help him
realize that wait a second if i play my
true style if i don't over press if i
don't overcook it and overdo it i can
actually beat these guys
and he didn't necessarily even play his
best this game but he didn't make any
crazy decisions he took a big risk with
f5 that was probably a mistake but the
moment fabio opened up the center he
responded very accurately so if ali reza
plays true to his style he harnesses his
strength i think he can prove to himself
with a win here
that there's a future for him on mount
olympus and there's a future for him and
the next candidates if of course as
we're discussing he can qualify and that
is far from a given
no guarantees in life in chess and for
five minute caruana i can guarantee you
that he is just so happy that today is
the last day yeah
it's
been a different fabiano and it's hard
to see we were talking about this with
yon chistop duda when he was suffering
yesterday against hikar nakamura
fabi who's usually quite stoic you know
even in defeat he does interviews he's a
very a gracious loser but you don't just
see him lose games this often it
it really is that rare and something
about the second half i don't know what
was in the water i don't know what was
going through his mind
but it's not the fabiano caruana that
his fans have become accustomed to
seeing that he himself
is used to being and i feel like he's
going to leave this tournament kind of
confused like what happened and what do
i need to change and it is a fascinating
process
the process of analyzing games i would
love to be a fly on the wall in the
cabinet of one of these players as they
and their team assemble
to look at the mistakes to figure out in
the case of people like fabian oliver
what went wrong in the case of nepo what
went right what do i have to preserve in
my world championship match what do i
have to keep
and what did i do that i didn't do in
the previous match i would love to see
that process unfold and that process is
critical for improvement at every level
whether you're 600 or 1600 or as these
players 2780 you cannot make serious
strides in chess without a sober serious
and deep look at your mistakes and how
you can use those mistakes to become a
better player in your next tournament
there's a lot to look at from 14 rounds
of chess you know we see the moves that
are played but they think about how they
were calculating why they were thinking
a certain way and figuring out that
underlying thought process that's how
these top players can make those
incremental improvements to get even
higher up the rankings
robert and we were talking about how
magnus uh well
was dominating and still dominating the
chess scene for so many years but if we
would
to change the system and would have a
democratic way of
everyone playing the same tournaments we
would have a universal system would it
create the same situation for example
instantaneously you have more players
who
still dominate the field but like nadal
djokovic federer and it would be easier
to follow nation national heroes and
do you think this is more interesting
for the audience now i think the
audience would appreciate i think
players would appreciate it
i don't think players particularly enjoy
playing the same people over and over
and over and over again right you get
this i mean the grand chess tour is
great for the top players because it
secures them a very nice wage right they
get minimum prizes based on their
performance so they you know financially
it's great for them but i think that in
any sport especially tennis you see that
in order for nadal to eventually play
djokovic they have to get through some
great competitors along the way that
it's not guaranteed that they'll win it
seems that way because they always
are winning these days but i remember
the us opened several years back where
this guy named john millman he was able
to upset roger federer and everyone who
you know i paid to see that was supposed
to be federer versus djokovic they
didn't show up because they were like so
upset that this
quote unquote nobody
john millman who the players had great
respect for he's a training partner for
them beat them and that's thing about
chess is chess players in any one game
if you see a grand master against a top
player an upset can happen it does
happen isla man tournament a few years
ago i think of the 2700 plus players in
the first round something only 11 out of
20 won their first game
in an individual round over the course
of the tournament those players will
rise to the top but that's exciting and
i think that the round robin format is
not particularly great what i do think
is or who i think is great is dingley
wren because we're being informed that
a move that just happened here in that
game is leading to a completely winning
advantage for him so hikaru nakamura i
guess got to say sorry to all his many
fans out there his latest move knight to
e5 was incorrect you understand the
impulse going towards the king side but
it was a big mistake
and ding has to make sort of a list of
priorities here because it's it's
unclear whether his priority is to push
his king side pawns and if he decides
that that's the top priority then f4 is
kind of a no-brainer but
you can also say i want to win the a6
bun first there's no actual hurry my
pieces are firmly ensconced in their
places let's win a6 prevent black's only
source of counter play and then
we can
divert all of our attention to the king
side and central pawn play so if he
decides that that is indeed his priority
then he should consider rook a7 but not
immediately because there's knight e5 to
c6 that's a very nasty move
so you should reshuffle your pieces to
make rook a7 possible and that i think
is exactly what dangler n is doing
replacing the bishop on c5
the bishop on e7 with a knight on e7 and
forcing black's knight into permanent
passivity rook a7 is coming this game is
on its way to being over
and that would just be an extra pawn and
once a6 falls probably down goes b5 the
knight and f7 can't really move
this is
it's just no shot for hikaru nakamura
right now so
early in this game it looked like
dingley wren would have no chance at
victory but somehow he was able to
slither his way through the position and
hikaru nakamura at first was putting up
some very capable defense but somewhere
along the way he went wrong and dingley
wren's pieces just having a perfect
squares
much more active squares than their
counterparts and now it's clear i mean
the king on g8 is not safe the knight
and f7 is relegated to defense of duty
and knight e7 check cutting off the
e-file before playing rook a7 that looks
like it's lights out
yeah it does i don't see a single
opportunity i mean white's pieces are so
nicely positioned they're all totally
invulnerable the last little achilles
heel was that possibility of a685
dislodging the bishop from c5 and there
goes ding
and no he goes f3 which
is probably good enough for a win
because it does allow me five yeah
that's
there's something in the variation with
97 and knight g6 that i was trying to
calculate maybe he was worried about his
uh
e4 pawn then you have to play here
yes knight g5 and uh
f3 here so you see he's trying to
anticipate this variation and he starts
with f3 and maybe after a5 you have the
same position
so i think it's likely that hikaru plays
at a5 so you're saying
here white can still play knight d7 jack
which is 97 and then knight g6 aha
knight g6 i thought that you were forced
to play king g8 here yes and now i
actually think i can play rook takes b5
and after a b bishop takes before it
it's possible that ding just decided
this position is completely winning for
him which i think it actually just is
because you're gonna play f4 e5 that
knight on g6 is going to survive
you know
an earthquake of any magnitude and you
know what's important if white goes
sorry black was 95 you can actually
still play f4 this rook end game is
completely completely winning on account
of that pawn on g6 just being a monster
yeah the winning plane is simple f5 king
f4 e5 push your pawns and
it's not really just one extra pawn it's
kind of like two extra pawns for white
and then one extra pawn for black so if
this pawn we're on f6 we might be
telling a little bit of a different
story but with the pawn h6 and
just to show what that might look like i
can play f5 king f4 i'll just make some
moves king f4
and if you do sort of nothing in comes
the pawn to e5 then the punk come to f6
and it's like white is up two pawns over
here and then black's pawn not going
anywhere i think the only miracle safe
for hikara in this position resides in a
stalemate
stalemate idea but i don't know how to
make this work you need to put your king
on age seven the knight has to be on g6
so and you need to
sacrifice your knight and sacrifice your
hook you know
and your bishop and your pawns and your
everything and you have to stack them on
the right squares so like in the final
position white's work has to be on the
eighth rank
so you're right i mean black should
you should leave no stone unturned if
you're trying to
save such a position but
i just i have no idea yeah but let's
just have seven
a thing here
king f7 knight d6 check with a fork
so oh king e7 and knight takes b5 big
king f6
and i win the pawn on e4 that's
important so with the pawn f3 rook takes
f7 is a pretty big threat oh
that's a great point it is
but i was just like calculating some
tactics but this is important because
the knight takes here rook takes e4
black has a rook for bishop and knight
that should be good for the minor pieces
but with so few pawns remaining and
especially pawns all on these pawns on
the same side of the board here are no
pass pawns for anybody it should allow
black to escape so f3 the move in the
game it actually threatens rook takes f7
amongst other things i i wanted to get
back to the live position so let's see
that's exactly the idea that i wanted to
illustrate let's say a5
knight
e7
uh okay king king h7 knight g6 let's say
ignore this thread so i'll play knight
g5
something like you'll take on v5
it will exchange on before and you think
that this is winning
and somehow i will be able to sacrifice
94 and then you'll play with it and this
is you know the stalemate idea
right right these pieces are gone and
there's a rook on the last rank that
would oh my god do you want to hear
something hilarious
it would be stalemate so
uh
that
would be a help stalemate so it would
take a lot of work from
hikar and ding to orchestrate that
together yes but this position i think
if you want to trade the um the bishops
and to give up the uh the pounds on the
queen side this is what you should reach
for with the king on h7
knight on g6 and wait for a
small mistake
yeah it would require us a mistake to
survive and i'm still wondering in this
position after a5 is rook takes f7 an
option because the king f7 knight d6
check the only way you keep your rook
defended is by king f8 or king to e7 and
then after that i just take this pawn
take this bishop and now white is
winning because the e4 pawn is defended
and it will just
kind of be a matter of technique at this
point if you take on b4 white simply
takes back you have a bishop knight and
pawn for a rook
there's no way that black can survive
this yeah i agree this position is
completely winning especially that
now the move h5 comes in handy because
your
pawns are fixed and you have a dark
square bishop
so you will win this in a way you will
put the bishop on the big diagonally
bring your
knight to f5
just team up that's why knight and
bishop are better than a rook is the two
of them can team up on a square a rook
is only one defender so
actually
does black even have a move because rook
takes f7
wins the game so you might need to move
your rook as black
but where do you move your rook two
because i can play e5 if you move your
rook let's say you play
j8 only move
where because rook c8 just walks into a
four oh gosh i guess you can play with
d8 rook d8 but 97 check
and if the king goes here you might
still be able to play a move like knight
g6 and e5 is happening
it's like from every angle you you stop
one threat and you walk immediately into
another and that's why the rook needs to
be on e8 to stop the pawn from pushing
not root d7 so if you
make rook a8 i think you just play e5 by
yourself because if you take this pawn
rook takes g7 the king has to go to the
corner because f8 is covered and after
this bishop d4 is
lights out you're just no knight c6 or
k7 or or even just moving the bishop
somewhere
it's mate you're winning material
black speeds are all in the wrong place
you're just too passive here you're just
unable to
get any of white's pieces off of
their dominant posts maybe we can try
bishop b2 but um but then the rook f7
and you listen to your bishop on b2
after knight c4 that's the same
variation but at least i have my pawn on
my six and b5 yeah i wouldn't even go
for this
as why i mean even though this is
quite straightforwardly winning but
you can complete yeah but but as long as
there's a danger of black greening a
passer i feel like this is a little bit
too double-edged but instead of this
white can also just go rook a7
and let's not forget about that plane
hikaru
he was about to i think he's about to
play that move
but
white has an abundance of
winning plans here 97 checking f4 the
old idea that also looks completely
dominant
just spoiled for choice yeah completely
every single move for black is a
nightmare to make and for dingley ren he
has eight different options that all
leave him with a
huge advantage so
wow
i mean
this game is so important potentially
but it
decides who gets second place
in the overall standings here at the
2022 feed a candidate so
we know that hikaru nakamura entered
today in second
and timor java he
wins his game and is tied with ikaru but
dingley ren if he beats ikaro he
lands himself seoul second place and
perhaps a shot in a world championship
title
what an incredible performance under
pressure was it perfect no
was it
immaculate you know did he make the
right decision at every critical moment
no
but he kept his chances alive he didn't
panic you know against rajabov when he
faced that opening adversity he panicked
he he made a couple of irrational
choices here when he faced adversity in
the opening again he faced the
possibility of
the position liquidating into a draw he
found rook dc one he took risks but they
were measured risk they were risks
primarily aimed at keeping pieces on the
board rather than going for some
gimmicky crazy line and ultimately those
risks are paying off in a big way
and as we get
to our final games or final moves
i'm going to say it chat
feel free to ask any questions you may
have oh how did that that was quick we
already had a chat pulled up i was
trying to be inviting inclusive and we
got ready hikaru's facing calculations
is me looking at the third bowl of mac
and cheese for the day that blue panda
17 with the jokes
i mean three bowls of mac and cheese
that's just way too much that is an
obscene amount i don't judge people but
that doesn't sound healthy
i do like a good bowl of mac and cheese
though but one presumably yeah i don't
eat mac and cheese well but uh every day
i want to ask another question what does
hikaru have in his bag
in the plastic bag it's very important
for the players like to
drink and to eat something during the
game but
what are those elements what are the
secret ingredients maybe brings his
fonta
you know the fonte he's been drinking or
some water
i'm i'm just speculating now
yeah i mean magnus used to have
a very strict ritual or bringing only
certain things to the board i think
orange juice
was on that list eventually he sort of
grew out of it
but uh i still remember that time and
ding
is determined to not let this game drag
on any longer than it needs to yet
another accurate move this is in a way
reminiscent of hikaru's technique
yesterday against duda where at some
point he senses it and every single move
is the top engine choice
perfect play at this moment
winning the a6 pawn look at white's
pieces
a knight protected on f5 a bishop
protected on c5 black's pieces are
scattered the pawns are weak and it's
rook two minor pieces four pawns per
side and yet the eval bar is saying plus
seven it's just black has no choice but
to shuffle back and forth and white has
all these plans is about to actually go
up material yes and for someone who was
not even supposed to be playing this
tournament
yeah it's such an important comeback
and dingley wren played like
30 games in like 25 days or whatever it
was he played non-stop classical chess
in these uh round robin events in china
just to make
the quantity of games required 30 games
to play here so for dingley ren he
didn't have time to prepare
he
um
you know came to madrid two games before
he might have been jet lag coming from
china but he has shown why he is seen as
such a threat the second half of these
candidates tournaments they always go
his way he won three games in a row here
this will be his fourth win of the
second half if only he can get the first
half right or if only he can get like 50
in the first half or plus one
because he's clearly he has the most
stamina somehow he has that ability to
turn it on he won three games in a row
only player this tournament to do that
only player in recent canon's history
yeah he went three in a row that just
doesn't happen
so
you know he's got he's made the most out
of this tournament given the way he
started nobody could predict this and
that's the danger of drawing conclusions
after you look at one game because tons
of people are just saying this is going
to be a disaster for ding
you know he's going to lose 50 rating
points look where he is now about to
defeat the karnataka mural for a clear
second place and
you know if magnus abdicates the the
throne a chance to challenge
yanupondishi for the title
les flamenco asked me specifically
instead of asking you who would win
yeah what if we just uh you know my
lower center of gravity should help me
out
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with me and
wrestling and maybe you in boxing what
about arm wrestling oh i'm going with me
for sure and what about i think
the finest will be the catch
the catch yes what catch catch munch
attachment oh cage match okay no no do
you know this like it's mma
not cage this
i think this very often it's uh those
are staged uh catch
like where you have all these figures
they throw it each other oh like
wrestling like yeah wrestling okay
gotcha well then there's no winner right
you pick who wins right stage
you get to choose so who wins between us
right right i'm there you have to you
have to pick the winner so who wins so
uh what we're talking about what
discipline
what you just yeah what you were saying
right
[Laughter]
here i think that you have your chances
okay and that will be
well it will be an equal
match so wow that sounds like a very
kind answer just so you don't have to
pick pick a side here
oh mirrors being a professional
commentator or not do you think hikaru
should resign
would you resign
uh almira
no
i i think that it's very important to
at least to
well to find every possible defensive
resource in the position so
uh i know how difficult uh
it is to defend this one
um
well at least you should still you
should play a few moves here yeah you
get a loss whether you resign or you get
checkmated so you might as well play
because
zero next to your name isn't going to
change yeah i i feel like too many
players make way too big of a deal about
like when people are resigned
because you can't un-resign right
resigning basically means you're giving
up the game you're giving the point to
your opponent and
there are people who resign a little bit
earlier people resign later i mean it's
largely just a matter of taste and i
think we need to make the assumption at
this level that all of the players
respect each other which they do
so you know somebody resigned three or
four moves later than you think they
should have
move on you know maybe they
thought that they saw one more chance
maybe they just wanted their opponent to
prove it i think there's nothing wrong
with that now playing until may
that one could argue is unethical but
nobody at this level does anything even
resembling that
i think it also offers uh
the opportunity for a player who is
losing uh to grieve because you have to
to accept the defeat
yeah and i mean hikaru looks like he's
grieving right now he is clearly
very unhappy about how this game has
gone and yesterday he was in the studio
he said that no matter the result of
today's game he was proud and happy
of and with the way he's played so you
know he's had a great tournament and
he was very very close to second place
and it's going to be disappointing in
that regard but i do think that he's
shown such a high level of play that he
at least can shush all the critics all
the people who say oh you're a streamer
you're not a serious player and the top
players i've spoken to a number of them
they've never thought that way because
they watch hikaru and they lose the
hikaru online in all of these events and
they're like no he's playing great chess
and he did struggle so before
you know even before he was streaming
more or less full-time he lost a ton of
rating points
back in 2018 2019 because he was number
two in the world he was over 2800 and
then he dropped to something like 2730
and then when he picked it back up he
immediately has skyrocketed back to
something like 2770. so
people's
rating it sometimes fluctuates and for
caro he was at a low point but it seems
like he's back right he is a very
serious contender in any tournament that
he wants to play in and he just seems
happy to play not at this moment i think
he uh wishes this game never happened
but he does seem pretty thrilled and
i guess
what candidate would you pick for your
bug house teammate
amira
well i don't like
you don't like dog house
i don't like buck house either
i'm a terrible player i'm a terrible bug
house and people assume i'm good because
you know i'm a tactical player but
to me i mean bug house is a is a
completely different game yeah i'm going
with richard report though that sounds
obvious
and i've seen many of those games you
know the bug house games so uh
i didn't i even know that uh well
fabiano told me that there is a bug
house theory yes
i don't know it i don't you know
theory's not my specialty but there's
bughouse theory and for everybody
wondering bug house is a game where
there are two players as teammates one
teammate has white the other teammate is
black and when you capture your
opponent's piece on your board you pass
it to your teammate and they can use it
on their board so if you need a queen to
deliver a checkmate your partner should
probably try to trade queens and get it
to you but you can see each other's
boards so it's a lot of fun it's very
very tactical
it's just wild stuff so richard report
would be my pick i played bug house with
some of these players before but i've
never played with rapport and just his
style the way
like today he sacrificed a piece went
for checkmate i feel like he'd be a lot
of fun to play bug house with well but
if we're talking about like different
games i i for example like shogi very
much and this is like a japanese chess
and
in shogi well if you capture a piece
this piece becomes yours so there is
sort of this element which is introduced
in black house chess which you always
have in shogi so
something like what is happening in an
end game and shogi it's very wild
because you have to take into account
all your pieces and all your opponents
pieces which could be parachuted on the
board and it could be a very wild mating
attack
kind of like crazy house yeah a little
bit that's what it reminds me of i don't
know the rules of shogi but
crazy house is like one player or two
player bug house where
your pieces that you capture can be
become yours and you can put them on the
board so
that just lends to me to my eyes bug
house and crazy house like
are tactically overpowered you get this
ridiculous
amount of material
that leads to just insane combinations
so i have yet to master that game but i
can respect it but i understand i think
that what you described that uh the um
power of the thesis is not the same in
shogi that
that actually detail allows you to
parachute pieces they're not that
dynamic whether like in chess if you
also have the same
the same pieces that are being
parachuted then the variations are far
more complex
right
that makes sense
what else makes sense is dean getting
his knight to g6 he doesn't need any
additional material
to
convert this position
i think hikaru is totally reasonable not
to resign yet i mean he's still only
upon down ding still has to prove it he
still has to continue playing accurately
and
it seems that that's exactly what he is
doing just that black is running out of
moves and good question by sam fickle
when was the last time a checkmate
occurred at the candidates i do not have
the answer to that question but i'm sure
somebody in chat is a chess historian
and can give you that fact but
it's
not likely that it's happened in a long
time because usually top players they
don't like getting checkmated they
resign before it can happen
but it is good for the audience to see
when the game is about to be over anyway
a checkmate is nice it's easier for
people to understand than just a
resignation
yeah and and uh
i think that in recent years there has
been a shift where top players are aware
that chess
is now a spectator sport is now a sport
where
you know
the players they have an obligation to
play their best possible chess and rook
b7 here would be ding's best possible
chess picking up another pawn on b5 but
you want to invite players who are new
to the game you want to make it
interesting for players who don't
necessarily know or understand most of
the moves played by top players and one
of the ways to do that is sometimes if a
game features a beautiful combination to
allow
the player who carried that combination
out to complete it and check because
anybody even someone who learned the
rules of the game five hours ago can
appreciate the beauty of a situation
where the king has no squares left on
the board
that's some favoritism here he controls
he controls the screen and is of all the
chat messages he wants to put his own on
the screen what do you call abusing your
own power abusing your own power is
right i'm not even gonna that's right
that don't you do that don't you dare
yeah donnie and i are teaming up on this
one so in a rare turn of events donnie
and i completely agree and we are not
answering well i'm not answering that
question
um
so next question well you're perfect
candidates for the big bank theory like
chess
in a chess
setup it all started with a big bang but
but okay let's some interesting
questions who would you pick actually if
you would want to follow uh four
characters
like as chess players who do you pick so
i have to watch a show with four chess
players essentially big bang theory
style
oh gosh and i have to watch the show i
don't just pick them what does bing bang
theory style mean exactly
maybe you know show big bang theory i
know other than i've never seen an
episode okay so you just is that weird
it's not weird it's just you know it's a
was a popular show it's funny you
haven't seen it but the point is you're
creating a show
with chess players that's like big bang
theory so instead of you know scientists
you have chess players but is the
premise of the show that you just follow
them around oh gosh this is too much
explanation okay anyway i'll leave it
alone i probably would just pick four
chess players for sure players so yeah
or interesting who are your players okay
um
and then there will be a more difficult
question because you you would need to
pick a girl
okay i can do that yes sir
yes sir okay okay
good for story time for sure yeah now we
need someone flamboyant someone who
who has some sheik some chic and some
charm
you want to do iranian okay sure
no one in big bang theory is chic though
they're all like ultra nerds okay so we
need to choose an ultra nerd i am a nerd
myself i think what do we all i think we
all know that category is like big bang
theory they don't have to be like the
characters they just have to just to
style the show
yeah okay so we have two of them how
about you pick the other two because
you're the one asking the questions so i
mean if you want people to watch the
show you have to put a karu on it yeah
okay
your car for the publicity and i like
your mbl pick okay mbl and then
for
alexander
then yes
i i don't know let's do it
is that what he played
i'm just reading our producer's question
who would be the comic book guy stewart
that's a that's a funny one
why is thing repeating
wait
rugby seven what is
he went back into the issue
yeah rook b7 is just a good move maybe
he
was told to always repeat right a lot of
chess players are taught that
and
ben feingold says it jokingly but it is
something that gets you closer to the
next time patrol and dingle run happens
to have plenty of time right now but
it's something you build up it's like a
muscle memory that if you have a
repetition and then you can find a
better move you first repeat once and
then
go for move like rook b7 and
now he wants to play knight d goes to d5
um
where's that bishop going oh
that one doesn't look very good no but
you you want to go bishop e5 because
bishop e5 f4 okay let's get analysis
board up here
so bishop e5
it's not over like i'm just getting the
sense that ding is
he just needs to deliver that final blow
knight takes c4
fp5 rookie five and you've got to be
careful you've only got two puns left
this still requires a little bit of
technique but knight f4
rook d7 actually i think but knight f4
no but g5 check
i throw in that check and then i take on
c5 intermezzo
and then this is really annoying because
i can't play knight g6 and background
checkmate you because after king h7 rook
e8 you have rook takes h5
wrong piece rogue takes h5 removing the
guard of this knight and
there's no more win and if i start with
king g4 you will play rook c4
yes i can always pin your knight with
the move like rook to c4 i can also play
rook g5 check
after king h4 my king can start running
this way eventually and
maybe there's no progress to be made
yeah this is already a draw i'm pretty
sure
so
dang
knight d5 is perfectly sufficient for a
win but
i think that in this sequence here at
the rookie five you just play rook d7
and broke h5
yeah you have two pawns for the piece
but there's
no doubt in my mind that this is just
completely winning because
hikaru
he shifted his bishop down to b2
i once again like rook b7 just go after
a second pawn
why not i mean ding centralizes knight
so you can't really blame him no that
decision but he go right for this pawn
on b5 so
for all
30 plus k of you watching this is for
second place here in the 2022 feed a
candidate takara nakamura dingley ren
are fighting for that spot and if hikaru
draws he's in second he is in the tough
position it looks like dingley wren
should take this one home and we are
going to take a quick break when we
return it will be the end of this game
and the end of the 2022 feed a canvas
this is chess.com coverage live from the
palacio de santonia in madrid
it's fun
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing the
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy
sharpen your tactics with puzzles and
enhance your strategy with our lessons
by top masters learn from your own games
with our easy to use analysis tool
chess.com has everything you need to
take your game to the next level signing
up is free and easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
do
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh nakamura is disgusted he's distraught
he can't believe it but dingley wren has
secured second place here at the 2022
feed eight candidates who took a last
round victory over a
very impressive hikaru nakamura who
looked determined to finish right behind
yonder palmashi but dingley wren the
second half of the tournament has been
his four wins in seven games
it was a tour de force and
after that first round nobody could have
possibly expected him but i am just so
impressed
with his composure in this game
it didn't start off the way he wanted he
had a surprise waiting for hikaru bishop
d3 in the opening igara responded very
well
we were basically calling it a draw once
the queens were traded everything looked
like it would get traded on the d-file
we couldn't even imagine the ding would
create chances it all started with rook
dc one he took some risks he followed up
maybe not perfectly but accurately
enough he put pressure on hikaru and his
technique once he got a winning position
was amazing what a big last round win
for ding who is going to hold his head
up high even if he doesn't get to play
ianna pomnishi and the best players in
the world they sometimes leave you after
reviewing a game where like i don't see
where their opponent went wrong i did
every move they're improving their
position so i remember growing up and
watching the games of mickey adams and
just looking at them like i would have
played the move that the opponent played
that looks pretty good and yet dingley
wren even though he car was playing
normal move to normal move there came a
point where car had no activity to speak
of and dingley ren was able to
capitalize and very often you get this
feeling when you're watching the games
of anatoly karpov because everything is
well
every piece it's on its
perfect square and
uh well what a performance he grinded
hikaru down and that's been his winning
style right he did the same thing to yan
chest of duda it looked like a pretty
neutral position yanchez after made a
slight mistake and then came another and
then there was a win for dingley wren he
beat richard report and that was a
hectic game where you know his king went
on a bit of a run but he won in the end
game and then against five minute
carwana and up and down a seesaw affair
but ultimately ending a win for ding and
he finishes the tournament with a great
victory over hikaru nakamura player he
hadn't beaten in classical chess until
today
yeah he's gonna have a big smile
on his face and he car is going to be
happy with his overall result as he told
us yesterday but he is going to be
deeply deeply disappointed at his game
today you could see the consternation
and you know i think it would have
probably been an easier pill to swallow
if he had gotten crushed or if he had
you know
failed to respond properly to some
opening preparation but the fact that he
came as close as he did to holding that
position
you know quite straightforwardly i think
that's going to make it more frustrating
because there were several points at
which there's a clear chance for icaru
to completely neutralize
whatever advantage initiative
we were talking about so frustration in
the last round but obviously a very
successful outing overall for hikaru
nakamura can you imagine scoring eight
points out of 14 like dingleran did and
being a point and a half behind the
person in first just goes to show what
kind of tournament janupam she had where
we just stopped talking about him
because it was almost a foregone
conclusion that he was going to win he
was able to make that draw in round nine
against five-minute caruana and after
that
the storyline was such that is anyone
going to be able to catch up to young
palmashi
answer obviously not and a great
tournament by dingley ren a great
tournament by hikaru nakamura yet it
still
was so far away from first place
yeah i mean
it was locked up jan at one point was
two points ahead of the next player
can you even believe that i mean this is
the candidates we're talking about it's
not like jan is the top seed by 400
points
so simply amazing and uh we had so many
great performances in this tournament
and we still have one game going
with fabiano caruana very close to
actually saving an end game that at one
point we thought was
pretty much
dead
yeah this doesn't look that bad at all
white has a blockade set up on the light
squares the problem with the bishop is
that it can't change its color complex
you would need to go to the light
squares to kick out these pieces so
unless
this king get the b5 which doesn't look
legal there's no way to get it there the
c5 square is under white's control the
c4 square as well so the king can't get
over there so it seems like a position
where white can
just move around maybe bring the king as
well to the queen side and the a pawn's
not going anywhere so fabiano has found
the perfect defensive setup
can we go for example can we wait for
kingi 2 and king d3
and
while your king is far away from the g
pawn then i will go for the h pawn
and go for this rook end game
let's just switch on over to this way
yes
let's see
but the problem is after knight takes a
five i'm also attacking c6
and i'm threatening knight c4cha
so you'd force piece off the board i
guess you could start with the kings
h4 right somehow white has his cake and
he eats it too you know and black can
then defend this pawn for a more active
way but then this rook slides over
because you can't play a4 your rook is
no longer behind the pawn which means
that white is able to attack black's
weaknesses but fabi doesn't go
k2 he goes h4 immediately so he
recognizes
the weakness of that pawn and decides to
fix it
straight away now
what this gives black is the additional
chance of delivering a check on f8
okay
where does that does that do anything
like rook f8 check king oh cafe trekking
e2 you can't play because there's rook
f4
so king g4 is what fabio relies on and
he basically says okay well now you have
to go back to a8
because a5 is hanging but
is that in fact the case
probably not i mean the r so if we could
stop pass and move like rookie eight
knight takes a five works because at the
rook a you have a check
to this king which means that the rook
on eight is lost so the king were not on
a checkable square this could work so
maybe there's a way where after kings
before we
king d35 okay so you're out of the
checking zone of the night is what
you're saying right and if i try to
throw you back into the checking zone
with c4 check then i can get sick again
you're sidestepping and i want you to
push the pawn right because the more
advanced this pawn is the easier it is
for black to approach it so even though
white is still within
balance right only about a pawn better
for black which makes sense because
black is of a pawn it's not
an overwhelming edge for
ferruja
so after king g4 and d5 can i avoid
playing
c4 check like what if i just
pass the move and play like h5 for
example
can i sir
um c5 c4 i mean if you can get your pawn
to c4 i'll play c4 myself it just looks
so awkward yeah all of a sudden also the
white king like in the lines we were
looking at the king is on the queen side
now the king's cut off and black's king
is just
walking over here and this pawn on c4
may be in big trouble if you want the a5
pawn so this is how already frigid wins
this game let's back up a bit because uh
we looked at a position
around time control and we thought that
alerisa was maybe just going to win
quite easily
but after the king started running
fabiano reroutes his knight
this looked fine bishop b4 and that
apparently
is an inaccuracy so the bishop
should have gone back to e5 it would
seem but what's wrong with this bishop
well i think it allows
a timely c3
and you might say why is c3 important
because it it gives white a bunch of
tempe to reach essentially his ideal
setup like ideal defensive setup
and keeps black completely out of the
position
right
knight comes back to b3 and you have
this sort of fortress almost it's weird
to say it but it is kind of a fortress
the rook
guarding the fourth rank the knight in
the rook focused on the eight by fun how
does black make any progress whatsoever
that's why fabby's last move might be
accurate it finally gives black a chance
to mix things up a little bit by getting
the rook off of its passive square on a8
but what we should start here with king
d5
[Music]
what is your next move
h5 king
what if i go king e2 oh then you give a
check on here in rookie i like the h5
yeah
g7 pawn is now
a little bit weak
but now i can play rook h8
you cannot play you cannot i can't i
think i can take an a5 because rook
knight c4
um ah but you can take on h5 that's the
problem nice tactical vision by done it
with the fork here which protects the
rook tactically so that's a nice little
sequence
but then uh you say that i can play work
h5 oh wait did you go rook a7 that was
like uh no he did go individually five i
couldn't tell what pc grab but it looked
like
one square so king d5
so we were analyzing h5 for h8 and
there's something to note here is if i
put my pawn on h6 and you take it
now you have
the wrong
point and the reason why that could be
important is let's say i play c4 check
and you go king d6 and i play c5 at the
moment
right where if we get this type of
position and i'm trading rooks
there might be a position where i just
want to give you this pawn and then take
your pawn and i make a draw without
effort so it probably won't even come
down to that but it's something that i
have in the back of my mind that the
bishop does not match the corner square
and i'm actually just going to
kind of show that very quickly g6 h5
takes knight takes e6 seems like a
blunder but the problem is that black
cannot force this king out of the corner
so i just go in these squares over here
and
when you try to win
let's go there there here you can't even
play king g3 it's immediately a
stalemate because the white king won't
be able to escape and there's no way to
get the king out of there if this were
on another file at some point the king
would have to budge out of the way of
the pawn but for now the king just stays
in front of the pawn and there's nothing
you can do because the corner is a light
square
and fabi with no hesitation he's got
plenty of time but
he doesn't see the need to
waste any additional time he shoves that
pawn forward to h5 the g7 punt is
immobilized
purusha just doesn't seem to have a very
good handle on on this end game he's
been
kind of going between one plan and
another i feel like bobby's drawing
chances are a lot higher than black
swimming chances at this point i was
thinking 80 20 in fridge's winning
chance favor now i'm going
i mean
90 draw
i feel pretty strongly that this
position doesn't offer for that
much in the way of winning chances he
can't create a past pawn this blockade
is really annoying to deal with if you
ever try to push your pawn to c5 yeah i
was about to say i think c5 is this rook
can slide over this way and then
close your king off with c4 so you said
you're going to play c4 a4 a4 and i
think i'm going to play c4 check to
force your king back oh and then from
six and rook takes g7 i'm gonna force
you king back again and take this with
check and my knight can stop your pawn
before
so that might draw the game on the spot
right now this is a huge moment because
c5 is played oh then yes rook g4 a lot
of people would be tempted to play c4
check and say let me close it down but
then the rook has no way out of a4
i think you certainly don't want to play
that move
and the rook can't move because the pawn
goes to a4 and then this king could also
think about winning this spawn over on
h5 if the king tries to help then the
king goes into these squares so
yeah rook g4 is a very important move
you want to keep the black king cut off
out of white's territory but
if i start with rook a7 you still play
like rook g4 or k7 you still play c4 yes
must be so annoying for black and then
black could lose this game yeah black
could lose this game and you know what's
crazy
the the way that fabi positioned the
pawn on h5 it's also important in the
line
so again if we go with a4 instead of
rook a7
rook g5 check
um
oh no it doesn't even oh sorry c4 check
king e5 i might say oh let me run toward
f6 i escape the checks no you don't
because the pawn is on h5 king f6 g6
check
drop and then i take the bishop you take
the knight and rook takes here and this
is a draw so
it looks like fabiano caruana has things
under control what a game this has been
where early on it looked like fabiano
had no risk and could just play for a
win with a knight on a light square
against the dark square bishop
then alireza farouja he fought back
fiercely throwing his pawns forward and
even obtaining the upper hand and now in
the end game it does look like fabiano
caruana he should be holding here rook
g4 seems to be the last accurate move
necessary to hold the balance so
uh fabiano doing very very well
he is
about to make a draw it feels like so
it's a matter of time but we have a very
very special guest in the studio it is
grandmaster dingley wren
ding
how are you feeling i feel very good
after this very crucial
although he played
he had many mistakes maybe he
a nearly equal out of the opening but
after that i present whole game and i
think i didn't let the
advantage take sleep
yeah dean we thought that the game might
be heading for a quick draw at the
opening but then you played dc one we
thought that was a really interesting
way to generate chances
do you think that that was an early
important moment or would you identify
any other moments when you felt like the
game started turning around
in your favor
yeah i think
this
important moment after luke dc1
uh bishop f6 is too nature
to play but maybe he's worried about
knight d4 actually he can take with
knight i think bishop t rook c7 king g6
and bishop d4
takes
taken bishop d5 it's an easy jewel i
guess
so you saw that he could just play like
yeah maybe he only saw bishop d4 first
uh after knight d4 yes i think king g6
may be the movie missed
the bishop d4 bishop d4
knight d4 rook c7 king of six rook b7
knight e2
kf1 knight c3 ub6
yes
um
it's just
slightly better for white
so a4 is maybe you'll see two something
were you worried after the opening that
when he played f5 you spent a lot of
time
did you think at that point that maybe
you wouldn't even have a chance to play
for a win
yeah after actually after queen d1
i i thought maybe it's just a equal
after question after bishop b1 i'm i'm
very
optimistic about my chance since i i was
expecting bishop f6 instead of queen d1
but i have queen b3 that's the point
behind
bishop b1 uh-huh so you can play your
queen the ambition was on c2 yeah your
queen couldn't come out so you realized
that there were these small moments that
kept your chances alive in this position
so um
tell me where you started to feel
confident that you could win the game
because for a while it seemed like he
was playing good defense yeah i never
feel confident until the time control
at around 30 move okay since he played
very concrete
with bishop with e5 yes if i was in
one important position i first i want to
play bishop a1
but knight db6
knight a5
rook d8
king of one
d yes king f1 rook t1 if i can play king
e2 then i'll be better but he has a very
important group d2
yes so his rookie
permits it to the
and then the advantage shifts from your
active pieces to his so you were
calculating all of these lines so at
this point you know they're bishop c5 so
he plays bishop d8 and trades the rooks
and at this point
we were starting to feel like
he's playing really well here and you
know how is dean going to win
yeah he's playing very interesting he
moved the bishop back to the eighth
because he's aiming to capture h5 pawn
yeah i miss knight g4 i thought i would
slightly better but not at 94 i'm not
sure so i want to repeat once it's
knight f6 a bishop d6 knight g4 and
maybe king of one
i still want to play for win
but he played bishop h4 so did that
surprise you
um
not so much since he is sent into deep
thought at that point
you know i will
i won't uh go for three i i will maybe
go if what i want made to join
immediately
so
here
king f1 and then he made this bishop d8
did that move surprise you at all yeah
yeah and this is too strange
yeah because after bishop d8 it seems
like you're in complete control of the
game
but what
what should he play instead of maybe if
now if f4 he worried about take take
take and look d4 maybe this is what he
worries
oh and so he played [ __ ] of this one
rook d8 we thought
was like
the best resource but
even the minor piece end game is very
scary because a6 is so weak yeah so you
were planning to take care and go like
bishop b6
just knight c5 and v show b6
yeah it looked unpleasant though for for
black for sure because knight c5 and if
you take here comes the pawn right yeah
yeah i have c7 sorry and h5 palm became
bishop f8 at the end
wow
so yeah 21 bishop d8 so that you said
you found it to be a little bit strange
and then okay at that moment when you
find like
i can breathe my position is better it's
uh you know easier for you to play yeah
because my pieces are so well placed and
also a full comment surprise
and he missed his last chance of the
game here he needed to play this move f3
so it seems like both of you
uh weren't looking for that move it is
kind of strange no
yeah i didn't expect it
for where i
went wrong maybe i have to take the pawn
yeah i think you could uh safely take
this pawn and and pray 96 496. i'm the
king
kind of a strange position right where
your pawn structure looks worse but he
can't move
so
well you end up winning this game quite
nicely he didn't really have
after he missed f3 you were just playing
very accurately and he didn't really
have a chance to
get out of this game so i mean
at the end of this you know you won this
game you finish in second place my
biggest question for you is
what is the difference between the first
half
and the second half because in two
straight candidates tournaments you are
made the top scorer in the second half
so what's the difference for you
uh well first i think the first round is
quite different from the other ones
because this time
when i play the first games
i didn't feel so well maybe
still a time
jack for me also i didn't sleep well so
the mood is very strange
i'm going to make some uh
quick draw but
after
the opening it became clear that
it will be fighting game then i just
couldn't calculate
anything so i lost very badly
after that i tried to
[Music]
be normal and take it as a just normal
tournament not the candidates to
and do not put too much pressure on
myself
and i also watching some movies on the
rest day or movies
just some
about a family and
love
a japanese movie
saying if magnus
declines to play the world championship
you are the world championship
challenger he'll be playing yanda
pannishi are you excited at that
prospect unlikely as it may be
yes there is a chance he he might not
play
since i i guess he's lake of lakes of
[Music]
motivations to defend the title again
also
it takes a lot of energy and a lot of
open
population com comparing to the other
tournament
so maybe that's the reason she's not
uh sure if you play or not but i believe
when the
championship is uh approaching
then maybe his
inner heart will start to burn in some
fire so i guess he'll play in the end
i think well we had emil sutowsky here
we interviewed him and he said the
deadline for magnus is approximately
july 20th so in a few weeks so i guess
that's when you will know better about
what your future holds with respect to
the world championship but it's so early
it's international challenges they need
to make plans you know organize the
event um but
you know a lot of the players said they
were thinking about second place you
said that earlier in the tournament and
even if you think and others do you
think magnus will play
does that give you more of a feel like
even if yana pump she's running away
he's playing so well you always felt
like there was something to play for
uh yes at one point when i with three
games in a row
i feel obligated to play
for the win with white pieces to try to
catch him
although it's backward
backwards
but i think it's the only chance to
fight for the first place uh
so after the law the lose
oh of course i am very satisfied i'm
going to have a second place yeah i
think final question for me what are
your plans after the tournament are you
resting or are you going straight into
game analysis interesting um before i
was planning to play olympiad but then
the chinese team won't play
so i'll just go back and
have some
have some rest
uh is where can we expect to see you
play next because we've missed you you
know just
no i i guess it's the last over the
board tournament
at least out of the china
yeah because in second half of the year
still very difficult to travel
so i might just stay
in my home hopefully you can play more
tournaments there and thank you very
much we have a few questions from the
chat so many people were watching they
were rooting for you a lot of people
were so uh here's a question when you're
at your own best
who do you enjoy playing against the
most which player do you have the most
fun playing against
well i guess still magnus yeah yeah
since i enjoyed playing him
since i didn't feel too much pressure
against him
especially in the internet since uh
i think everybody is expecting this
pairing and also i'm very
eager to show my best when playing
against him
okay
all right let's see if we have
one more question from the chat
all right super record ding what's your
personal advice to becoming a stronger
chess player
became a stronger chess player i think
you might
[Music]
sacrifice a little bit in your life
to
work more on chairs to focus on the
openings but that means you will have
lesser time on the other things
to develop the other hobbies
yeah
well ding we want to congratulate you
again i mean the second half of your
tournament was unbelievable you finish
in second place you seem so much happier
now than when we uh we're seeing you in
the first half of the tournament
yeah i become more happy after winning
some games
well we'll see you tomorrow most like
the closing ceremony but enjoy your time
here in madrid and congratulations again
dean congratulations yeah thank you
bye-bye
that was grand master dingley ren the
number one player from china the first
chinese player to break 2800 second
place here at the candidates and also
the number two rated player in the world
he leaves madrid with a few rating
points to his name so a great showing by
him and you know he
talked to us about a lot of things about
how his favorite person to play is
magnus carlsen i'm not surprised one bit
by that answer because the way dingley
wren plays when he's at his best he
i mean i think it's never left for
debate he's
second third best player in the world
maybe he's one of those players
well magnus brings the best out of him
you know you were talking about how when
other players are facing magnus there
well there's so much fear that they're
simply not capable of making uh
showing their great potential and making
the best moves
whilst ding and some of the other
players in this tournament uh
well
they're
showing their best play against magnus
yes sometimes you punch up right you
play to the level of your opposition and
for you know dingley and he said in the
first round he wanted to make a quick
draw like he had jet lag he just got
here and
we keep always talking about the
what-ifs right and
that's one of those moments where you
can just feel it it's like the whole
tournament could have changed but for
yondu palmishi he's the deserving
champion for dingley wren to show the
mental fortitude to bounce back after
not just that really bad defeat but
losing the team over job of in a game
where he said he felt a lot of pressure
with winning three in a row i need to
catch yonder palm machine i'm the only
one who can do it he lost a really
heartbreaking game and to win this
against hikaru nakamura it seemed
impossible
but dingley wren he accomplishes the
impossible well first of all this that
was such a sincere answer not many
players will admit that uh well that
they were feeling so bad that they
wanted to make a draw with white from
the very start and well they
simply didn't he simply didn't manage so
it showed that he um
well understands the tournament strategy
very well he he was trying to minimize
the um
the damages at the
beginning of the tournament so and also
i cannot strike well i wanted to to
underline that how important is to have
a second with you because during those
difficult moments you need
uh to have a person to me well you you
can talk you know it's we were talking
about mental coaches coaches but
dinglerand didn't have anyone and no
wonder he's watching the movies about
family love you know this is this
says so much about
well human being alone here and you
could sense the sadness in his voice
when he said he doesn't know when his
next classical game will be he loves
chess and i'm really hoping we get to
see him over the board soon because the
world missed him right everyone was
talking about it dingley wren can't
leave to go play in the world cup in the
grand prix and there's no question
there's no debate that he deserved to be
here his performance shows that but even
if he finished in last place everyone
would say dingley wren is a top
three player in the world at this moment
so
to have him here was a really big gift
an unexpected gift but he finishes with
eight points out of 14 games a really
strong showing from him and
you know maybe next time is the charm in
the candidates because
his second halves are
absolutely incredible he won four games
almost everybody at the top was asked to
unobjectively say who
might be the most challenging component
for magnus
dingley round is almost always featured
in that list and
that doesn't happen by accident and it
doesn't happen because
you know he's 2800 and number two in the
world that's not the reason why people
say that i think the reason why so many
gm's point to dingley run specifically
is because of how unbelievably universal
his style he does everything incredibly
well his opening preparation
is virtually impeccable his positional
understanding his ability to squeeze
wins out of equal positions we saw it
play out here he's not just doing it
against random people he's doing it
against the top players in the world and
perhaps the only other player who has
that talent developed to a crazy degree
is magnus carlson himself so you can see
little bits and pieces of magnus in the
way the ding plays i think that's what
makes him so exhilarating to watch like
you're watching magnus but it's not
magnus another player it's a very
wholesome player and it's a player who
just got second place in the candidates
tournament yeah dingley wren i think a
lot was said before the event because
people weren't happy that
the way he was able to play 30 games
right all these internal terms in china
and well that's the only way possible
for him and he didn't need rating points
so that storyline is in the past he just
needed the quantity not the rating so uh
it's great to see him here it's great to
see him play well and as you're saying
some of his wins here against yanchez of
duda and now again dakar nakamura it's
games that if you're just scrolling you
know on your phone looking quickly at
games you're like oh what wait how did
white win this game what how it's equal
but he just puts that pressure on and he
believes in himself you can tell when
he's talking about he's like i was
playing for a win i never thought this
was a complete draw so
elmira it's pretty incredible to see
players win like that at this high level
well first of all i'm really grateful
that he had this opportunity to play
those tournaments at least in china so
he was able to qualify
and of course his performance here was
well
impressive but what i wanted to say so
what are the conditions that should be
reunited for ding to perform well in the
first half so maybe and also being able
to play maybe the candidates tournament
should be organized in china once
well i think that would certainly help
no jet lag you can have your team of
seconds your family all your supporters
there is a lot of pressure in that
though we know that people who play on
their home turf
with everybody right there beside you
that's too much going on for some but
for dingley ren you know if he is able
to stabilize in the first half of the
candidates watch out you know he may be
a challenger to a future world chess
championship including the next one if
magnus carlsen does not play but we have
one game left here five in a car wanna a
former world chess championship
challenger he has the white pieces he is
holding on against alireza for dear life
for dear life indeed but with only two
pawns remaining that helps the night
knights are not long range pieces so
having the pawn so close together helps
the knight in its defensive task and
there's a critical line here by the way
if fabi missed the direct draw with the
rook chief iv i mean he is just not
himself
that was a move that he
you know would find in rapid game rook
g4 and we analyzed a4 all you have to
see is this move c4 check and once you
see this move you understand that you
pick up the g7 pawn with check the
knight with plenty of room to stop the
a-pawn but instead fabi
with
a different move knight back to d2 he
stops c4
that's not a terrible move it keeps
drawing chances
after that the h bond traded for the g
pawn so he does eventually play rook g4
but the thing i wanted to point out if
you look carefully there might seem to
be a tactic here after rook h5 rook g7
black can give a check on h2
what's the point of that well king d3
rook h3 check king c2 and you might say
ah rook takes c3 check you win another
pun but if you keep calculating after
king d3 bishop takes g7 still looks
winning but amazingly knight c4 saves
the day black cannot defend a5 if you
play a4 you walk into a check a fork and
black white eliminates both of the pawns
of the night so white hinges white's
defense hinges solely on this line and i
feel like ali reza just in his body
language may have missed this from a
distance
and that would allow fabiano to make a
draw with relative ease the pieces come
off so quickly it's a forcing variation
and so for fabi who
has had a second half to
forget
he would love to have fought for first
place he was doing just that in the
first half
he had us in the first half not gonna
lie as they say and unfortunately for
fabi i mean this tournament has been one
that he will not want to dive into too
much longer but yonder palm shield he
would love to remember this tournament
forever it was a masterpiece a stroke of
genius from jan de palmashi as he makes
a record 9-14 and he caught up with dina
bellancaya before hikaro was losing
talking about world chess championship
revenge
i didn't expect this particular line in
petrov so i had to
i mean recall i think it was more or
less all my prep
but since i have some wonderful guy in
my team who
you know shows me the lines like a5 rook
e6 it's you know it's never easy to
replay it if you didn't repeat it like
just before the game yes it was quite
confusing because it
looks strange to see the list but in
fact i think black is doing fine there
did you feel any particular pressure
after bishop takes g6
uh well i wanted to play on because
i knew that another repetition like
i think the line i could recall is uh
not a g6 but knight f6 check uh sorry
rook takes g8 bishop d8 knight f6 bishop
f6 ef6 rook f6 rook 8 king g7 queen e3
h6 queen c5 q1 and four and that however
i think this was the draw and also there
is some another draft rook demand but um
ag6 i had no idea this move also works
so i thought okay come on it's time to
to play on
but somehow
quite i mean it's it's not worse like
okay this bishop g64 is just brilliant
so i just missed i just missed this
rugby one idea but uh
i think
black has different ways but i felt like
okay bishop d5 is surely the most solid
one
would you just theoretically prefer to
face
hikaru ding or magnus
well let's wait until the tournament is
over but
of course i seek for revenge
and speaking of
what is the biggest lesson you've
learned at the match or the the biggest
change that you would like to make
approaching the next world championship
match
uh the big lesson is like not to get
tired before the tournament starts yeah
so before the match starts before the
candidate starts here just
you know have enough rest and don't like
don't go like don't work like crazy yeah
because you
uh you also i mean it's not competition
of who worked more if it's a competition
of who plays better but to play well you
have to you know to be fresh so that
that was something i really
i really couldn't uh couldn't do during
dubai
right jan thanks a lot and uh lots of
luck for
for the next tournaments thanks
and yonder palm she said lots of rest
don't overdo it not too much preparation
and then he just rattles off all these
variations from today's game we thought
that young schuster of duda was the one
in preparation catching yan off guard
and yet napoli says oh i my second
helped me out with this line and i
wasn't worried well i just really loved
his comment about like okay bishop g6 so
let's switch the brain on it's time to
play
because it seemed that he remembered the
lines till the move 30 and
we were all surprised here in the studio
and a5 when he made that move it seemed
out of nowhere and it's just from his
trusty team of second so i said at the
time like i'm surprised but i could know
nothing i know nothing his team knows
everything and that was excellent
preparation but i mean perhaps the most
impressive aspect of it to me was the
fact that he recalled all of it and it
took him some time but now we know that
that's what he was doing he wasn't
thinking independently he was actually
trying to recall his prep
and he did it flawlessly and the fact
that he was rattling off these lines of
perpetual check at the end like almira
said
30 move lines
in a sideline that he didn't expect he
didn't even know what first move jkd
would make so
jan is on another planet
this tournament i mean that in the best
possible way what an end to the
tournament he didn't win
but he drew from a position
of strength and
very well deserved rest
for ian upanishing and he spoke about
revenge
when he was asked by dina would he
rather play hikaru ding or magnus and
he's looking for revenge so
amir when you see his reactions his
interviews throughout the tournament
about how you know he has kept his
emotions in a box he's made sure that
he's objective he's make sure that he's
rested
do you think he believes that he can
beat magnus carlsen i i really think
that he believes that he can do it now
you remember that french phrase i told
you that the ranch is the dish that best
served cold so
now that he had enough time to put all
those uh
events into perspective and that he won
his second candidate's tournament in a
row which gives him an extra boost in
self-confidence i really think that
well that his chances are
well how to say uh
it's much higher much higher than before
yeah uh the yonda policy we've seen here
is unbelievable and he won the previous
candidates but a lot of people out there
were saying well what has he won before
this is this kind of a fluke it stopped
midway i think jan
proved
and to himself just much to anybody else
that no of course it wasn't the fluke
yonda pamshi when he's prepared when
he's focused when he's determined when
he has a clear goal in sight he's a
scary player anish was with us yesterday
and he was saying that when jan plays
his best he might be the best player
not named magnus carlson and people hate
facing him janna's such a good practical
player he plays quickly he finds
ideas that are incredibly hard to play
against magnus is not immune from that
category he doesn't like facing yan
either now the yama we saw in dubai is a
completely different person from the
young
that we saw here with that being said
unless superman himself comes along
magnus is always going to be the
favorite in a world championship match
so i don't think any of us are saying
that jan is now somehow the favorite i
still think it's likelier than not that
magnus is going to win
any anybody he plays against right now
and if that changes i'll let you know
but
in terms of
having chances to at least give magnus a
serious fight if yon can reproduce his
form from this tournament
beware because it's going to be a
thriller of a world championship match
and the fact that jan is an amazing
rapid player that's going to help as
well in case you have a caruana
situation where you have a tie after the
classical portion so whichever way you
look at it if yon comes prepared if he
comes rested and we saw him saying how
important that is something he may have
underestimated the first time around
oh we might be in for a doozy
well paviano caruana he knows what it's
like to face off against magnus carlsen
over the course of a world championship
match he is still trying to
make a draw in this game against alireza
farouja and
vamano down under five minutes he still
has three moves to make until the time
control and he spent now five and a half
minutes on this particular move so he's
trying to figure out what to do here the
eval bar says zeros no problems but it's
never that easy right there's no force
draw at the moment at least not one that
i see and 500 doesn't have the benefit
of having our silicon friend
yeah zeros might be
the most misleading assessment i've ever
seen
is literally black is up a pawn
so
it's laughable too to say that this is
sort of like a dead draw
is there any fourth duration
well i think it's semi force but
carawana he didn't go knight c4 i think
he made a a very good movie played king
d3
getting his king into a better defensive
position closer to the queen side
allowing your tactic allowing the attack
but doesn't it work wait rook h3 check
nope because once you take
oh now there's a different way to win
the pawn oh my goodness but king c4
exactly my king wow up because your
king's not on d5 anymore that's quite
amazing because previously the knight
had to go to c4 now the king goes there
and you have a fork
so this is a draw
i think the reason it's drawn is because
fabia has gotten all of his pieces to
ideal defensive positions the rook on g7
the king is close to black's a pawn
and black's king is never safe from side
checks from forks
i i don't see alireza winning this
anymore especially if fabi makes the
time control the second time control in
one piece
and if black tries bishop e5 something
like this the rook can come up to g6
king d5
oh my gosh checkmate ouch
king b5
and you may be tempted to just check
this king the king has to go up this way
and think that this is all said and done
you know your king's blocking the pawn
but you have to be very careful in a
position like this because if
black is able to get this king
out from in front of the pawn this
pawn's a runner and this bishop is
protecting the corner square so it is
still a hold
it's not like anything has changed very
much but you don't want to assume that
you have everything under control you
need to make sure that you don't allow
any kind of tricky sequence so uh fabi
after king d3 he's probably feeling
pretty good about chances ali raza was
seven minutes on the clock he's trying
to work through this position but it
it's nearing that half point for each
side
yeah i mean i don't know exactly what
rouge i think bishop b5 might be black's
best the line he just showed actually
might be black's best practical chance
because if black's king can get to like
b2
and if i can go a4
then things start getting really dicey
for away because the knight is very bad
at stopping especially a corner passer
so alireza needs to go for a very
concrete position in which
fabi has to be accurate and given the
time situation even with 15 additional
minutes ravi's not gonna have four hours
you can have 18 minutes or probably 15
because he'll probably deplete the rest
of the time he has so it's not a dead
draw by any means i'd put it somewhere
around
20 80.
okay
well already needs to find a move here
he can also start trying to push his
pawn the issue is that very easy for
white to stop the pawn a4 this knight
can come up to c4 your pawn's not going
anywhere so
time control is in just a couple of
moves this is a format with three time
controls they already have the
additional hour after move 40 they get
15 minutes
added once they reach move 60 plus 30
second increment per move so that way if
you're in time trouble but you're trying
to hold on you will not lose on time if
you make moves quickly
there is a farouja on the clock here
trying to work some end game magic but
it seems like the most of his advantage
is behind him at this point and
amira you know he's been trying very
hard
do you think at this point he kind of
feels that he no longer has real winning
chances
well he knows that the advantage
that he had before slipped
away but he's well he's still trying
so i agree with daniel that bishop b5 is
the best practical chance but maybe
there is another way to keep
if not the fire on board at least to
keep the game going
um
yeah maybe a4
yes let's try four
okay so the king d3 a4 i'm going to
bring my knight up yeah there's a
peculiar drawing mechanism rook g6 is
now a serious positional there you can
r5 for example
rogue g6 can be five i just want to show
that perpetual with knight a3 and knight
c4
funny funny little line king has to go
back and forth as well and that's just a
draw okay so we're about to see a move
for molly rasa who's got
four minutes and change to make
one two three
more moves until time control i'm
fully expecting bishop e5
i just don't see any other enticing
options
yeah he's
trying to see if something works and
bishop e5 there it is yeah
good move let's see how quickly five
nano plays rook g6 check very quickly oh
no
rook f7 rook f7 whoa so he can block a
check in the third rank with his rook
and rook trades lead to a position
where at first you may say how could you
trade you're down a pawn the table base
says it's a draw here and this king can
come to c4 this pawn's not going
anywhere this is like the
wait the the hicaro against report end
game
i forget what minor pieces were on the
board but this reminds me of that for
whatever reason it was knight in uh two
pawns against bishop and one at the end
okay so
it was like a mirror image of this one
but uh now i would play a4 and i i
played quickly if i'm ali reza not here
i feel like one of his only
chances lies in bobby making a mistake
in the next two moves because once this
additional time control is reached i
feel like
fabio will be able to make it over the
finish line and here's a great example
of a possible mistake because a4 of
course trying to go a3 if you think
knight c4 robert was just telling me
about that here he comes with an exact
check and you no longer can block on the
third rank so a4 is the only try i would
say
for
black and after a4
what is white going to do maybe i can
play knight f3
first
knight f3 there's bishop h
maybe
now rook a7 uh-huh i just chased the
pawn down but now we're g3 i have rick
h3 and i'm losing everything e4 and like
king b5 and already it gets very
i mean now it's just lost because you're
gonna lose c3 so dangerous no maybe not
to k7 then i i i don't like that elairs
is taking
just about a minute now finally there he
goes a4
a move i thought you should have played
almost instantly but now let's keep a
very careful eye on what fabby does he's
got time
but a lot of little minefields here and
two more moves yeah this ain't over the
apon is actually really annoying it's
just frustrating to deal with because
you want to play rook a7 in all these
positions but with rook h3 check coming
that's going to spell trouble for
white so fabi on the clock has a couple
minutes to make a couple moves
we'll see what he does here but he is
calculating he's searching and amir
you've said this many times that fabi
has a style that must be exhausting he's
always calculating he's trying so hard
maybe he's even spent the most time at
the board throughout this event
a lot of players with the white pieces
in a tournament where they've lost a
bunch of games they say let's just make
a quick draw let's go home this wasn't
our event he's still well now he's
defending but throughout the game he was
still fighting he wanted to win this one
well and i feel that um it's not that
they feel i think that fabi feels
that this is his
moral obligation towards the organizers
and the chess community this i can only
respect this attitude and i was thinking
actually about this position uh knight
of three maybe is a little bit
complicated knight c4 loses can you make
another knight move and well it's sort
of ugly looking but knight b1 that's the
only way for me to stop uh
the a pawn advance
to protect this can i hold yeah
somehow here
i thought rook h3 check king c2 king
city and a3 looked dangerous but i think
there is king b3
very important donna's idea is to
distract the knight away so rook takes
c3 hits the king hits the knight have
king b2 the only way to keep the knight
you lose this rook because they discover
a check so
you can't take this pawn on a3 it's
poisonous play king b3 instead and that
way you just get the pawn on the next
turn
and i apologize earlier i said that fabi
has two more moves to make he of course
has one final move to carry out before
time control is reached so
it makes sense to take all of his
remaining time
when you play knight though it's a great
move that almira but i've tried
but you know he's also trying everything
right he's looking
he's been spending time trying to
calculate and might be one that's
actually very instructive
backwards moves very difficult to find
typically passive moves very difficult
to play psychologically and yet knight
b1 here protects your only pawn and
stops the enemy pawn at the same time i
really like knight to b1
yeah and there's like i said a lot of
pitfalls here where k7 allows rook h3
check so this possibility of rook h3
check needs to be
factored into whatever
move fabi ultimately chooses to make
but through k7 rook h3 king e4 bishop
takes c3
and i hit your knight no but i can play
knight b1 there
but you cannot take on the a4 because of
the skewer or show this
what they're talking about here so rook
a7 this is what the show is about we
have producers calling us we will pitch
right something today h3 check and where
did you get king e4 e4 chip c3 knight b1
let's say knight b1
he got them out with 41 seconds it looks
like and it is
so let's say what is it no what did he
play
what did he play
oh he played what wave at 94 what
oh my gosh rook h3
oh my wait
wait wait wait wait wait rock h3 king c4
rookie three yeah he's gonna get mated
oh my goodness oh my god fabby is just
whoa but will alireza see the check and
he's about to grab his rook
oh my god rock h3 chuck wins
and if you go back to c2 there's rookie
three played rook h3 champion oh my
lance and that's move 60.
that is tragic for fabiano i mean just
every single game in the second half of
this tournament there have been moments
like this where he looks like he's on
the verge of saving something or he's
been better and then
i don't know king c4 yeah we'll see
three actually we'll bring it up here
king c4 trying to go for this pawn broke
while keeping this pawn same sounds rook
h4 the king has to slide back to protect
the knight and then there's move c4
check if the king takes the pawn you
lose the knight on e4 the king slides to
the side and then there's a move rook h3
check and this is
getting bad here king d2 king d5
king d2 or a3 no a3 is much simpler
because rook a7 a king oh my i see we're
gonna do and now king d5 i mean any just
white just busted yeah you get this pawn
here because the knight cannot be
defended once the knight moves c3
is
lost here so fabiano carwana has made a
fatal error right at the time patrol
this is what happens in chess sometimes
when you
only have
you're waning seconds for a last move
but as fabiano tries to figure out how
he can possibly save the ruins of his
position we are going to play an
interview with team java after his win
today
timur congratulations on your win the
final game uh how important is it to
finish on a positive note i don't know
it's hard to say i mean it was a good
game of tired people
and
yeah it was quite fighting in general
with richard is always like this i mean
it's
always something sacrificed always
streaks and so on
but
certainly i was expecting uh that today
there will be a fight so uh
yeah i was just fine but of course i
didn't feel comfortable with this king
attack you know like all the time knight
g5 all the rooks and the four is coming
and it's like such a mess and uh i don't
know if i played well there but at least
i didn't see the direct
threats from his side but certainly it's
pleasant to finish on a good note
indeed there was this moment you could
have played bishop takes c4 instead of
taking the knight on g5 immediately did
you consider this line
yeah but
i mean i spent way too much time there
like uh i don't know why because if he
wanted to take on d6 he could take
instead of knight g5 just 96 cd and then
95 so yeah that was kind of strange uh
you know to take time there but i was
not sure if i have to take the knight or
not yeah and so finally it proved to be
i think better than i that i didn't
because i mean
um
after taking the knight i saw that there
are a lot of threats like the queen h3
is coming rook h5 is coming all the time
and the bishop is somehow controlling
the the squares
so uh
yeah i think that was the right decision
not to exchange it but it took me a lot
of time to realize that it's possible in
general what is going to be let's say
the first thing you will do once you get
back home
everybody will sleep whatever they're
answering but
in general just want to
get all this you know all of these
preparations all of these things uh off
my head because it's like so many
berlins i've looked uh in last few weeks
it's like uh unbelievable i mean i i
have worse games in berlin i have best
games in berlin already i think for
after these two tournaments i think it's
enough for two different books so good
games in berlin and bad games in berlin
yeah and uh
so many times you know i've um
i've been going through the end game and
nobody won the end game and it's like
some months spent on the end game just
went for nothing
and
yeah just getting all of this you know
all of these informations all of this
ideas all of this preparation of
my head of course first of all and uh
just trying to recover right then let me
wish you to recover well and uh see you
back soon on on the chessboard thank you
very much
sorry from timor java who finished in
third place ahead of vikkar nakamura by
thai breaks and that was a very happy
timor who won three games in the second
half he has every reason to be happy
this is a tremendous success
on
really the biggest stage in the world
after
you know a start that was frustrating
that
led many people to pat themselves in the
back and congratulate themselves and say
yeah i told you you know teamwork
doesn't belong in this tournament
and look where he is now seven and a
half points out of 14 in this field
third place
amazing just an amazing amazing
performance by the most experienced
player in the field
and then while we still have one game in
progress i think that's uh next to
incentive in this game for lyra zafurz
is that he simply doesn't want to finish
last and if he wins this game uh he will
overlap
young sister of duda and richard report
right and that would be big probably for
his future his confidence and
well
bob no carwana he's trying to survive
this one as much already as a frugal
trying to get out of the cellar of the
tournament standings and we're gonna
bring up the prizes for you all because
now that we know who has won the
tournament that's yonder palm tree he
takes 48 000 euros second place dingley
wren
third place was timur rajabov taking
home 24 000 euros he
took that prize ahead of hikar nakamura
despite the two
tying for third by points so with every
half point earning 3 500 euros it's
quite a hefty payday for some of these
players and
we just have one game left that will
determine all of the final standings
we have ali raza furuja
he's gonna try to get another 7 000
euros if he wins this game and he is
going to get 7000 years because at this
point it is the result of the game is
not in question he's got several
options that lead to very quick victory
knight e4 as you said was the fatal
error that knight
is just impotent it's on the worst
possible square
it the black king is totally
invulnerable here the bishop covers it
very nicely
and now either a3 or king d5 both
essentially force resignation because
the c3 pawn
in the latter case is lost and in the
former case essentially everything
collapses at the same time there is one
line that i think we should show here
because uh if you push upon a three
sometimes you push that a little bit too
far and alareza
he's got his hands that he's thinking
rook a7 and if you think you can play
king d5 to get this knight like wait a
second i'm gonna get both of your pawns
i'm gonna take on c5 of course you're
gonna take me back and then you realize
that black doesn't just have to take
this back bishop takes c3 is check the
king moves over and then black has
bishop d4 protecting this pawn pinning
this knight and winning this night and
thus the game
great line and all yours that he did go
for the other move king d5 straight away
to which
i was gonna say magnus caruana
responding it's been a long day with
knight f2
and
a little bit of finesse still
required it actually might be most
prudent not to take on c3 but instead to
go for rook h2 with a3 to fall i
actually think that wins on the spot
because the king probably has to move
over otherwise the rook can't get over
to a7 you need to protect the knight and
if you move your king pretty much
anywhere
well then you can push this a pawn and
the rook can't move because the knight's
hanging so if we switch to king e2
then this pawn on c3 is lost and then
the bishop comes back to d4 and bye bye
to this knight
what a collapse by fabby i mean
this is far from a perfect game but ali
reza is going to be so happy at the
closing ceremony to have scored that
last one of the black pieces
from a position in which
i honestly thought was just a two result
game when fab you got that knight to e4
it was unfathomable to me that black
the black can win this game and the
entire campaign started with d4 i think
that's
what led very quickly to fabby's
downfall i i cannot understand
any of what he did
in like the next ten moves starting at
the
yeah in the moment you're showing in the
analysis board to get started
g3 was that was an ominous sign yeah it
was an ominous sign maybe unnecessary
but then the decision to open up the
center
you know removing the support of that
monster knight
was
just unthinkable yeah just showing the
knight on the lights because all the
pawns and light squares the bishop can't
do anything the pawn e5 is isolated and
a future target so
to play g3 and then d4 and open up the
position that was a pretty big mistake
and then we see that as the game
continued you
black start scooping up pieces five
minutes still had a chance at a draw he
went wrong at move 60 and we're being
informed that yon napomshi is active on
social media he let everybody know his
team of seconds so maybe i can read
those names because a lot of them are in
russian so it's vitigolf lecco hi
rolling and podkin and tomaszewski
so
actually vitigo and leko and hyulin were
present in madrid
and podkin and tomaszewski helped janja
pomneshi from distance
oh gosh that's a really great team of
seconds five of them
most players you know they feel
fortunate to get one or two seconds
without five seconds uh to help you out
and it's very important that somewhere
madrid somewhere elsewhere because you
as seconds you want to work around the
clock and a single person can't work 24
hours a day they need to sleep but it's
very common that when you have a team of
seconds some people are elsewhere some
people come with you to lend the
emotional support to help you on site
and then when you sleep the player and
the second on site the people who are
elsewhere they work and that way it's 24
hours i actually know how important it
is because
when lauren was helping magnus during
their first matches that he was working
from home and then we had to move the
crib you know for our little daughter to
the living room then he had to work
during uh
he had night shifts all the time so i
think this model works much better for
the seconds and for the families
yeah
it really takes a village i think that's
what this shows
and you know amira mentions the work
around the clock that's not an
exaggeration
because sleep always comes second if
there's a line that's unresolved
if there is a move
you know in the petrov that jan doesn't
know what to play against that
work takes place until a solution is
resolved whether that takes
five hours or or 15 hours nobody sleeps
until you know the top opening
priorities are solved in preparation for
the next game it takes tremendous
sacrifice ding
mentioned sacrifice
and during a tournament like this all of
the second sacrifice
their netflix time
family time their sports time their
sleep time
eating time everything is done in
service of
finding the right opening ideas
and making sure that the player
who whom they're working for is in the
right frame of mind and confident in
preparation for the next game and
sometimes you know
seconds are prominent names as players
peter lecko played for a world chess
championship he also works with vincent
keimer who is
one of the absolute premier talents uh
as a teenager from germany and then
sometimes people like who's that person
i don't know that name they're not 2700
yeah are they qualified to work for
something yeah but that's not what it's
all about right sometimes uh people
choose their seconds based on friendship
and trust other times like this person
plays this opening in a way that i would
like to learn from them so just because
somebody isn't playing in the candidates
themselves doesn't mean they're not a
capable second and you know victor goff
is a top player nobody's disputing that
uh but one names there was
uh was it kariolin
yeah yeah who is a fantastic player also
around the same age as yonda pomshy so
i'm sure they've been friends for a long
time and there's that trust and karilyn
as a grandmaster a very strong player
himself that actually helps right the
whole is greater than the sum of its
parts sometimes
yeah and i think you can see a very
direct parallel in
sports coaches i mean i'm most familiar
with basketball but if you look at
basketball coaches they're not all
you know players on the level of michael
jordan lebron james some of them are
right but others like you know long time
coach of the san antonio spurs greg
popovich
was you know i don't think he played in
the nba i mean he played in college he
played in europe he's a very capable
player you could compare him to like a
2500 right he knows what he's doing on
the court
but
it's not all about how
well you play when you're a second like
you said the trust factor that's
priceless how you analyze how you use
chess engines
how creative you are when you've got you
know unlimited time essentially to find
opening ideas so he's got vichygav he's
got tomaszewski 2700s but he's also got
people who whom he trusts
uh who know him as a person who can
sometimes tell him the right things
after a tough game and who can generate
game-winning ideas day after day
and the world championship experience
that peter lecko had is invaluable peter
like almost won the world championship
yeah right
vladimir krumnick was on the verge of
losing his title that he won against
gary kasparov and unfortunately for
peter didn't go his way he's a
phenomenal commentator a great human
being still a fantastic chess player but
that kind of experience you can't
replicate that you just have to have it
and so for yon
in his second candidates you know he
wins in a row and i don't think it's
just a coincidence that peter lecko is
part of the team and all the others as
well right vitsugov giving great
preparation we mentioned that he played
the position from the white side that
jan was playing from the black side so
that really helps when you can test it
out over the board and uh work on those
openings and someone like bitsy yougov
obviously super super strong as are the
other players that
seconds that jan works with so
fabiano rook takes c3 super strong
player in his own right not having a
super strong second half he's down two
pawns here and
it is feeling like all hope is lost and
the youngster the french iranian player
with the black pieces he's gonna win his
first game ever
against five minute car one and i think
that is so important because if somebody
keeps piling on where if this went from
uh three wins for fobby to four wins and
none for already you get in your own
head you're like i just can't do it
against this guy he beats me every
single game and now that ali reza and
the candidates of all places is gonna
take him down i think that will really
help him in their head-to-head matchups
going forward i think it's also going to
help him uh for his career
and the way he
will think about
preparing
for these tournaments
and
once again he needs to win this game in
order not to be lost in this tournament
and and one last attempt by fabiano
let's hope that my opponent blunders
rook takes e5 which removes the guard of
the rook on c3 already
moves his rook away to g3 knight d3 rook
takes d3 i think is critical oh my
goodness we'll show that right now
because knight d3 looks like it just
goes ahead and wins a piece but after
knight d3 dania is saying rook takes d3
with check the king takes after a3
the you think rook f2 stops the pawn and
it does for the moment but i go c4 check
and where's your king going can't go
here
if you go here uh-oh that's a skewer
thank you very much for your rook if you
go to the second rank somewhere like c2
d2 e2 doesn't matter there goes the pawn
and the best you can do is give up your
rook for the pawn and with the bishop
and the c pawn remaining black wins
easily
just the way earlier is sitting you can
tell that he's calculated that that's
actually what he was spending his time
on i think
after rook takes c3
that's it because if fabi doesn't play
knight d3 then a3 follows the pawn is
unstoppable
and the game is finally over what a
heartbreak for fabi
a tournament that's gonna be hard to
process
it just doesn't add up that he had five
out of seven it was like two different
people participated in this tournament
and
a great win for alireza just a
confidence booster a rating saver
and uh
one of the black pieces in the last
round is always a pleasant feeling no
matter how poorly you might have played
throughout the tournament as a whole
just everything possible that could go
wrong went wrong for fabiano yeah he
lost his first game in the second half
to his compatriot hikara nakamura then
he has a great position against yonder
palm she can't win that then he loses a
couple games in a row and
you know
you can just look at him right this is
not the five minute caruana who's
sitting upright with great posture ready
to
play a very intense game he there he
resigns the last game of the candidate
so the candidates is officially over and
alireza farouja scores his first victory
over fabiana carwana who understandably
is dejected doesn't want to look at
chess anymore i'm sure for the time
being and he just gets out of the
playing hall and he can't believe what's
happened here in the palacio de santonia
and when you have a tournament result
like this i'm always curious to see
the players next tournament in fabiano's
case how will he bounce back he'll be
angry he'll be motivated
he'll want to make the following
candidates but that's out of the
conversation for now because
this candidate has only just finished
but fabiana's tournament docket is
always full and always full of
opportunities to rebound in a big way he
will be representing the united states
uh during the olympiad and this is going
to be a big chance for fabi to redeem
himself to rebuild his confidence and to
show that fabiano caron at his best is a
force to be reckoned with it's very
difficult after such a big tournament in
your life
when all just falls apart right when it
rains it pours
how do you just move on that's the
question and it's
not an easy one to figure out well it's
not easy that i feel that it's sort of a
tragic love affair you know something is
broken inside fabiano
and uh well
ding was talking about sacrifices i can
only imagine how many sacrifices
fabiano has made in order to achieve
uh all these tournament successes and
play world championship match so
and for a while i mean you know his
results especially after the world
championship match also were um quite
unstable so we were talking how about uh
how stable he was in the first uh leg of
this tournament and then everything went
wrong yeah and it's hard to see i mean
fabiano's a universally well-liked
player of course he is very humble and
you know gives interviews even when he's
struggling but you can just tell them
the body language it's like not again
and at some point there's just nothing
you can do that's going to get out of
hand but he does have a few weeks to get
this term out of his head the
upcoming olympiad starts at the end of
july so favino will take part for team
usa and yeah he went wrong i mean we can
show everybody once more where after
surviving what was a bad position out of
the opening he was in great shape but
two times in this game it was with the
knight on e4 so the 94 early on was an
awesome piece but the knight on e4 late
in the game uh he made this move to make
the time patrol and then immediately he
was lost
yeah very symbolic
and fabi's probably not going to
miss that symbolism but it was an
essentially unlosable position
great job by ali reza to stay in the
game
he wasn't flawless he gave fabby chances
he had that immediate win right before
the time control taking on f4 with the
bishop he missed that but he kept his
foot on the gospel he made it difficult
at all times for fabiano and his play
right before move 60 really did fabiana
in and that last challenge is one that
he couldn't solve properly that's right
so both americans lose in the final
round here
in madrid at the 2022 feet of candidates
but ikaru nakamura another player who is
beloved he
talked to dina bill and kaya for several
minutes and here is that interview
hikaru thanks for joining uh that was a
tough game do you think ding's opening
choice
was justified
no of course not i mean but the problem
is that i didn't trade the rooks on d1
if i go rook d1 or d1 or d8 i mean the
game is drawn within like half an hour
and it's i mean
that's it but the problem is that after
h4 h6 rook c1 i mean it still should be
fine but already i was very upset at
myself and then i just played some moves
that i think weren't um weren't great it
still i think was probably okay but
i mean to to my opponent's credit he
found found some good moves kept the
game going um but i mean i still think
even around move 40 i was fine until i
played this insane f3 move i mean we'd
reach time control and then i i blitzed
uh knight e5 and f3 out for no no
particular reason um and yeah i i mean
ding found this this great idea i think
was this bishop e7 and so forth but
yeah it's i mean very uh very
unfortunate but i guess luck goes goes
uh you know look what comes around goes
around you know probably got a little
bit lucky yesterday um to win and then
yeah today i mean i just yeah it's
insane there were indeed several moments
you could uh equalize for instance
instead of bishop d8 uh did you consider
rook d8
yeah rook t yeah i mean i thought about
rook d8 also but i mean this this end
game it takes and bishop d6 feels kind
of unpleasant i mean i think it's
probably okay also i mean probably
everything is okay objectively but
you know it's still not so not so easy
to um to play um yeah i mean i of course
i should have gone for this i like i
said there are many different moments
but simply i think i was just you know i
was a little bit on on tilt or a little
bit un unsure of myself uh after after i
mean i had to play with bishop d697 so i
mean this it came down to like one one
critical moment really uh and yeah i
just couldn't couldn't find stuff after
that and the one more moment that was uh
pretty interesting when ding played e4
you had an idea of f3
did you see that one yeah i know i mean
i i again like i said i felt like there
were many possibilities and i had enough
time but i was just moving too fast i
mean i just couldn't couldn't control
myself um and i think that was true
probably for most of the game
uh after after i played this bishop d697
i just wasn't using my time correctly
and that was in large parts i was you
know just not not very happy with what
was going on throughout the game um
yeah i mean after it was one move but
like i said even i think towards the end
if i don't play f3 check if i just play
knight c4 i think i also probably saved
this game quite comfortably but you know
that's that's how it goes long game
obviously everybody's tired and um
that's it's unfortunate but i mean
it happens
well willing to conclude um your journey
so far you're the biggest chess streamer
in the history
you're as you call yourself a retired
professional chess player and yet you
almost came second uh how do you rate
your performance overall
yeah my performance was good i think um
problem is i just yeah i couldn't
control my nerves and my emotions today
and um it ruined what could have been a
very good tournament um
but uh yeah still to be on plus one gain
some rating points is always a positive
so yeah i mean it's just it's
unfortunate uh to end to end the
tournament this way but again i mean if
you told me before the tournament i
would finish on a plus score i would
have been very happy so yeah that's how
it goes
well perhaps one last question where
will you see you streaming again
oh i mean i'll probably stream tomorrow
um uh that that'll be a better way to uh
to enjoy things i mean that is the one
upside i mean i was probably starting to
enjoy playing too much and now i can
actually go back to
uh go back to something that's that's
more fun than this um i mean obviously
i'm not happy after today but i'll
stream tomorrow and yeah i'll play chess
again sometime but it won't be anytime
soon that's for sure well thank you so
much once again and then see you
tomorrow yeah all right
we heard hikaru nakamura he zoomed out
so at first he talked about how upset he
was he felt nervous and that
impacted him in today's game but then he
grounded himself he said if the
tournament at the start tournament you
told me i would finish plus one gain
some rating points i would take that
sounds like a good result so i mean a
bad day at the office and i guess even
the most popular twitch streamer for
chess can be impacted by nerves that's
no surprise but in the second half look
at that it was a couple wins to start
sandwich that loss there then a win in a
loss down
the final two so he was very combative
elmira well he was very competitive and
this last interview also made me think
about the way japanese they
view beauty and because i love japanese
aesthetics very much so there's uh an
aesthetic concept uh when you see
everything through imperfection and also
that the things are ephemeral and
those things are beautiful and he
covered expressed exactly this you know
during this interview while you know he
was uh well he played his best chess but
it wasn't perfect and you know this
tournament will pass as well but it
doesn't change who he is and the way he
sees things and well
so well i like this very much
yeah don it's a sad way for him to
conclude the tournament but it was in
fact a great tournament for macaroni
yeah i mean the phrase you pointed out
really says it all
you know
he's going to focus on the positives
he's plus one he gains rating
he
anybody who thought that you know
hikar's streaming career in any way
derailed his ability to play classical
chess
this is the stage to prove those people
wrong and he did and the last round
doesn't change that with that said
he is going to have that sour taste in
his mouth for a while he's going to
thinking he's going to be thinking about
what if what if i played rook t what if
i had come in second what if magnus had
declined the world championship match
but
obviously that will remain behind the
scenes nonetheless it was a great
performance by hicara had a lot of fun
looking at his games
and he's going to remember some of those
lovely wins such as the gaming ali reza
and that monster game against fabiano
which he won time and time again so on
balance great performance
and he's going to have his head
up high and you could tell how much he
loves chess and well yonda pompsie is
loving chess at the moment because he
finished in clear first place one and a
half points ahead of dingley wren nine
and a half points a record in the modern
candidates nine after 14 zero losses and
just an absolutely stunning performance
from jan
yeah what a what a what a clean clean
tournament and as i said yesterday to
win such a tournament you need to
demonstrate mastering every single area
openings tactics and games defense
attack initiative
name a skill
and yonda pandushi was a model
of that skill in this tournament so the
score says it all you know i don't need
to add anything but
it has been a treat to cover his games
in the 2022 candidates and elmira six
out of 14 doesn't sound that bad if
you're out to raise a frugia after
scoring that last round win well it
doesn't sound doesn't sound bad at all
but what i wanted to point out is that
have a look at the standings uh those
players who had already previous
candidates experience are on the top of
the standings but our well wannabes one
of the baby sharks there well they
finished
last you have earlier israel you have
young sister buddha and richard report
on the bottom of the standings that's a
very very good point you know i i didn't
even think about that but you're right
the newcomers all at the bottom here
yana pomshi he was a newcomer last time
he won so a first timer can still win
the whole thing but you're right that
the people without experience they
struggle in this one but there's a lot
of prize money at stake so as we see
here yonda pomshi winning 114
500 euros with a nine and a half score
and
that's a very handsome payday and his
payday will only grow when he plays his
world championship match
yeah i mean very well deserved and uh
you know as you said there's a a major
asterisk that comes after the 114 plus
rights to play the world championship or
he will receive probably on the order of
at least
a million dollars and i don't think
anybody begrudges him that because his
play in this tournament showed that he
is indeed very deserving of the
opportunity to avenge his loss in the
previous world championship match
i just can't get over that five in a car
want to finish in fifth place
he was five out of seven he finished
with six now one and a half out of seven
in the second half i just it's really
hard to look at this graphic and think
is that a mistake what's going on here
but no fabiano caruana somehow finishes
in the bottom half this is the first
candidates where he's ever finished
when i look at these prizes i i can't
help but notice that recently there have
there has been such a change in the
chess paradigm where streamers probably
earn more money and i read an interview
which was given by hikar and he said
that he's actually losing money by
playing in this tournament and that that
was such a surprise to me well we know
historically chess doesn't have so much
money in it i mean a lot of these
tournaments that grand masters trying to
win you know a couple thousand dollars
and they draw their last game they get
you know maybe a couple hundred or
something so uh
takara makes a lot of money i guess is a
a good way of summing it up but the
prizes here were good and the players
they earned every single penny they got
and the big question now that we know
that yonder palm she's the winner of the
candace is who will he face this graphic
it says it all magnus carlsen has the
right of first refusal because he is the
world champion it's up to him and if not
magnus dingley wren almirah he seemed
pretty excited at the prospects of
playing a world championship match
well i think he is very excited excited
that prospects are playing at all so he
will take anything
oh he will be given any tournament and
donya we know what happened the last
time jan and magnus played what would
you make of a potential yonder palm
shield dingley red matchup well it's a
fascinating one tingly wren we've
established is one of the toughest
opponents for magnus carlsen by
extension he's one of the toughest
opponents for anybody else including
gandapamishi
i think jan he's got only one way to go
and that is to wait until the deadline
he's not going to start preparing until
he finds out who he is playing but i'm
sure that he is ready to take on the
challenge whether it's dinglerand or
magnus carlson who will be sitting on
the opposite end of the world
championship table well july 20th was
the date that emil sutasti gave us in
terms of when magnus will have to make
his decision but happening far before
that date is the upcoming blitz champs
tournament you will not want to miss
this hall of fame receiver larry
fitzgerald all pro linebacker micah
parsons new cleveland browns receiver
amari cooper top five pick k von
thibodeaux and more will take part in
this charity event with a hundred
thousand dollars in prize money at stake
july 9th and 10th 1 pm pacific right
here on chess.com
well it is that time we have to wrap it
up but before we begin to wrap things up
i'm told we have a surprise for donya
and myself so well a surprise what okay
yeah well let's see it so i think that
took me a second right and final
thoughts right after
oh goodness is the idea e takes f4 e5
and then knight gf3
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my only report
can play such a move oh
my goodness
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh
goodness oh my goodness that's an idea
to watch out for oh my land
oh my lands oh my land yes my lands this
position is terrible oh my gosh oh gosh
oh gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh
there oh gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
[Music]
amazing that was awesome i loved that
that was a lot of fun
that was excellent just highlights the
incredible work that our production team
does it really takes a village to win
the candidates it also takes a village
to produce the candidates and we are the
recipients and the beneficiaries of the
best production team in the world we
certainly are and as we start to head
out we want to give some big thank yous
to our friends at fide atrevia our
chess.com broadcast and events team and
of course our chess.com broadcast team
spread across 11 languages including
spanish they were doing it live here at
the palacio de centonia also big thank
you to the city and people of madrid for
their hospitality hospitality i can't
even speak it's been such a long event
and that is how much i've appreciated
all the people of madrid so that
concludes our coverage of the 2022
candidate tournament from madrid for
elmira from donya for myself thanks to
the chat as well all of our miss amigos
hanging out for spending these three
weeks with us and being so engaged
we leave you with the best moments from
our last day here in madrid good night
and we will see you soon
teamwork
[Laughter]
he's playing an instrument on his nose
there ding doesn't strike me as a first
move troll i think it is in fact one d4
both players betraying a smile but those
smiles will be quickly wiped off of
their faces dude in an
uncharacteristically good mood so good
mood all around as the last round begins
we would not be happy
if magnus skips it we also don't believe
that the world champion can just say you
know
it would be this this way or i don't
play so when
is his deadline i would say july 20 is
about the time when when we will have a
decision miss amigos
one two three miss amigos
look at the top left there whoa richard
report everybody
that is perhaps the game's most creative
player he just pushed his pawn to g5
dingley wren you know he pushes pawn h5
and that's how you beat these super
strong players you force them to make a
decision the game between ali raza
farouja and five minute carwana that one
is getting spicier it is checkmate
whichever way you go that's a beautiful
construction using each minor piece and
the rook to keep the king trapped yikes
and it's a nervous situation both these
two players they seem nervous elmira you
know they feel a lot of pressure well we
were thinking that this is going to be
richard's masterpiece but obviously the
canvas it's totally different now
feature chats coming in a lot of people
saying ding has this a lot of dingley
rent fans out there teamwork drop of
story is going to go down as in many
ways one of the most impressive
candidates performances could revive his
career nobody thought that java was
getting a plus score in the tournament
what a second half fabiano's last 10
moves what is he doing
he's
what is happening black has this inner
mezzo fabi definitely missed this and if
furuja sees it he wins the game what a
big last round win for ding who is going
to hold his head up high even if he
doesn't get to play beyond the pawn
issue who would you just theoretically
prefer to face
kikaru ding or magnus
let's wait until the tournament is over
but
of course i seek for revenge
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss amigos